THINK WHAT WE HAVE PEOPLE WILL
BE TRICKLING IN.
THAT I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND AND NOW
SOMETIMES IT HAPPENS WITH
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THAT THERE'S
MORE OF YOU OUT THERE THAN THERE
ARE OF US UP HERE.
PICKING YOU CAN BE SURE THOUGH
THAT IS GOING TO BE.
AB A LOT OF PEOPLE PEOPLE
WATCHING IF NOT HERE THEN FROM
HOME AND FROM OTHER OFFICES.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT HOW THE WATER FIX.
GOOD HERE SEEMS TO BLOOM
APPROACHING.
AND WHICH THERE'S PROJECT HAS
RAISED AT THE LOT OF CONTROVERSY
AND AND SO I HOPE WE ARE WHICH
MAKES FOR A GOOD DISCUSSION
TODAY.
SERVICE PEOPLE KNOW I REPRESENT
THE DELTA AREA AND AND ON THE
WATER FIX AND AND THE BUT.
BEFORE THAT. TWIN TUNNELS AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S COME BEFORE OF
MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE HAD A LOT
OF CONCERN ABOUT.
AND AN FOR THE REST THE STATE
WHAT IS IT MEAN FOR THE STATE
WHAT WILL IT MEAN FOR RATEPAYERS.
AND TODAY'S HEARING AS WE ALL
KNOW IS ESPECIALLY TIGHT TIMELY
AS WE KNOW.
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT BUT
LAST MONTH AUTHORIZED.
TEN BILLION FOR THIS PROJECT
AND YESTERDAY SANTA CLARA A
THREAT IN THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN STALLED
OFF AND ON SINCE LAST SEPTEMBER
OVER THIS PROJECT IF IT'S COMING
TOGETHER NOW THAT I THINK WE
HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN FRONT
OF US ABOUT THE POSSIBLE.
IMPACTS AND NEXT STEPS.
M. WE DIDN'T AUDIT LAST YEAR.
AND FOUND SOME YOU KNOW
SOMETHING'S OR PRIEST ARE LIKE
THE FINANCIAL ANNOUNCES HAD NOT
BEEN DONE THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS HAD NOT BEEN DONE TO
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN DONE.
WE'RE STILL NOT SURE OF EXACT
COSTS.
WE'RE NOT SURE OF EXACT FUNDING.
NOW WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT
WILDLIFE FISH.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW SEX AND
EXPERTS HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
VIEWS ON THIS.
.
IF WE LOOK AT MEGA PROJECTS
AROUND THE WORLD WE KNOW THAT.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
ON PALM ALMOST ALMOST WITHOUT
DOUBT THEY GO OVER BUDGET BY
HALF SOMETIMES BY THREE TIMES
WHAT THEY WASN'T INITIALLY
ESTIMATED SO THEN SO THEN THE
QUESTION BECOMES WILL AND WHO
WILL PAY FOR ALL OF THAT. WHO
WILL MANAGE ALL OF THAT WILL
RATE PAYERS BE ON THE HOOK A AND
IS BEEN ESTABLISHED MULTIPLE
TIMES?
THAT THIS PROJECT WILL NOT
CREATE ONE EXTRA DROP OF WATER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS I CAN
SEE BEFORE US TODAY AS WE GO
FORWARD.
AND SO WE HAVING A JOINT HERE
TODAY BETWEEN AND THAT.
OVER OVERSIGHT.
WITH THEM THE BUDGET DEALS WITH
THIS AREA AS WELL AS THE WATER.
AND COMMITTEE AND SALAS TOGETHER
I HOPE WE'LL BE ABLE A VERY
FRUITFUL DISCUSSION. ARM AND
FLIPPED CALLED AND FIRST PANEL
I'D LIKE TO.
MISTER BLOOM IF YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE SOME. OPENING COMMENTS
TAKING CARE EGGMAN.
AND THANK YOU.
SO WE TRY TO GET.
ONE MORE TIME.
HOW'S THIS ONE OVER HERE.
RIGHT.
WAIT.
IT IS IT'S WORKING NOW OUT RIGHT
WE GOT IT.
A WELL.
THANK YOU CARE EGGMAN.
BECAUSE SAID THAT THREE TIMES
ALREADY.
IT'S GOOD TO BE HERE AND TO.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE HAVING ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND I
WANTED TO.
FOR STATE MY APPRECIATION FOR
THIS HEARING COMING TOGETHER AT
ALL I THINK IS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THAT TO A WE REALLY
NEED TO BE TAKING INTO AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THE BUDGET FOR THIS PROJECT
ACTUALLY PASSES OUTSIDE OF OF
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THREE SO WE
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGETARY
OVERSIGHT OVER. A A PROJECT LIKE
ALL THIS IS TO ME IS SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO THE SCALE OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL OVER WHICH BY
SUBCOMMITTEE DOES HAVE OVERSIGHT.
SO WE WANT ONE ISSUE I THINK WE
NEED TO.
A GRAPPLE WITH IS WHERE IS THE
OVERSIGHT CAN TAKE PLACE ON ON A.
ON THIS PROJECT HAS A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT GIVEN ITS
SIZE.
THE INTO. I CAN SAY THAT AS THE
CHAIR OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE I SEE FIRSTHAND THE COST
OF OPERATING AND MAINTAINING OUR
CURRENT WATER DELIVERY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE DELICATE
BALANCE BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND WATER RELIABILITY
IS THAT CLIMATE CONTINUES TO
TREND TOWARD THE EXTREMES AND TO
ALL THE SCIENCE POINTS IN THAT
DIRECTION. THIS BOUNCES FURTHER
STRAINED.
AND WITH COSTS INCREASING AT THE
SAME TIME I LOOK FOR TO OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY AND GETTING AN
UPDATE ON THIS PROPOSED PROJECT.
THANK YOU AND I THINK WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST PANEL
NUMBER ONE.
WHICH IS CARL AT NEIMAN
DIRECTOR OF IDW ARE.
GARY LIP NERD DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE DELTA CONVEYANCE.
I LEAN SO BACK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. AND DIANNE RIDDLE
ASSISTANT DID DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DIVISION DUMP WATER RIGHTS.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE SUM OF.
OKAY.
.
EXCUSE ME WELL THANK YOU.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
UPDATES ON THE CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX AND.
ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEES.
AS I'M SURE YOU ARE AWARE THERE
HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS ACTIVITIES
OCCURRING IN PARALLEL ON THE
ENGINEERING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
THE GOVERNMENTAL AND FINANCIAL
FRIENDS OF THE PROJECT. OF THIS
MORNING I WANT TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH SOME UPDATES.
RELATING TO ALL THOSE TOPICS
AND I'LL HOPEFULLY ANSWER SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
I WOULD EMPHASIZE ALSO.
I'M ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON THIS PROJECT IT IS
VERY COMPLICATED.
AND YOU SHOULD CONSIDER MY DOOR
OPEN.
TO YOUR STAFFS OR ANY QUESTIONS
MOVING FORWARD.
I LET ME FIRST TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT REGARDING.
WHAT HAS BROUGHT US TO THIS
CURRENT SITUATION?
WITH REGARD TO THE DELTA
ECOSYSTEM WATER SUPPLIES IN THE
WATER FIX PROJECT.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT THAT MOVES WATER
THROUGH THE DELTA WAS COMPLETED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY.
BEFORE COMPUTERISED MODELING A
FLOWS.
A BEFORE THE STATE AND FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS SUCH AS
SEQUEL AND NEPA AND THE STATE
FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
THAT GUIDE CURRENT OPERATIONS.
AND WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF SIX
DECADES OF PROGRESS IN
UNDERSTANDING THE RISK OF
EARTHQUAKES CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SEA LEVEL RISE.
TO FIFTY EIGHT YEARS LATER I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DISAGREEMENT THAT THIS EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FACES DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES UNLESS CHANGES ARE
MADE.
WATER FIX IS ESSENTIALLY AN
UPGRADE TO THIS NINETEEN SIXTIES
ERA INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IT WILL
IMPROVE THE RELIABILITY OF WATER
SUPPLIES FOR TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND THREE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND. AND
ALSO RESTORE MORE NATURAL FLOW
PATTERN A IN THE SOUTH DELTA.
WATER FIXES IN IT IS IN ADDITION
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND
WILL BE OWNED AND OPERATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE WATER.
WATER RESOURCES IN THE SAME
MANNER THAT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT HAS BEEN ARE OPERATED
AND MANAGED
A BY THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES.
WATER FIX WOULD ADD THREE NEW
INTAKES FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WITH STATE OF THE ART
FISH SCREENS TO THE NORTH DELTA
AWAY FROM SENSITIVE FISH HABITAT.
THIS WILL PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO
OPERATE THE STATE WATER PROJECT
USING EITHER THE NORTH OR SOUTH
FACILITIES TO LESSEN IMPACTS ON
FISH.
WILL PROVIDE OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS THE U. S. BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION THE ABILITY TO
OPERATE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT WITH THAT SAME
FLEXIBILITY.
THE PROJECT WOULD MOVE A MAXIMUM
OF NINE THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
SECOND. THROUGH TWO TUNNELS AND
IT WILL BE OPERATED TO COMPLY
WITH EXISTING STATE WATER
PROJECT CONTRACTS. AS WELL AS
PERMITTED FLOW CRITERIA TO MEET
BOTH FISHERY IN WATER QUALITY
NEEDS.
ONE OF THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED DESCRIBES SOME
RECENT DESIGN BY MINTS THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED OVER MANY YEARS
OF STUDY.
RESULTING IN A SMALLER PROJECT
FOR PRINT AND FEWER IMPACTS TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
ON THIS TYPE OF OPTIMIZATION HAS
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PART OF OUR EFFORTS AS WE WORK
TO REACH FINAL DESIGN.
I DO WANNA ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT THIS PROJECT DOES HAVE
TREMENDOUS PHYSICAL IMPACT ON
DELTA COMMUNITIES THERE'S JUST
ABSOLUTELY. NO WAY AROUND THAT
AND.
IT IS OUR DESIRE AND I'LL
DESCRIBE. IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL AT IN A MOMENT A IS OUR
DESIRE THAT THE DEPARTMENT WORKS
INTENSIVELY WITH OTHER
CONSTRUCTION A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. TO AYE ABLY.
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS AS
REQUIRED BY LAW.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF WATER FIX HAS
BEEN VERY COMPLEX
IT'S TAKEN YEARS OF PLANNING
STUDY AND COLLABORATION TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
OTHER WATER FIX IS A PROJECT
THAT WILL ADDRESS ECOSYSTEM
CONCERNS WHILE SECURING THIS
CRITICAL WATER SUPPLY FOR
CALIFORNIA IN FULFILLMENT OF THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIRECTIVE OF THE
DELTA REFORM ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WHICH WAS TO IMPROVE WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OF THE DELTA.
ULTIMATELY THE REASON FOR WATER
FIX ITSELF IS NOT PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX
OUR CURRENT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE TELLS
US THAT WE CAN EXPECT FLASHER
STORM EVENTS. AND LONGER PERIODS
OF DROUGHT IN THE FUTURE.
SUCH CHANGES IN PRECIPITATION
WILL IMPACT BOTH OF THOSE DELTA
REFORM ACT GOALS.
WHAT WATER FIX WILL DO IS
INCREASE CLIMATE RESILIENCY BY
ALLOWING THE EFFICIENT MOVEMENT
OF WATER THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND
INTO STORAGE WHEN THAT WATER IS
AVAILABLE AND GREATLY REDUCE
IMPACTS ON SPECIES?
IT WILL DO THIS A IN THE PART OF
THE DELTA THAT IS MUCH LESS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE EFFECTS OF
SEA LEVEL RISE. AND GREATER
WATER QUALITY FLUCTUATIONS THAT
WE CAN EXPECT WITH THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
BY EFFICIENTLY AND SAFELY MOVING
WATER THROUGH THE DELTA WHEN
IT'S AVAILABLE. WE BELIEVE WATER
FIX STRENGTHENS THE STATE'S
EXISTING PORTFOLIO OF WATER
SUSTAINABILITY INITIATIVES
WATER FIX IS JUST ONE OF MANY
PRIORITIES INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S WATER ACTION PLAN.
AND THIS PLAN INTEGRATES THE
MANY WATER SUPPLY TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL INCLUDING RENEWED
EMPHASIS ON WATER CONSERVATION.
WATER FIX IS THE BEST WAY TO
HELP REGIONAL WATER MANAGERS
PURSUE THOSE PORTFOLIO OPTIONS
AND MAXIMIZE LOCAL INNOVATION
AND RESILIENCY.
REGARDING LOCAL GROUND WATER
BASINS AS WELL AS NEW STORAGE
WILL REQUIRE RELIABLE SURFACE
WATER SUPPLY.
RECYCLING PROGRAMS BENEFIT FROM
THE CLEANER ORIGINAL SUPPLY THAT
DELTA WATER WOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE WITH WATER FIX.
INSTABILITY OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST SOURCE OF RELIABLE WATER
WOULD MAKE INVESTMENT IN EACH OF
THESE OTHER WATER SUPPLY AREAS.
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
AND WHILE WATER CONSERVATION
RECYCLING DESALINATION AND
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ARE
VITAL COMPONENTS OF THE
PORTFOLIO. FOR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL WATER MANAGERS THEY
SIMPLY DON'T PROVIDE ENOUGH
WATER TO REPLACE SUPPLIES
CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY THE STATE
AND FEDERAL SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF AN UPGRADE.
MANY REGIONS IN THE STATE
HEAVILY RELY ON DELTA CONVEYED
WATER PRINCIPALLY PARTS OF THE
BAY AREA CENTRAL VALLEY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THERE WATER PLANNERS PREDICT
DECLINING RELIABILITY OF THESE
SUPPLIES EVEN WITH INVESTMENTS
IN CONSERVATION RECYCLING
GROUNDWATER DESALINATION
STRATEGIES.
THEY ARE ALSO PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN PURSUING AND
PROTECTING THE MOST AFFORDABLE
SUPPLIES FOR THEIR RATE PAYERS.
AFTER ELEVEN YEARS OF ANALYSIS
DIALOGUE IN SCIENTIFIC INQUIRY
WATER FIX REMAINS THE BEST
APPROACH TO COMPLY WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
THAT PROTECT SPECIES HABITAT IN
WATER QUALITY. WHILE SECURING A
CONTINUED RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER SUPPLY.
THE COST OF THE PROJECT IS.
FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S INTO A
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S FOR CONSTRUCTION
MITIGATION.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS ESTIMATE INCLUDES A CONCERT
OR A CONSERVATIVE THIRD.
CONSTRUCTION CONTINGENCY.
MEANING WE HAVE ADDED THIRTY SIX
PERCENT TO THE COST DOES A SAFE
BUT FOR ACCOUNTING FOR THE MOST
CURRENT EVALUATION OF RISKS
INVOLVED WITH TUNNELING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS TYPE.
THE ESTIMATE ITSELF IS ALSO
CONSERVATIVE WE HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT ESTIMATES FROM THREE
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY EXPERTS THAT
ARE USING THREE DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY STANDARD AND RISK
ADJUSTED METHODS. WE ARE USING
THE HIGHEST OF THE THREE.
WE ARE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
UPDATING OUR ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
OF THIS UPDATE WILL PROVIDE A
BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS FOR THE NO
PHONE NINE THOUSAND CUBIC FEET
PER SECOND PROJECT.
AS AN UPDATE OUR EARLIER WORK
WHICH WAS AN AGGREGATE OF
BENEFITS AND COSTS THIS PROJECT
WILL LOOK SEPARATELY AT
DIFFERENT GROUPS WITHIN THE
STATE WATER PROJECT AS WELL AS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT. WE
EXPECT TO FINALIZE THIS UPDATED
REPORT BY THE END OF THIS MONTH.
THE DEPARTMENT IS OF VERY
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES COLLABORATING ON
COST ALLOCATION FINANCING FOR
WATER FIX.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY DRIVING THIS
IMPORTANT WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT FORWARD AND WE SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS.
SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF WATER FIX
WILL BE PAID FOR BY THE STATE
WATER PROJECT BENEFICIARIES OF
THIS PROJECT.
ALTHOUGH THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT HAS VOTED TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE REMAINING
THIRTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
PROGRAM WE DO EXPECT THAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
CONTRACTORS WILL PARTICIPATE.
ZONE SEVEN WATER AGENCY IN
EASTERN ALAMEDA COUNTY VOTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. METROPOLITAN
VOTED APRIL TENTH TO INVEST TEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE PROJECT AND AS YOU NOTED
JUST YESTERDAY SANTA CLARA. OF
VOTED TO INVEST SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
PROJECT A KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY IS SCHEDULED TO VOTE ON
MAY TWENTY FOURTH. THERE ARE
OTHER STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
WHICH I'M SURE MISS PEER WELL
DESCRIBE FOR YOU WHO ARE ALSO OF
WEIGHING THE THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROJECT AND AND MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR INVESTMENT.
A NEW JOINT.
POWERS AUTHORITY A TO DRESS
FINANCE IS EXPECTED TO BE FORMED
BY SOME OF THE PARTICIPATING
WATER AGENCIES. TO COVER THE
INITIAL STAGES OF IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL D. W. ARE ISSUES BONDS.
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES WE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY ARE CURRENTLY
TO ISSUE THOSE BONDS WE ARE
SEEKING VALIDATION IN THE COURTS.
IN THE FINANCE JPA WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO COVER THE FINANCING
FOR THE PROJECT IN THESE INITIAL
STAGES UNTIL HAVE VALIDATION
OCCURS.
I WATER FIX.
WE BELIEVE IS AN EFFECTIVE
IMPRUDENT AND OVERDUE
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADE.
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA RELEASED A STATEWIDE
OPINION SURVEY IN MARCH
FUNDING THAT SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS SAY THE
PROJECT IS IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE'S FUTURE QUALITY OF LIFE
AND ECONOMIC VITALITY.
IN ADDITION SCIENTISTS FROM THE
CENTER OF WATERSHED SCIENCES AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS.
FOUND THAT THE ORIGINAL
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX OPTIONS
SEEMS TO DEAL BEST WITH THE
FUTURE CHANGES TO THE DELTA AND
SEEMS MOST LIKELY TO KEEP DELTA
SMELT. SALMON AND OTHER
DESIRABLE FISHES AS PART OF THE
DELTA ECOSYSTEM
ESPECIALLY IF IN ASSOCIATION
WITH EXPANSION OF ECO RESTORE.
WHY THE PROGRAM PROGRAM ITSELF
IS COMPLEX
A PROMINENT PUBLIC AN EMINENT
FISHERY EXPERTS SEE IT AS A
NECESSARY UNVIABLE PATH FORWARD?
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE SEVERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED AND PERMITS
HAVE BEEN OBTAINED.
WE HAVE OUR SEQUENT NOTICE OF
DETERMINATION ARE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT PERMIT
FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
AS WELL AS BIOLOGICAL PIT
OPINIONS ISSUED BY THE FEDERAL
AT AGENCIES WE HAVE SEVERAL THAT
LIE AHEAD OF COURSE ONE IS THE
CHANGE PETITION AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AS WELL AS A CONSISTENCY
CERTIFICATION FROM THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
FINALIZING A SUPPLEMENTAL.
<c.green> IR TO ADDRESS</c>
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE DESIGN AND
DECREASED IMPACTS TO WETLANDS
SALMON AND SMELL.
OF PARTICULAR INTEREST I SUSPECT.
I MAY BE THE STEPS THAT WE ARE
TAKING ON GOVERNANCE AND PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT.
I WITH THE FINAL PERMITTING ON
THE HORIZON A IMPLEMENTATION IS
IMMINENT. AND TO EMBARK N THIS
IMPORTANT NEXT STEP D. W. R. IS
ADJUSTING ITS ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE TO ENSURE AN EFFICIENT.
AND EFFECTIVE CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM THAT PROTECTS THE STATE
INTEREST BY MANAGING RISKS AND
CONTROLLING COSTS.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE OFFICE AND APPOINTED
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR GARY LAETTNER
OF WHO'S HERE WITH ME TODAY. AND
THROUGH THIS CONVEYANCE OFFICE
AND UNDER GARY'S MANAGEMENT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL RETAIN
ITS AUTHORITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
WATER FIX REGULATORY OBLIGATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION AND
QUALITY CONTROL. THIS OFFICE
WILL OVERSEE THE WORK OF THE
SOON TO BE FORMED A DELTA
CONVEYANCE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. OF ALSO FOR SHORT
CALLED THE D. C. A.. A WHICH
WILL BE A PUBLIC AGENCY CHARGED
BY GW ARE WITH THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF WATER FIX
FACILITIES.
THE STATE'S OVERSIGHT ROLE.
WILL BE DESCRIBED IN A JOINT
EXERCISE
OF POWER AGREEMENT A WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION JPA.
OUR ROLE BE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS DELIVERED ON TIME AND
ON BUDGET. INSURE THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION JPA TAKES EFFECTIVE
STEPS TO SAFELY DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCT THE PROJECT WITH INDY
W. OUR SPECIFICATIONS WHILE
PRUDENTLY MANAGING THAT RISK.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL APPROVE
SPECIFICATIONS APPROVED MATERIAL
CHANGES ANNUAL BUDGETS AND
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH OF THE J.
EPA AGREEMENT.
ONCE THE FACILITY IS BUILT.
THE CONSTRUCTION JPA WILL
DISSOLVE THE FACILITY WILL BE
TURNED OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT AS
THE OWNER AND OPERATOR OF THAT
FACILITY.
UP THERE ARE THREE POTENTIALLY
FOUR MAIN INGREDIENT AGREEMENTS
AND TOTAL THAT WILL ALLOW THIS
OVERALL GOVERNMENT STE AND
FINANCING A MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE
TO WORK.
THERE ARE LIKELY TO NEW GPA IS
AS I MENTIONED ONE FOR THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION ONE FOUR
OF THE FINANCING OF THE PROJECT.
AS WELL AS THE POTENTIAL FOR A
FINANCE GPA A SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON THE THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. OF THE PROJECT THAT.
METROPOLITAN HAS AGREED TO A TO
FINANCE.
THEY'RE ALSO AS I MENTIONED BE
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN OUR
DEPARTMENT AND THE CONSTRUCTION
JP.
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION WATER
FIX
THIS AGREEMENT IS ESSENTIALLY
THE LEGAL MECHANISM THAT
DELEGATES THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROGRAM TO
THE GPA. A FINAL COPY OF THAT
AGREEMENT WILL BE PUBLISHED ON
OUR WEBSITE ONCE IT'S FINAL.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD
A FEDERAL PARK.
TOWARDS FINAL PERMITS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE STATE WATER PROJECT
CONTRACTORS AND FEDERAL WATER
PROJECT CONTRACTORS.
TO DELIVER THE PROJECT.
.
WITH THAT OF I THINK ALL PAUSE
AND.
.
MOVED TO THE REMAINDER OF THE
PANEL OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
AS YOU SEE FIT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I THINK WE HAVE A POLL THE
PRESENTATIONS VERSANT QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR.
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE ON.
THAT'S THIS JOINT HEARING TODAY
MY NAME IS EILEEN SO BACK I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF. THE
RESEARCH IS CONTROL BOARD. AND
WE ARE HERE TODAY I AM HERE
TODAY WITH ANTI AND LITTLE OF
OUR DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU
AND.
AN OVERVIEW OF THE STATE WATER
PORTS ROLE IN AND WATER FIX I'M
ATTRACTED NAY MATHIS TOUCHED
UPON IT AND I'M JUST GOING TO
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT BUT THE SUBSTANCE THE
PROCESS.
THE DEGREE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THAT'S AVAILABLE
AND.
.
THE THE TIME TABLE SO JUST TO.
TO TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THEM
THE MISSION OF THE WATER PORTS
AND WHY WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS.
I'D THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD'S AND REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
MISSION IS TO PRESERVE ENHANCE
AND RESTORE THE QUALITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RESOURCES
INCLUDING DRINKING WATER.
FOR THE PROTECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALL BENEFICIAL USES. AND TO
ENSURE PROPER WATER.
RESOURCE ALLOCATION AND
EFFICIENT USE FOR THE BENEFIT OF
PRESENT AND FUTURE GENERATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT REGARD
TO ITS WATER RIGHTS
RESPONSIBILITIES WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS CHARGED
WITH ADMINISTERING THE STATE'S
WATER RIGHT SYSTEM TO ENSURE.
THAT ANYONE WHO TAKES WATER FROM
A LAKE RIVER STREAM OR CREEK.
FIRST HAS A LEGAL RIGHT TO TAKE
THE WATER.
AND USE IT IN A WAY THAT IS NOT
WASTE FULLER AND REASONABLE AND
SECOND THAT THEY DO SO IN A
MANNER THAT DOES NOT ADVERSELY
AFFECT MORE SENIOR WATER RIGHTS
HOLDERS. OR UNREASONABLY IMPACT
THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WITH RESPECT TO OF WATER FIX
ON THE STATE BOARD HAS TWO MAJOR
CHARGES US TOUCHED UPON BY
CONTRACTOR NEMETH. FIRST TIME
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND THE US BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION. HAVE PETITIONED THE
BOARD TO ADD THREE NEW POINTS ON
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER WHERE THEY
ARE I'M.
ARE AUTHORIZED TO DIVERT AND
TAKE WATER UNDER THEIR WATER
RIGHTS FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT.
FOR THE PROPOSAL.
TO GO FORWARD IT WOULD. REQUIRE
THE APPROVAL BY THE BOARD OF
WATER RIGHT CHANGE ON A PETITION.
FOR THE STATE BOARD TO APPROVE
THE STE THE CHANGES
A TIME THAT DOES THAT HAVE BEEN
ASKED FOR BY THE BUREAU AND D.
WR. THE BOARD MUST FIND TIME.
THREE THINGS THAT THE CHANGES
DON'T CONSTITUTE A NEW WATER
RIGHT OR ENERGY OR INJURE ANY
OTHER WATER RIGHT TIME LEGAL YOU
ANY.
OTHER LEGAL USER OF WATER.
SECOND THAT THE CHANGES WILL NOT
RESULT IN UNREASONABLE IMPACTS
TO FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND THIRD THAT THE CHANGES ARE
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
SO DEPENDING ON ITS FINDINGS THE
BOARD CAN EITHER AUTHORIZED THE
CHANGES AS PROPOSED.
AUTHORIZED THE CHANGES WITH
ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THE CHANGES MEET THE
CRITERIA THAT I JUST STATED OR
DENY THE PROPOSED CHANGES.
THE BOARD ON IF THE BOARD
APPROVES THE CHANGES ON IN THE
POINTS OF DIVERSION AS REQUESTED
TIME THE STATE WATER BOARD IS
ALSO REQUIRED. BY THE DELTA
REFORM ACT TO PUT THE TO A
INCLUDE APPROPRIATE DELTA FLOW
CRITERIA.
AND I AM AS A CONDITION OF
APPROVAL SO THESE APPROPRIATE
DATA FLOW CRITERIA WOULD TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT FISH AND WILDLIFE
NEEDS AND OTHER COMPETING
BENEFICIAL USES OF WATER.
THE FOCUS CRITERIA WOULD BE
INTRON UNTIL THE STATE WATER
BOARD COMPLETES ITS CURRENT
PROCESS TO UPDATE AND IMPLEMENT
THE BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY.
CONTROL PLANTS FLOW REQUIREMENTS.
THE SECOND MAJOR ELEMENT OF THE
BOARD'S CONSIDERATION OF THE
WATER FIX PROJECT
I'M IS THAT THE PROJECT WILL
REQUIRE A PERMIT FROM THE U. S.
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
AND AS PART OF THE CORE PERMIT
THE STATE WATER BOARD MUST ISSUE
A CERTIFICATION UNDER FOUR
SECTION FOR A ONE OF THE CLEAN
WATER ACT.
WHICH.
WHICH WILL ARTICULATE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT WATER QUALITY.
THE CORE IS REQUIRED TO INCLUDE
THE STATE WATER BOARD SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS INTO ANY PERMIT
THAT IT AUTHORIZES.
I'M.
FINALLY I WOULD I WOULD NOTE
THAT TIME THE STATE WATER BOARD
IS A RESPONSIBLE AND PARTY UNDER
THE FOR FOR THE WATER FIX UNDER
THE UNDERSEA QUOTA. AND THAT'S
SUCH THE STATE WATER BOARD MUST
CONSIDER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECTS OF THE PROJECT DISCLOSED
IN THE INNER. ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT PREPARED BY DIP DE
WR. BEFORE DECIDING WHETHER AND
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS TO ISSUE
TIME NECESSARY APPROVALS FOR THE
PROJECT.
SO NOW GOING INTO A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THE PROCESS AND THE
TIMING.
AND THE BOARD THE STATE WATER
BOARD IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF CONDUCTING AN
ADJUDICATIVE HEARING ON THE
WATER FIX WATER RIGHT CHANGED
MISSION.
DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S I SAID TO
APPROVE THE PROJECT AND IF SO
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS.
OTHER RECORD FOR THE HEARING
WILL ALSO INFORM THE WATER
QUALITY CERTIFICATION.
I'M THE BOARD HEARING ON WATER
FIX IS GOVERNED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
WHICH INCLUDES PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE FELT A FAIR PROCEEDING
AND DUE PROCESS FOR THE
PARTICIPANTS.
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO PRINT
TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE CROSS
EXAMINE OTHER WITNESSES.
AND PRESENT REBUTTAL AT EVIDENCE.
PURSUANT TO THE APA THE STATE
WATER BOARD MEMBERS ARE SUBJECT
TO A PROHIBITION ON X. PARTY.
OFF THE RECORD A COMMUNICATIONS
CONCERNING SUBSTANTIVE OR
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES IN THE
PROCEEDING.
AND THEY CAN ONLY CONSIDER
INFORMATION THAT IS PART OF THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD IN
MAKING THEIR DECISION ON THE
CHANGE PETITION.
THE STATE WATER BOARD BEGAN ITS
PROCESS IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN DE WR AND
RECLAMATION SUBMITTED THE TIME
WATER RIGHT CHANGE PETITION.
I'M ANDY W. ARE SUBMITTED ITS
APPLICATION FOR A WATER QUALITY
CERTIFICATION FOR THE WATER FIX
PROJECT.
THE BOARD HAS DIVIDED ITS
HEARING PROCESS INTO TWO PARTS.
THE FIRST PART WAS FOCUSED ON
IMPACTS
TO OTHER LEGAL USERS OF WATER
AND THE SECOND PART FOCUSED ON
FISH AND WILDLIFE INCLUDE AND.
INCLUDED APPROPRIATE BUT.
AT DELTA FLOW CRITERIA.
THE FIRST PART OF THE I'M
HEARING IS COMPLETE.
THE SECOND PART OF THE HEARING
IS IN PROGRESS. AYE WE ARE UP
JUST ABOUT TO MOVE INTO THE
REBUTTAL.
PORTION OF THAT PROCESS.
THE SCHEDULE FOR COMPLETING THE
HEARING I WILL DEPEND ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE EVOLVED DURING
FACE UP PART TWO AND WHILE I'M.
AND INCLUDING I'M SOME
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTATION THAT TWR AND
RECLAMATION. ARE COMPLETING FOR
THE PROJECT AND OTHER ISSUES WE
ARE MOVING AS EXPEDITIOUSLY ON
AS WE CAN.
AFTER THE HEARING IS COMPLETE.
OF THE BOARD WILL ISSUE A
WRITTEN DRAFT DECISION ON THE
WATER RIGHT CHANGE PETITION.
I'M THE DRAFT ORDER WILL EXPLAIN
THE FACTUAL AND LEGAL BASIS FOR
THE DECISION AND WILL BE BASED
AS I SAID EXCLUSIVELY ON THE
EVIDENCE IN THE RECORD. ON.
THAT'S BEEN VETTED THROUGH THE
HEARING PROCESS.
THE DRAFT ORDER WILL BE RELEASED
TO THE PUBLIC FOR COMMENT AND
REVIEW PRIOR TO CONSIDERATION BY
THE BOARD AT A PUBLIC HEARING
FOR ADOPTION.
UP FOLLOWING THE COMPLETION OF
THAT HEARING AYE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WILL MAKING A
DECISION ON THE APPLICATION FOR
THE WATER QUALITY CERTIFICATION.
I'M IN THE WATER AT A QUALITY
CERTIFICATION DECISION WILL ALSO
BE BASED ON THE HEARING THE
RECORD OF THE HEARING PLUS.
OTHER ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
BOTH THE DECISION ON THE WATER
RIGHT CHANGE PETITION DECISION
MADE BY THE BOARD AND THE WATER
QUALITY CERTIFICATION DECISION
MADE BY THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
ARE SUBJECT TO RECONSIDERATION
BY THIS THE STATE. WATER BOARD.
THERE HAVE BEEN AND ARE NUMEROUS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC PART
A PATIENT DURING THE BOARDS
WATER FIX DECISION MAKING
PROCESS.
BOB THE STATE WATER BOARD AND
GOT.
D. W. ARE PROVIDED BROAD PUBLIC
NOTICE OF PROPOSED WATER RATE
CHANGES IN WATER QUALITY.
CERTIFICATION AND THE ASSOCIATED
HEARING PROCESS TO OTHER WATER
USERS IN THE WATERSHED AND. AND
ALL M. OTHER OF SUCH A
INTERESTED. I'M AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND INTERESTED
PARTIES.
ON AND ON.
AND NOTIFY THEM AND LET THEM
KNOW HOW AND WHEN AND IN WHAT
WAY THEY COULD BE INVOLVED IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS. ON
IN OUR FORMAL HEARING PROCESS WE
HAVE OVER SEVENTY FIVE PARTIES
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY GOVERNMENT. AGENCIES
AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
I'M IN AND AS I SAID IN THE
EVIDENTIARY A FORMAL PART.
PROCESS.
UPDATE THAT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN PRESENTING THEIR THEIR
AFFIRMATIVE CASES CROSS
EXAMINING WITNESSES PER.
PRESENTING EVIDENCE.
I THOUGHT WE WE'VE ALSO HAD OVER
TWO HUNDRED OTHER PARTIES THAT
HAVE TIME ENTERED POLICY
STATEMENTS BEFORE THE BOARD PER
ANNUM. ADEQUATE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION.
THE HEARING PROCESS IS FULLY
TRANSPARENT
THE HEARING ITSELF IS OPEN TO
EVERYONE IT IS WEB CAST ON A
DAILY BASIS. IN REAL TIME AND
IT'S RECORDED AND THE VIDEO IS
AVAILABLE I'M AT OUR WEBSITE.
GENERALLY SPEAKING ALSO MIDDLE
AND CORRESPONDENCE MUST BE SENT
TO ALL PARTIES WHO ARE ABLE TO
MAKE UP OBJECTIONS MOTIONS.
AND RESPOND ORALLY OR IN WRITING
TO THEM TO HEARINGS PARTIES AND
CAN WRIST CAN SIGN UP AND
RECEIVE EMAIL UPDATES ON
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON AND
ALL OF ALL OF THE INFORMATION
AND SUBMITTALS ARE POSTED ON. ON
OUR WEBSITE.
NOT SO WITH THAT AND I WILL AND
I THINK IT PROVIDED A A ROADMAP
TO TO WHERE WE'RE GOING AND WHAT
WE'RE CONSIDERING AND WE ARE
AVAILABLE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU'RE LISTENING.
OKAY HAS IT FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS.
OKAY WELL AND AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL FOR COMING HERE AND AND I
KNOW YOU YOU ARE YOU ARE DOING
YOUR JOBS AND AND NOT REPORTING.
.
YOU CAN TALK ALL WE TALK ABOUT
THE THE PUBLIC PROCESS IN AND
THE PERMITTING PROCESS CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SO SINCE
HIS PROJECTS BEEN. AT GOING FOR
IT IT IT JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
CHANGES OF IT'S GOING TO BE.
WHERE THE INTAKES ARE THERE'S
TWO TUNNELS THERE IS ONE TITLE
THERE'S A?
A PROCESS OF TUNNELS AND NOW
NOW WE'RE BACK TO TWO TUNNELS SO
HAS THAT IS YOUR.
.
HEARINGS BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH ALL THE CHANGES IN ANDWHAT
EXACTLY ARE YOU LOOKING AT NOW.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THE PETITION
THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD AT THAT SUSTAIN
RENTAL AND WITH THE STATE WATER
BOARD. AND SO WE'RE LOOKING UP
THE PETITION THAT WAS SUBMITTED
WE CONSIDER THAT PETITION UNTIL
D. W. R. OR THE BUREAU ACTUALLY
MODIFY THEIR PETITION WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT ANYTHING IN ADDITION
TO WHAT THEY ACTUALLY SUBMITTED.
AS FAR AS THE TUNNEL LIMA ISSUES
GO WILL CONSIDER WHAT NEXT STEPS
TO TAKE WITH THE HEARING. AFTER
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTATION
AND FOR THOSE CHANGES TO THE
ALIGNMENT COME OUT SO THERE WILL
BE A. LIKELY SOME ADDITIONAL
PROCESS IN THE HEARING RELATED
TO THOSE ISSUES.
AND YOU TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
THE PUBLIC PROCESS IN THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ON AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT GOING INTO.
YOU KNOW I'M A MASSIVE JPA
BETWEEN AND JAY A JP BETWEEN
CONTRACTORS INTO W. ARE WHERE IS
THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN AND
PROCESS AND THERE.
BUT I DON'T I DON'T HAVE THE THE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION ON THE PORT
SIDE OF THE HOUSE IT'S IN OUR UP
REGULATORY.
.
A REGULATORY PROCESS REGARDING
THE THE WATER RIGHT CHANGE
PETITION AND THE HOME FOR ONE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WITH
RESPECT TO. THE ACTUAL ACTION
FORMATION AND ACTIONS TIME OF
THE GPL TO FOR TO EMPTY WR. OR
ANYTHING AND I WOULD ADD TO SO.
AS WELL AS WELL TALKING ABOUT. I
MEAN ME JUST.
I'M FROM THE COUNTRY BUT BUT I
KNOW WHO WHO PAYS MORE GENERALLY
TENDS TO HAVE A BIGGER ST THANKS
ON WHENEVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SOMEBODY INVESTING MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND THEN WHEN
YOU SAYING.
OTHER AGENCIES WILL BE INVOLVED
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WILL COME THROUGH
METROPOLITAN BEING ABLE TO HAVE
LARGE AMOUNTS OF WATER THAT THEY
CAN THEN SELL TO OTHER
CONTRACTORS AND THEN THEREBY BE
ABLE TO. HOW PART OF THAT FUNDED
SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
THIS THIS JP THAT THAT THE
CONTRACTORS WILL YOU KNOW BE BE
PAYING FOR PART OF IT BUT TO
DOUBLE OUR OWN IT. THEN IT
BRINGS BACK TO THINKING ABOUT
THE DEBT THAT YOU KNOW ORVILLE
AND THE DAMS AND. CONTRACTORS
AGAIN BEING ON YOU KNOW BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT. D. W. ARE
MANAGING THAT AND CLEARLY WE SAW
SOME SOME ISSUES WITH THAT AND
WE KNOW THOSE ISSUES ARE ON
GOING. SO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT AS
YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
ANOTHER MASSIVE.
MULTIPLE.
JP HAYES WITH PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS.
AND THE STATE.
WHAT IS A PUBLIC PROCESS FOR
THAT
AND?
CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
SURE CHET AND THAT THESE ARE
ALREADY ON.
IN EFFECT WE HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE GETTING READY TO SIGN
TODAY OR TOMORROW.
AND CERTAINLY NOBODY SITTING UP
HERE HAS HEARD ABOUT. THAT ST
ENGAGING IN A IN A GPA WITH
OTHERS OR I GUESS MISTER BLOOM
SAID ANY KIND OF OVERSIGHT.
OR ANY KIND OF PUBLIC PROCESS
IN THAT SO CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT SURE.
BEEN THE STATE.
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE.
WATER CONTRACTORS NEARLY A YEAR
AGO.
HAD BEEN DISCUSSING THE
POTENTIAL FOR.
ENTERING INTO A NEW KIND OF
ARRANGEMENT FOR PROJECT DELIVERY
OF A PROJECT THE SIZE.
AND.
LAST SUMMER I BELIEVE IN JULY.
AS PART OF OUR WATER FIX
COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT DISCUSSED THE.
CONTENTS OF A JPA OR THE
RELATIONSHIP OF THE DATE OF THE
JPA AND HAS HAD THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW OF COURSE. ARE AND WHAT
HAPPENED THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THE FALL IS.
THE WATER CONTRACTORS
THEMSELVES NEEDED TO GO TO THEIR
BOARDS OF DIRECTORS AND HAVE.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
IN THEIR PUBLIC SETTING.
ABOUT THEIR FINANCIAL INTEREST
IN THE PROJECT AND WHETHER OR
NOT.
IT WAS GONNA PENCIL OUT FOR
THEM.
AND AS YOU POINTED OUT DIE IN
YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THAT CONVERSATION WENT ON ALL
THROUGHOUT THE FALL A WE HAD A
MAJOR.
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
CONTRACTOR OPT NOT TO
PARTICIPATE.
ON THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION FELT
THAT IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT AFTER.
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS SPENT ON PLANNING COSTS
THAT OTHER STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS GO AHEAD AND.
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH THEIR
BOARDS AND INDICATE THEIR
INTEREST BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT HAS LED US TO THE
SERIES OF VOTES THAT WE ARE NOW
IN A WITH THOSE WATER BOARDS.
AND CERTAINLY LEAD TO A.
RENEWED INTEREST IF YOU WILL
AND.
AND ARRANGING FOR THE
FORMALIZATION OF THIS JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY SO.
IT REALLY WASN'T UNTIL PARTIES
WERE SURE THAT THEY WANTED TO.
ACTUALLY INVEST IN THE PROJECT
AND THAT WE COULD DEFINE THE
PROJECT AS YOU POINTED OUT MORE
CONCRETELY.
IN KEEPING WITH OUR OUR
PETITION IN FRONT OF THE WATER
BOARD THAT.
THE CONVERSATION AROUND A JPA
BECAME.
MUCH MORE TANGIBLE SO.
SO A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE IS.
THE STATE THROUGH ITS.
EXERCISE OF A A JOINT EXERCISE
OF POWER WITH THE JPA WILL HAVE
AN IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT MECHANISM
AND ALL THE CONSTRUCTION
STANDARDS UP MAKING SURE THAT
RISK IS MANAGED APPROPRIATELY.
WE CERTAINLY AGREE THAT.
PROJECTS OF THE SCALE.
HAVE A TRACK RECORD FOR GOING
OVER BUDGET SOMETIMES
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER BUDGET.
WE BELIEVED THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR.
DIDN'T SEE IS.
.
IT IS IS LARGE AND REFLECTIVE OF
SOME OF THE RISKS IN A TUNNELING
PROJECTS WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON TUNNEL PROJECTS OF A
COMPARABLE NATURE.
TO ARRIVE AT THAT.
THIRTY SIX PERCENT CONTINGENCY.
SO WE BELIEVE WE'RE DOING.
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF PRE PLANNING.
TO HELP US FROM THE BEGINNING
ON CONTROL COSTS IN AND MANAGE
RISKS.
THE. CALIFORNIA WATER
COMMISSION OF DOES HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN OVERSEEING.
THE FACILITY OF THE STATE WATER
PARK THE FACILITIES OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT NOT LONG AGO WE'VE.
PRESENTED TO THEM THE
DEPARTMENT'S IDEAS ON ASSET
MANAGEMENT.
THEY'VE HAD A PRESENTATION ON
OF THE OROVILLE A SITUATION AND
WHAT NEEDS TO.
WHAT IT NEEDS TO OCCUR?
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT PART OF
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS
OPERATED TO MAXIMUM PUBLIC
SAFETY.
SO THAT IS A AN OPPORTUNITY I
THINK AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
FOR TRANSPARENT AND AND.
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT.
THE JPA ITSELF A IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES WILL IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
THE PUBLIC ESPECIALLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES TO INTERACT DIRECTLY
WITH THE JPA PARTICULARLY ON ON
DESIGN ISSUES WHICH ARE GOING TO
BE A MATTER OF.
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF.
.
OF CERTIFYING OUR CONSISTENCY
WITH THE DELTA PLAN THERE'S
IMPORTANT DELTA AS PLACE KINDS
OF REQUIREMENTS THERE.
THAT WILL BE SPELLED OUT.
IN IN THAT SETTING AS WELL.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES WILL BE IMPLEMENTING A
WILL BE HELPING THE A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY TO.
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THOSE
MECHANISMS AND I PROVIDE FOR A
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT.
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND.
AND PROVIDE INPUT INTO THE
DESIGN.
BUT BUT I MEAN I APPRECIATE. THE
REITERATION DID THAT. IT IS CAN
WE TALK ABOUT DELTA'S PLACE THAT
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE DELTA WHO WHO WHO
TRUST THE PROJECT.
AND SO THAT THAT REMAINS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE ESPECIALLY AS
YOU KNOW AS AS I. AS I AS I SIT
IN THAT IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THE.
THE WAY THAT CHANGES HAVE
OCCURRED DON'T MAKE ANYBODY FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND THE THE IDEA OF.
THIS MASSIVE GPA WITH SO MANY
UNKNOWNS.
LEAVES A LOT OF PEOPLE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE AND I THINK IT
SHOULD LEAVE EVERY LAWMAKER
SITTING UP HERE.
WHO HAS TO WORRY ABOUT AND EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERRUNS I
CAN TELL YOU AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE PUBLIC LOOKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO?
MANAGE THE STATE'S MONEY AND
MANAGE THE STATE'S RESOURCES IN
AN APPROPRIATE FASHION.
RUSSIANS WERE ANYONE ELSE.
PHONE.
UP THE SURLY REPRESENTING A
COMMUNITY AND KERN COUNTY SOUTH
OF DELTA AND TO WHAT EXTENT ARE
WE. NOT PUMPING WATER FROM
EXISTING FACILITIES AT MAXIMUM
CAPACITY BECAUSE OF THE BALLOTS
COMPANIONS SO PRESUME THAT CAL
ARE TOUGHER Y. FACES.
AND BUILD A DOZEN ABOUT LIKE
DON'T DON'T WE STILL HAVE THE BY
BY THOSE BIOLOGICAL PAINS AS
WELL SO WHAT ASSURANCES DO WE
HAVE THAT MORE WATER IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO.
THE DEBATE.
SO I'M WE DO HAVE TO ABIDE BY
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS AND OF
COURSE WATER FIX HAS ITS OWN SET
OF BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THAT.
STIPULATE WHEN.
WE CAN MOVE WATER IN CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK.
SIR THAT. TO ME THE MOST KIND A
TANGIBLE EXAMPLE OF.
A PRETTY COMPLICATED SYSTEM.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE PROJECT IN TERMS OF WATER
SUPPLIES IS.
IN.
JANUARY FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN YOU ALL RECALL WE WERE
SOMEWHAT EMERGING FROM A DROUGHT
WE HAD.
SEVERAL A FLASHY STORMS MOVING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
AND IN THAT PERIOD WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO MOVE OUT WATER BECAUSE
OF THE INHERENT CONFLICT.
BETWEEN.
SPECIES DOWN IN THE SOUTH DELTA
AND AND THE LOCATION OF THOSE
PUMPS SO ONCE SPECIES ARE
DETECTED IN A IN THE VICINITY
THAT'S WHEN.
THE PROJECT OPERATORS STARTED
TO TURN DOWN THE PUMPING
CAPACITY. IN THAT TWO MONTH
PERIOD.
HAD THE TUNNELS BEEN ONLINE WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THE PROTECTIVE CRITERIA IN THE
SOUTH DELTA.
USE THE NORTH DELTA DO
DIVERSIONS AND MOVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE DURING A TIME OF YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE SO MUCH WATER
MOVING THROUGH THE SYSTEM. THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
OUTFLOW REQUIREMENTS TO MEET
BECAUSE AGAIN THESE ARE LARGE
STORM EVENTS THERE'S A LOT OF
WATER MOVING THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
TO ME THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THE PROJECT FOR
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY OVER
TIME AS FOLKS HAVE POINTED OUT.
OVERALL THIS PROJECT DOES NOT
HIDE GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF QUOTE UNQUOTE NEW
WATER BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS IT
PROVIDES THE FLEXIBILITY. SO
THAT IN THE FUTURE WHEN WE HAVE
LARGE STORM EVENTS WE CAN MOVE
THAT WATER IN A WAY THAT SAFER
FOR FISH.
AND WE CAN STORE IT.
IN LOCAL SERVICE AREAS OR IN
STATE RESERVOIRS OF FOR USE
DURING.
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE TO BE LONGER
DROUGHT PERIODS?
SO.
IN TERMS OF SO IN TERMS OF JUST
NUMBERS AND YOU YOU INDICATED
THAT JUST EXAMPLE FROM JANUARY
FABRICS Y. SIXTEEN YOU PUT YOU
ESTIMATE THAT FOR EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET WOULD BE
MOVED.
WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN MOVED MORE
INCENTIVE AT GO OUT?
TWO OTHER FACILITY ONLY OUT TO
THE OCEAN CORRECT CORRECT WITH.
EXISTED WITH IMPROVEMENTS TO
SPECIES PROTECTIONS IN THE SOUTH
DELTA
AND IN A WAY THAT'S SAFE FOR
FISH I WITH THE OPERATION OF OF
THE NEW.
INTAKES.
AND JUST THAT MY CURIOSITY.
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF WATERS
THAT WE HAVE NOW WHY ARE WE NOT
PUMPING AND AND TO A LARGE
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW OR HIGHER
CAPACITY.
WELL WE HAVE THESE INHERENT
CONFLICTS OF WHEN WE HAVE SPENT
AS I MENTIONED WHEN WE HAVE
FISHERIES. A IN THE VICINITY OF
THE PUMPS IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO.
TO OPERATE THOSE PUMPS WITHOUT.
OF HARMING THEM UNDER THAT THE
DEFINITION OF A OF STATE FEDERAL
LAWS IN OUR CONDITIONS ARE
CONDITIONS FOR THOSE PERMITS.
THERE ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
QUALITY.
.
CONTROLS IN THE DELTA THAT ALSO
DETERMINE WHEN WE CAN I MOVE
WATER OUT OF THOSE PUMPS IN THE
SOUTH DELTA.
THE PUMPS IN THE SOUTH DELTA
ACTUALLY DRAW WATER INTO THE
SYSTEM FRESH WATER INTO THE
SYSTEM THAT AND A MORE NATURAL
SYSTEM IN ALL LIKELIHOOD
WOULDN'T BE THERE BUT THERE ARE
A LOT OF BENEFICIAL USES THAT
HAVE. GENERATED AROUND THAT THE
HOT NAMELY A LOT OF OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN THE DELTA SO
THOSE WATER QUALITY RESTRICTIONS
ARE ALSO.
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY ON THE
CURRENT OPERATIONS OF THE
PROJECTS THAT.
UP PREVENT THE DIVERSION OF OF
MORE WATER. THE.
OTHERS SAY THAT ENDED UP BECAUSE
CERTAINLY THAT THE.
PRO THE BENEFITS OF THE CAL
WATER FIX IF THE ESTIMATES ARE
CORRECT IS THAT WE DO ARE WE ARE
MOVING MORE WATER. I THINK THE
CHALLENGES ARE THAT IF WE DON'T
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE PUMPING AND
WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY PUMPING.
BECAUSE.
OF VARIOUS REASONS AND WE BUILT
A FACILITY THAT IS A PUMPING
WATER AND THEN THAT'S THAT'S MY
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE
NOT MOVING WATER AND OUT
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED WATER ARE
GETTING.
AND IF I COULD JUST.
THE FOLLOW UP BECAUSE SO IT IS
USED IN ESSENCE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS IS. GOING TO SPEND.
SEVENTEEN BILLION POTENTIALLY A
WHOLE LOT MORE OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO CAPTURE SOME WATER DURING
TIMES OF STORM. ARM AND AND THEN
WHEN YOU SEE CAN EITHER USE IT
AND AND RESERVOIRS BUT IT CAN
ALSO BE BANKED HEAT TO SELL
LATER CORRECT.
SO A STORM WATER COULD THEN BE
UNDERGROUND BANK IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO SELL TO ANOTHER WATER
CONTRACTOR LATER.
WELL THOSE THOSE WATER
CONTRACTORS ACTUALLY THEY HAVE
THEIR CONTRACT AMOUNT WITH.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND WE DO HAVE A TRANSFER
PROGRAM.
AND. OTHERS WATER SUPPLIES HAVE
TO ABIDE BY.
OLIVER TRANSFER RULES.
THAT REQUIRE SEQUEL AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTATION SO I
DON'T. I DON'T.
CONSIDER WATER FIX PROVIDING
ANY.
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY THEN.
WHAT'S OTHERWISE AVAILABLE TO
PARTIES TODAY IN TERMS OF OF.
TRANSFERRING WATER.
EUROPE IN A JUST. MY OTHER
QUESTIONS YOU YOU.
YOU TALKED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE COULD START
RESERVOIRS IN A AS SOMEONE WHO
IS VERY ACTIVE ENOUGH ON.
ABOUT ONE AND I NEGOTIATIONS FOR
THE.
THE WATER BOND WE DID AND THAT
WAS A YOU KNOW. GROUP OF MONEY
IN THERE FOR RESERVOIRS.
AND I HEAR A LOT OF COMPLAINTS
pTHAT WE HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING ON
THAT YET.
WITH THAT MONEY SET ASIDE WE'RE
NOT MOVING AT AND YET WE HAVE A
GOOD POTENTIALLY ANOTHER
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS AGAIN
IN A PROJECT THAT. HAS A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS WITH ITS TO.
MISTER BRAZIER.
SHARE.
GOOD MORNING.
SO WE LOOK AT THE SIZE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS PROJECT IN
AND POTENTIALLY EIGHTY MILES OF
TUNNELS.
OF GOING THROUGH.
.
UNPREDICTABLE SOILS GAS WELLS
THOUSANDS OF GAS WELLS.
THROUGH THIS THROUGH THIS
COMPLEX.
MARRIOTT OF.
.
SIDON SOON ALL OF THESE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD WE JUST HAD A
PROJECT ON HOW WE TWELVE THAT
WAS FULLY ENGINEERED AND FAILED.
AND THEY HAD TO RE ENGINEER AND
TRY TO FIX.
WHAT THEY IN ENGINEERED?
AND THEN YOU AND YOU LOOK AT
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE
HAD MEGA PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY'VE SAID THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER THAT WE PUT A RISK
FACTOR IN.
AND IT NEVER EVEN CAME CLOSE TO.
BROWN BAY BRIDGE IS WHAT FIVE
TIMES OVER.
HIGH SPEED RAIL KNOWS.
THREE TIMES OVER.
.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC AND SELL THEM.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO COST TAX
AND THEN END UP COSTING Z..
I JUST THAT'S JUST.
UNCONSCIONABLE.
AND THERE'S GOT TO BE A BETTER
ABILITY FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF PROJECTS OF THIS
ENORMITY.
TO BE ABLE TO SAY ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH WHAT HAS A TENDENCY IS WE
GET INVOLVED IN THESE PROJECTS
TO A CERTAIN AMOUNT AND YOU GET
TO THE TIPPING POINT.
AND THEN ALSO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE.
YOU GET US INVESTED INTO A POINT
WHERE WHERE WERE WOULD JUST WE
HAVE TO GO ON.
THAT'S NOT FAIR SOB FAIR TO US
IS NOT FAIR TO THE OTHER THE
TAXPAYERS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BECAUSE OF THIS
SIZE.
AND THE DEBT SERVICE THAT THIS
WILL. POTENTIALLY.
A OCCUR.
HOW DO YOU PAY FOR IT WHEN YOU
HAVE A SAY GOD FOR BID A DECADE?
LONG DROUGHT.
I AM. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
THINK IN A PART OF OUR
CALCULATION IS YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THE COST OF NOT DOING.
A PROJECT AND NOT FIXING ON THE
ABILITY OF THE DELTA CONVEYANCE
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE WATER SUPPLIES.
AND THE CHALLENGES I I QUITE
AGREE WITH YOU.
.
AND I THINK ARE INTERESTED IN
HAVING LEARNED FROM THE BAY
BRIDGE AND OTHER BIG PROJECTS
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE THESE
OVERAGES.
BUT.
WE BELIEVE THAT AFTER LOOKING AT
ALL THE INFORMATION.
IT'S OUR OUR DUTY TO UPGRADE
THE SYSTEM.
THAT CAN PROVIDE RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLIES IN.
IN THE MOST AFFORDABLE WAY AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE OUR GOAL AS
WE MANAGE THROUGH THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT.
AND OF. CALIFORNIA'S GONNA
STRUGGLE STRUGGLE ACROSS.
MULTIPLE WATER SUPPLY SOURCES
IN THE EVENT OF A DROUGHT.
WHICH IS WHY.
WE HAD OUR PROP ONE.
PASSED SO SIGNIFICANTLY.
TO INSURE THAT WE ARE INVESTING
AND ALL OF THOSE PORT FOLIO
KINDS OF WATER SUPPLIES. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW REALLY THE WAVE OF THE
FUTURE IS THE DIVERSITY OF THE
DIVERSITY WATER SUPPLIES THAT
ARE PROVIDED ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THAT'S THE. THAT'S THE
BEST BULWARK AGAINST.
A LONG TERM DROUGHT CLUB
SCENARIO SO.
.
I THINK OUR WHOLE CHALLENGES HOW
WE MANAGE RISK AND THERE'S A
RISK TO DOING NOTHING AND AFTER
A DECADE OR SO IT'S OF THE STUDY
IN PRE PLANNING. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT.
MITIGATES RISK SHIRT CHEN
GENERATES OTHER RISK IN TERMS OF
CONSTRUCTION.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT A REASON
TO TO NOT GO FORWARD UP FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE
OKAY.
SO YOU KNOW.
ALSO YOU LOOK AT.
THE DELTA PROTECTION ACT OF
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
WHICH REQUIRES A DELTA NEEDS.
CONTINUED TO BE NET AS EXPORTS
OCCUR IN THIS WATER CODE SECTION
ONE TWO TWO EXACTS.
AND IS BOLSTERED BY THE MANDATE
TO REDUCE DELTA RELIANCE.
ALL EMPHASIZE REDUCED DELTA
RELIANCE ON EXPORTS TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WATER NEEDS.
WORKERS SECTION EIGHTY FIVE OH
TO ONE.
SO WHERE WE CONTINUE TO PUSH HIS
AGENDA. IS NOT EVEN COMPLY WITH
THEIR OWN LAWS
NOW WE'VE AS THE MAN CHARITY
INDICATED THIS LEGISLATURE VOTED
TO PUT THE WATER BOND OUT WITH
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE WERE GONNA
GET STORAGE. OUT OF THAT THEN
THE WATER COMMISSION NOW IS
DECLARED THAT IT DOESN'T MEET
THE PUBLIC NEED SO WE HAVE ONE
AGENCY TELLING. US THAT WOULD
WHAT WE INTENDED TO VIEWS CANNOT
BE USED FOR NOW.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT THESE THESE
LAWS WE PUT IN PLACE.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE NOT
REDUCING THE NEED ON THE DELTA.
NO OTHER SEAWATER AGENCIES HAVE.
SAN DIEGO BUILT THEIR OWN DIESEL
PLANT AT THEIR EXPENSE.
AND THEY REDUCING THEIR NEED ON
THE DELTA.
THIS INCREASES THE NEED ON THE
DELTA SO. ARE WE BREAKING OUR
OWN LAWS.
WELL WE ARE REQUIRED AS I
MENTIONED WE DO NEED TO.
PROVIDE CERTIFICATION OF
CONSISTENCY WITH THE DELTA PLAN.
DOCUMENTING.
THIS THOUGH PROJECTS PRODUCES
ALLIANCE ON THE DELTA IS GOING
TO BE PART OF THAT. MOM
CERTIFICATION AND OF THE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THAT.
WOULD US SEE THE BENEFIT OF THE
WATER.
OF THE WATER FIX PROJECT WILL
BE PART OF PROVIDING THAT
DOCUMENTATION AND THAT.
THE. GEORGIA COUNCIL ITSELF
WILL MAKE DETERMINATIONS ON.
SO YOUSO YOU'RE RIGHT AND.
WE ANTICIPATE DODD DESCRIBING.
THE REDUCE RELIANCE OF
REQUIREMENT AS IT RELATES TO
THIS PROJECT.
SO.
FORGIVE ME THE AMBER WE TALK
ABOUT OTHER AGENCIES MAKING THE
DETERMINATION THOSE ARE
APPOINTMENTS BY ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND SO A THERE HAS BEEN A
FEVERISH ATTEMPTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN.
AB ARM.
ACCOMPLISHED GOAL.
A BY CERTAIN TIMES THAT.
A.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT THE
TROUBLES ME IS THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
ALIENATED FROM THIS PROCESS WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS HUGE INVESTMENT.
GOING FORWARD IN ASISTIR
ACCOMPLISH SCHOOL OF THIS
LEGISLATURE.
TO DO WAY IN.
I MEAN IT'S JUST LIKE THIS THE
SEE AGENCIES ARE TELLING US WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
AND YOU'RE GONNA LIKE IT.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT WHAT I
CAME UP HERE TO BE.
I CAME HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE PEOPLE'S MONEY IS BEING
SPENT AN APPROPRIATE FASHION THE
BEST.
OF VALUE GOING FORWARD I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS A VALUE.
.
THE OTHER THE OTHER THING IS
WHEN WE LOOK AT OTHER COMPONENTS
I JUST WONDER WHAT THE PEOPLE
WERE TOLD WHEN THEM PUMPS FOR
PUTTING THAT TRACY. THIS GOING
TO MAKE THE DELTA BETTER.
AND THE EARLY FIFTIES OR
WHATEVER THEY WERE PUT IN.
AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK ONE
MILITANT DAM WAS INSTALLED.
IN THE FRESNO AREA WHO.
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER DRIVE.
OR SIXTY MILES
THAT WAS THE SOUTHERN PUSH TO
THE DELTA.
SO WE KEEP TELLING PEOPLE OF
THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
BUT THE ONLY THING THAT I'M
SEEING HERE IS THAT.
THAT TWO THIRDS OF THE ECONOMY
WILL FLOURISH WILL A ONE THIRD
OF THE ECONOMY WILL BE DAMAGED.
AND THAT'S MY AREA I LIVE IN THE
DELTA.
SLOWLY READ A ERROR SALINITY
WILL RISE IN THE DELTA.
IF YOU'RE TAKING NINE THOUSAND
CUBIC FEET KNOW WHAT IS SEVEN
GALLONS.
NINE THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
MINUTE.
HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF GALLONS IS
THAT TAKING OUT OF THE RIVER?
AND INTO CONVEYANCE.
AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE A DRAMATIC EFFECT ON BRING
SALINITY UP INTO THE DELTA.
INTO MY FARM'S WERE MY FARMS ARE
SOME OF THE CROPS ARE VERY.
SALTER SALINITY SENSITIVITY
CAN'T PLANT ANYMORE OR THE
ABUNDANCE ASSAULTS WILL NOW
BUILD UP IN THE SOILS IN THERE
AND THIS WAS WILL BE. USELESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF HYDRO
MODELING WHO'S DONE.
BUT I MEAN WHEN I WAS A LITTLE
GUY.
THE SALINITY BARRIER OF THE
SLOUGH DEMARCATION LINE WAS THAT.
THE THE CROCKETT BRIDGE.
NOW THREE MILE SLOUGH.
IT'S GONE UP MILES ALREADY AND
WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW DIMINISH
FLOWS IN ALL OF THIS.
WELL YOU DIMINISH THE FLORIDA
THAT THROUGH THE SOUTHERN DELTA
YOU'RE NOT ONLY GOING TO HURT.
THE FARMERS ARE GONNA HURT FISH
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE FRESH
WATER FLUSH.
AND SO. YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
EARTHQUAKES WAS THAT VINCE
PLENTY OF EARTHQUAKES WE'VE
NEVER HAD A LEVEE FAILURE TO AN
EARTHQUAKE.
AND WE TALK ABOUT ALL THIS
OTHER STUFF.
BUT WE SEE. AGAIN WE CAN HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION HOW YOU
GET TO ACTS.
BUT.
WITHOUT IT CREATING A.
ONE DROP OF NEW WATER.
TO ME IS SO FOOLISH.
WHEN WE HAVE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
IN OUR PROVEN YOU TAKE A
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
FIFTEEN D. SELF LANCE.
FRESH WATER
NEW WATER.
I MEAN WE HAVE DE COMMISSION
POWER PLANTS ON ARE DELTA RIGHT
NOW IN PITTSBURGH IN ANY ACT
THAT HAVE DISTILLING PROCESS IS.
IN PLACE.
THAT WE CAN UTILIZE.
THERE'S THE COMMISSION BAD TO
DISTILL THE WATERS WOULDN'T RUIN
THEIR PIPES.
SO AGAIN I SEE THIS MYOPIC PUSH
TO THIS PROJECT.
AND A TROUBLES ME BECAUSE.
WE THE LEGISLATURE HAVE NOT
WEIGHED IN SAID.
IS IT OF VALUE.
TO CALIFORNIA'S HOLE IT JUST
SAYS THEM FLORA COMMISSION HAS
TOLD US.
AS WE APPROVED.
PROP ONE A.
THAT THE THE THE SITES RESERVOIR
IN TEMPERATE SO WE HOLE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WANTED. TO GET
FUNDED. IS NO VALUE TO THEM.
THEREFORE OUR OPINION DIDN'T
MATTER.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER AND AND
I. GOT UP AT MISTER GELLER NEXT
RIGHT BUT I WOULD JUST REITERATE
THIS EMPLOYMENT I HEAR YOU ALL
SAYING WE DON'T WORK ON THIS FOR
YEARS AND I THINK.
PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE IT HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR YEARS WHY YOU MYOPIC
ON ONE SOLUTION WHY AREN'T WE
LOOKING AT A MULTITUDE OF THANKS.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
SO FOR SOMEONE DID. YOU HELP ME
CAN UNDERSTAND THE THE FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT HERE BECAUSE.
AS WAS SAID SEVENTEEN BILLION TO
BUILD WATER FIX ESSENTIALLY.
WHY NOT YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT WE
BUILD BOTH SITES RESERVOIR? AND
TEMPERANCE FLAT.
TEMPERANCE FLAT WOULD STORE ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION THERE AT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION ACRE FEET OF
WATER. THAT'S ALREADY SOUTH THE
DELTA.
SO WE'VE ALREADY GOT IF IF WE
BUILT THAT PROJECT TODAY.
WE WOULD HAVE THAT WATER THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN AND MAYBE
THROUGH AN EAST WEST A
CONNECTION CAN NOW.
COULD POTENTIALLY BE EXCHANGE
WATER THAT CAN BE USED FOR SOUTH
OF DELTA NEEDS.
BUT THAT PROJECT NOW SITES DID
GET.
PUBLIC ELIGIBILITY FUNDING OF
THE WATER COMMISSION.
BUT TEMPERANCE GOD GROSSLY
UNDERFUNDED FOR ITS PUBLIC
BENEFITS.
AND.
SO THAT PROJECT LOOKS LIKE IT'S.
VERY MUCH HAMSTRUNG.
AND FOR BASICALLY TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION I THINK DOES THAT TOTAL
PROJECT COST.
VERSES SEVENTEEN BILLION.
THAT YOU CAN ONLY GET. I THINK
BY WHAT YOU SAID FOR ANY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER.
MAYBE DEPENDING
IN IN THE DELTA LATER THAT WE
HAVE AN ANTICIPATED.
IS NOT A BETTER BET AND A MORE.
AT A BETTER USE OF OUR MONEY TO
GET MORE WATER SOUTH OF DELTA TO
HELP WITH NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
I I THINK IT'S APPLES AND
ORANGES.
IN TERMS OF THE COMPARISONS HOA
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS TO
CONSIDER.
ONE I AGREE WITH YOU THAT.
STORAGE NEEDS TO PLAY A ROLE IN.
AND OUR WATER FUTURE IN THE
WATER COMMISSION HAD ITS PROCESS
WHICH WAS.
.
DETERMINE THROUGH THEIR
REGULATORY.
.
OF THE RULE MAKING ON HOW TO
DISPERSE THAT MONEY SO IF I
COULD WITH ALL DUE RESPECT KIND
OF SET THAT ASIDE AT THE MOMENT
BUT.
BUT WATER FIX.
.
IS YOU KNOW EFFECTIVELY A
PROJECT THAT.
WE BELIEVE WILL DO MULTIPLE
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR WATER USERS AND FRANKLY ARE
A LYNCH PIN AND A LOT OF THESE
OTHER INVESTMENTS.
SO ONE.
IT'S GOING TO PROTECT.
WATER SUPPLIES FROM AN OUTAGE.
TO TO.
EITHER A NATURAL DISASTER BE AN
EARTHQUAKE OR ANY.
A BIG MOVING STORM THROUGH THE
SYSTEM TO ITS.
PROTECTS THOSE WATER SUPPLIES
FROM.
SEA LEVEL RISE OVER TIME AND IF
THERE'S ONE THING I THINK I'VE
LEARNED IN THE PAST DECADE IS
THAT. THE INTENSITY OF THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE.
IS INCREASING AT A RATE OF WE
HADN'T REALLY PREDICTED.
BUT BUT HERE WE ARE.
.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE NEW INTAKES
CAN MOVE WATER IN A WAY THAT'S
MORE BENIGN ENVIRONMENTALLY THEN
THE CURRENT. LEASE SITUATED
WATER PUMPS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY KNOWN FOR
DECADES.
.
BUT.
WERE NOT ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY ACT
ON.
THE VALUE OF THIS PROJECT I
THINK IS MOST APPROPRIATELY
EXPRESSED.
.
AND ALL OF THOSE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES.
AND WITH THEIR BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS THAT TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR SUPPLY THAT I THEY GET
CONTRACTED THROUGH. OF MY
DEPARTMENT ATTITUDE OF YOU ARE
IN THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND
THEY PLAN FOR HOW THEY USE THAT
SUPPLY LOCALLY WITH OTHER
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY MAKE AND
RECYCLED WATER. IN DESALINATION
IF IT'S AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY
STORE THEIR CAPTURE IS OF A KIND
OF A NEW AREA WHERE WE'RE
STARTING TO FOCUS ON WE NOW HAVE
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE US TO. GET OUR GROUND
WATER OF BASINS CLEAN AND I TO
HAVE A POINT OF SUSTAINABLE
YIELD A.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DECADES SO. I'M MOST
OF WATER IN CALIFORNIA'S MANAGED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THAT
SUPPLY AND IT'S THOSE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THAT NEED TO MAKE
A DETERMINATION BASED ON THEIR
LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES. OF THE
VALUE OF OF THIS UPGRADE TO
THEIR LOCAL RATEPAYERS AND
THAT'S WHY THE THE PAST NINE
MONTHS PLUS MONTHS HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL IN. IN THE DISCUSSION
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S THE
DISCUSSION THAT'S HAPPENING IN
FRONT OF THESE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS AND.
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHERE IT THAT VALUE SHOULD
SHOULD LIE AND THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
RIGHT IN THAT INCIDENT THAT'S A
VERY LONG ANSWER A LOT IN THERE.
HOWEVER NONE OF THAT IS NOT OF
THAT SAYS THAT HAVING ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION ACRE FEET OF WATER
RD SOUTH ADULT THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED. CHAIR
AND WAS SITES ONLINE WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO SITES ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF SITES PROVIDING
FLOWS TO THE DELTA.
SO IF YOU HAD BOTH THOSE
PROJECTS ONLINE IT WOULD DO THE
SAME THINGS HE DOES MENTION FOR
A FRACTION OF THE COST. AND.
I WOULD POINT OUT YOUR OFFICE
DID PLAY A ROLE IN THE WATER
COMMISSION AS YOU WERE TO VALUE
RECREATIONAL BENEFITS. WHICH YOU
GAVE ZERO TEMPERANCE FLAT.
AND YET YOUR OFFICE MOVED HEAVEN
AND EARTH.
TO MOVE THIS PROJECT FOR TO TO.
AND LET'S JUST BY ONE OF CLARIFY
THIS BECAUSE IT WAS IT WAS
ALMOST STATED LIKE WE WENT BACK
TO THE OTHER CONTRACTORS TO SEE
IF IT WOULD YOU GUYS.
WE WANT TO HELP. PAY FOR THIS
PROJECT.
LET'S BE REAL I MEAN I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT DID YOUR
OFFICE AND THE ADMINISTRATION DO.
TO LOBBY THESE GROUPS
TO COME UP WITH THE MONEY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK YOU JUST
LET HIM GO BACK I THINK THERE
WAS A VERY CONCERTED IN
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT.
TO GET SANTA CLARA WATER
DISTRICTS ONBOARD AND TO GET AT
METROPOLITAN.
I MEAN SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
LIKE WHAT DID YOU GUYS DO TO
HELP.
LOBBY ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET
ONBOARD WITH THIS PROJECT.
WE PROVIDE OF THE SAME
INFORMATION TO THEM THAT WE'VE
PROVIDED TO THE PUBLIC ON THE
VALUE OF THIS PROJECT. ON THEY
DO THEIR OWN.
EVALUATIONS BASED ON THEIR
URBAN WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS TO
ESTABLISH A THE A APPROPRIATE
DEBATE FROM OTHER BOARD AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S AN
INVESTMENT THAT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THEIR RATE PAYERS. LEADING
LOBBY THEM TO TO COME ONBOARD TO
MAKE THIS PROJECT HAPPEN. THERE
WASN'T AN AGGRESSIVE EFFORT ON
THE BEHALF ADMINISTRATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
TO ENCOURAGE THE OTHER WATER
CONTRACTORS TO COME ONBOARD WITH
THIS PROJECT.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
VERY ASSERTIVE FOR A DECADE ON
THE VALUE OF THIS PROJECT AND
THAT HASN'T CHANGED.
RIGHT AND LESS SO ON PROJECTS
LIKE TEMPERANCE FLAT WHICH ARE
ALSO IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THE
WATER FOR.
SOUTH OF DELTA CONCERNS IN FACT
WHEN YOU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SHUT HIM DOWN AND SAID ZERO ZERO
POINTS THERE.
WELL WE DID A JUST THROUGH THE
APPEALS PROCESS OF THE
RECREATION BENEFIT ASSOCIATED
WITH TEMPERANCE FLAT.
RIGHT AND THEN SO LAST QUESTION
IS.
YOU KNOW YOU SAID IN YOUR
PRESENTATION THAT YOU ANTICIPATE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WILL COME
ONBOARD RIGHT WHAT DO YOU MEAN
BY THAT.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE.
NOT ANTICIPATE YOU CAN HOPE TO
FORCE OR COERCE THEM TO COME IN
BECAUSE HE SHUT DOWN THEIR
BIGGEST PROJECT TEMPERANCE FLAT.
THEY WERE PROVIDE WATER FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND NOW HAVE NO
TEN BILLION TO MAKE SURE IT'S
TWO TUNNELS BUT THE IDEAS
ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE. A GUYS
WANNA COME IN THIS PROJECT YOU
CAN BUT YOU'RE GONNA PASS TO GET
IN TO GET IT RIGHT.
I MEAN ISN'T IS NOT SORT OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AND. WITH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S NOT WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE WE'RE GONNA TRY AND
FORCE THEM.
TO COME INTO THE PROJECT IS THAT
RIGHT. I DON'T BELIEVE SO THIS
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A A PROJECT
BASED ON WILLING PARTICIPANTS
AND MANY OF THOSE CONTRACTORS
ACTUALLY WERE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS AND PAID FOR THE
PLANNING PROCESS.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS.
UNIQUE TO THE US BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION.
AND I'M HAVING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
RECLAMATION COMMISSIONER TO
IDENTIFY A PATH.
WHEREBY A CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT CONTRACTORS WHO WOULD I
REALIZE A BENEFIT FROM THE
TUNNELS HAVE THEY HAVE A PATH TO
INVEST IN THE PROJECT.
SO. WHAT JUST WHAT MOMENT MISTER
AT THAT WE ABOVE MEANT THAT WHAT
MISTER PATTERSON WAS UP AND THEN
MISTER FRAZIER A BIT IF I COULD
JUST?
I MEAN TO WHAT MISTER.
MR.
GALLAGHER SAYING I MEAN IT'S SIX
MONTHS THAT METROPOLITAN WATER
DECIDED TO DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
THEY WERE PUTTING IN.
DOUBLE.
BILLIONS DOUBLE BILLIONS AND I'M
IN A FEW MONTHS TIME.
IN WHICH TIME SOME BILLS CAME ON
VERY QUICKLY SO THAT I MEAN THAT
JUST.
AND PASS THE SNIFF TEST MISTER
PATTERSON.
I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT THE ACT
CONCERNS OF THE AND THE MAN
CHAIR AND.
OTHER MEMBERS HERE.
WITH RESPECT YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
TEMPERANCE FLAT AND SITES AND.
THE WATER BOND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATED.
BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN TERRIBLY ABUSED IN THIS
PROCESS.
AND I JUST WANT TO LAY OUT. A
WHAT I THINK IS A.
THIS IS THIS IS A JOINT.
HEARING WITH RESPECT TO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I THINK THERE'S A SPLIT THEM
BETTER BE A TIME A PLACE TO REAP
FOR PRESS TO HOLD.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND
AND THE THE WATER THAT.
AB.
BUREAUCRACIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT WENT FOR WHAT WENT DOWN
TEMPERANCE.
WE ASK FOR A MODEL.
THAT WE COULD USE.
WE ASK PERMISSION TO USE IT WE
DID.
AND IT WAS DEEMED THAT IT WAS A
IT'S A TEN YEAR MODEL TO
UNDERSTAND THE HYDROLOGY OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER.
IT DEMONSTRATED.
A SIGNIFICANT A OF THE BENEFITS.
NOT AND YOUR DEPARTMENT.
PARTICIPATED IN.
UTTERLY THE.
A OF ABANDONMENT OF OF EVERY.
DECENT PROCESS.
A ARE AT DUE PROCESS AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO REDRESS LIKE
THAT.
A GRIEVANCE WITH.
WITH WITH THE WATER COMMISSION.
I DON'T I MEAN IT UP SO THAT WE
GOT ZERO.
FOR RECREATION.
AT ZERO.
FOR INCREASED FLOWS AND AND A
NET BENEFIT.
DOWNSTREAM TO THE TO THE. FISH
HABITATS.
USING.
A.
A WELL REGARDED.
ACCEPTED MODEL.
THAT WE WERE TOLD I WASN'T
HEARING THREE AND HALF HOURS.
THAT WAS APPROPRIATE TO USE
AND WE DID.
AND IT WAS THAT THE
TESTIMONY OF THE STAFF THAT
ASTOUNDED US THAT THEY BASICALLY
SAID THAT ENTIRE MODEL WE'RE
GOING TO THROW OUT WE DON'T.
BELIEVE IT'S WORTH IT.
AND WE HAVE ASKED ALL ALONG
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATIVE MODEL.
GIVE US A AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER WAS WE DON'T HAVE ONE.
WE WERE NOT PROVIDED ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE THE.
THE VALUE.
WE THINK THERE IS A CONNECTION
BETWEEN WESTLANDS DENIAL.
OF PARTICIPATION.
AND OUR DENIAL OF TEMPERANCE.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS
BORDERING ON ON ON OF ON A VERY.
ALMOST DICTATORIAL APPROACH
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION IF YOU
PLAY BALL WITH THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION YOU GET THE DEAL
AND IF YOU DON'T.
BUT YOU YOU GET MESSED WITH
AND AND TO ME THIS THIS IS I
MEAN IT'S NOT COINCIDENTAL THAT
SANTA CLARA. HELD OFF.
THEY DID THE BOOK PERSONAL DEBT
DEBT VOTED NOT TO PARTICIPATE.
THEN THEY THEN THEY HOOK HOLD
OFF
JAYCO GETS APPROVED.
AND A FEW DAYS LATER A THEY SAY
HEY HERE'S A WHOLE WHOLE BUNCH
MORE MONEY.
IF YOU PLAY BALL WITH THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU GET THE DEAL.
AND YOU GET THE WATER.
AND I'M AYE I THINK THERE IS
SOMETHING.
TERRIBLY AMISS HERE.
AND I THINK YOU'RE HEARING THAT
FROM THESE MEMBERS
WHO.
WENT TO THE BARRICADES OVER PROP
ONE.
WE WORKED OUR AND AND WE AND AND.
WE
WERE ASSURED.
THAT THERE WOULD BE FAIR.
A OPPORTUNITY FOR TEMPERANCE AND
FOR.
S. SITES IN FOR THESE.
OTHERS.
AND WE HAVE WE HAVE BEEN SHOT
DOWN AT EVERY TURN.
AND THEN WE TURN AROUND AND SEE
BUT JACO APPROVED AND
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT. SANTA
CLARA PROVES.
WHY?
SHOULD WE NOT BE SUSPICIOUS OF
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
AND WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO WHEN IT SEEMS
LIKE THE REAL EVIDENCE.
THAT IT IT IN THESE HEARINGS AND
WITH RESPECT TO THESE PROJECTS.
UP BELIES THAT TRUST.
WHY SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO TRUST
THIS ADMINISTRATION WHEN WE SEE
WHAT HAS BEEN? TAKING PLACE WITH
RESPECT THE ABROGATION OF EVERY
RESPONSIBILITY. WITH RESPECT TO
THE TO TO THE WATER BOND AND AND.
INCREASE STORAGE AND AN
INCREASED WATER FLOWS.
WHY SHOULD WE TRUST YOU?
THAT A RHETORICAL.
ALL DO RESPECT HER IT IS A
SPECIFIC DETAILED DIRECT
QUESTION CITING HISTORY AND
ACTIONS THAT TOOK PLACE VERY
VERY RECENTLY AND I BELIEVE
SOMEBODY.
PASSED A COME TO THE TABLE AND
EXPLAIN TO US IN OPEN SESSION
WHERE THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY
JUST WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON
HERE. BECAUSE WE DON'T SEE TRUST
WE SEE MANIPULATION.
AND FORCE AYE I'M ASKING THE
QUESTION SINCERELY AND HONESTLY
WHY SHOULD WE TRUST YOU AND I'M
GONNA ANSWER YOU SINCERELY AND
HONESTLY RIGHT BACK I THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSIONS.
PROCESS I THINK IT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF IN TERMS OF THE
REGULATIONS THEY PROMULGATED AND.
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY WERE GOING
TO.
VALUE.
THE PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIO AND.
MANY PROJECTS ORIGINALLY.
HAD A ZERO MARK AND THROUGH AN
APPEALS PROCESS.
THAT WAS CONDUCTED IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY THEY WERE ABLE
TO.
THEY WERE ABLE TO RAISE THEIR
PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIO.
I'M NOT PREPARED TO GET INTO
THE DETAILS TODAY ON THE
RECREATION BENEFITS A TEMPERANCE
FLAT I'D BE.
I I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT.
WHEN I'M MORE PREPARED ON THAT
VERY SPECIFIC TOPIC AND I WOULD
WELCOME THAT DISCUSSION WITH YOU.
AND I'M I'M I'M I WILL TAKE YOU
UP ON THAT AND WOULD AND AND I
THINK THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS.
PARTICULARLY OF UP OF THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA CAUCUS STATED
THAT INTENDED TO DO THAT THAT
VERY THING BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE.
FACTS ARE THE FACTS
THAT THE MODEL WE USED WAS
APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION UPON
A REQUEST OF EIGHT AND APPROVED
MODEL.
WHEN WE DID ALL OF THE WORK.
THE TESTIMONY WAS THAT THE MODEL
DOESN'T.
THERE IS NO GOOD ANYMORE IT'S
OUTDATED AND WE SAID WHAT'S THE
ADDITION WHAT WHAT.
WHAT'S AN ATTORNEY THAT AND THAT
A DIFFERENT MODEL.
THAT WE CAN APPROPRIATE WOULD WE
WE WERE NOT GIVEN ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT
TEMPERANCE FLAT COULD DO BECAUSE
THE VERY MODEL WAS STRIPPED FROM
US AND NO ADDITIONAL DIFFERENT
MODEL. WAS SUGGESTED IN FACT IN
TESTIMONY THEY STATE WE HAVE NOT.
HOW IS IT THAT DUE PROCESS HOW
IS THAT FAIR AND HOW IN THE
WORLD DOES THAT COMPORT WITH
WHAT YOU JUST?
TESTIFIED THAT THE WATER
COMMISSION USED IT REGULATORY.
DETERMINATIONS AND IT AND I AND
ALL OF THAT. TO BASICALLY SAY
THERE IS NO PATH FOR TEMPERANCE
BLACK.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO MODEL THAT'S
GOING TO WORK
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ONE.
I CAN ONLY REITERATE MY OFFER.
TO HAVE A MUCH MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ON THIS
TOPIC WHEN I HAVE BETTER
INFORMATION A LOT WHEN I'M
UNDERSTAND THAT I APPRECIATED
AND AND THAT AT SOME POINT I I
DO. I DO THINK.
AND I'M ASKING OTHER COLLEAGUES
HERE.
PERHAPS TO CONSIDER WHETHER THE.
ACCOUNTABILITY.
COMMITTEE OUGHT TO HOLD SOME
HEARINGS INTO THE PRECISE.
PROCESS BY WHICH TEMPERANCE FLAT
WAS DENIED BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT DOES HUGE DAMAGE TO THE
PROMISES OF THE PROPOSITION.
DO WE KNOW MISTER PATTERSON.
I'M UNDER ANY WITHIN EVERYBODY
HERE A MINUTE. WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THAT THAT PEOPLE ARE VERY
TROUBLED BY HIS TOUCH.
M. MISTER FRAZIER SOMETHING ELSE
BRIEFLY AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
TO.
TO MR MATHIS AND THEN MATCH TO
MR SALAS AND I'M WHEN I'M WE'RE
STILL IN PANEL ONE SO WE NEED TO
GET THE PANEL TO AT SOME POINT
OR SAID OF HIS VERY SHORT.
MS NAME IF THAT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT THIS.
MEDIA ORTON METEORIC.
PATHWAY FOR THE WHAT EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO PUSH.
THIS TWIN TOTAL PLAN.
BUT IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THE DUTCH SLEW.
OF.
WHAT'S A WATER.
YOU MEDIA. WHEN WAS RESTORATION.
WHICH WASN'T TITLED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO WERE BREAKING
GROUND THIS MONTH AND SIXTEEN
YEARS LATER.
FOR WETLANDS RESTORATION.
SIMPLE PROJECT.
OKAY.
GOOD GOOD MAKE THE DELTA BETTER.
BUT.
YOU KNOW ALL THE SUDDEN.
MISSING FUNNELS DOWN FUNNELS
DOWNFALLS IN ALL IT'S NOW IT'S
ON A PATH.
I THINK WE NEED TO SLOW THIS
THING DOWN EARLY'S ENJOYMENT AND
MAKE SURE THAT.
.
WE'RE NOT STUCK HOLDING THE BAG
ON THIS THING BECAUSE.
.
AGAIN.
WE HAVE NO ASSURANCES THAT IT'S
NOT GOING TO GO UP INTO THE THAT
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF.
AND AND IF IT DOES.
THE USER SAY SO BE IT.
SO.
SPIKE TO SENSE.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE PLANNING.
DOUBLE THE COST
A PLAN FOR THIS PROJECT.
DOUBLING COST FROM WHAT THEY
THOUGHT SO AND THAT I THINK THAT
GIVES AN INDICATION OF. A THE
COMPLEXITIES OF MR MATHIS AND
THEN MISTER SALAS AND THEN AND.
NOW I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT ABOUT TEMPERATURE MOVE WE
SO SAW ECHO ALL THE TEMPERANCE
REMARKS.
THEN A ANY GETS A A GREAT POINT
ABOUT THAT THE COST OF PROJECTS
IN OUR STATE DOUBLING NOW WE ARE
YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING WITH
OTHER PROJECTS.
ARE.
MOMENTS AGO YOU SAID WILLING
PARTNERS.
I I FIND IT FASCINATING BECAUSE
YOU'VE ALSO SAID YOU KNOW
REGULATORY DEMONSTRATIONS.
WORDS LIKE SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
WILLINGNESS.
THROUGH YOU THE REGULAR TORY
PROCEDURES.
THAT YOU ALL HAVE DONE WITH THE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
YOU SHOULDN'T DOWN OTHER AVID.
OTHER DOORS HAVE CLOSED ONLY
LEAVING ONE DOLLAR OPEN.
SHOW THAT THERE'S A WILLINGNESS
TO MOVE FORWARD TO GET WATER
SOUTH
THAT'S THE WILLINGNESS.
AND IF.
AND IN ORDER TO GET WILLING
PARTNERS.
YOU SHUT DOWN EVERY SINGLE OTHER
OPTION.
THROUGH REGULATORY
DEMONSTRATIONS.
YOU ONLY ONE OPTION
SO.
GATHER GONNA BE WILLING BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY OPTION THEY HAVE.
AND THAT'S NOT RIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THIS STATE.
WE DON'T NEED TO BE USING.
REGULATORY DEMONSTRATIONS.
TECH CUT OFF.
OTHER OPTIONS AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN THIS
STATE WHERE WE DID.
DO. MIND FOCUS ON THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO BE DONE.
AND WE FORGET ABOUT EVERY OTHER
OPTION OUT THERE.
IN OTHER OPTIONS IN A NOT TO. GO
FARTHER TO HAMMER ON ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF TEMPERANCE AND.
TAKE TO GET INTO THINGS LIKE
DESALINATED THINGS FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE HAVE AN EXTREME PROBLEM
WITH THE DELTA WE WERE PROBLEM
OF THIS PROJECT.
IN.
YEAH I'VE GOT I AGREE WITH ALL
MY COLLEAGUES HERE THERE'S SOME
EXTREME CONCERN.
ONE WERE USING INNER REGULATORY
EFFORTS.
THROUGH STATE AGENCIES.
CUT OFF.
ANYTHING OUT OF THE BOX.
THAT IS WANTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
CONCERN IS I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
HEARING.
WHERE WE GO THROUGH WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH TEMPERANCE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THERE ACTUALLY BEING
SOME TRANSPARENCY?
AND IN CLARITY IN THESE WATERS.
THANK YOU ARE I'LL BE BRIEF.
JUST BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER
PATTERSON KIND OF OUTLINED A LOT
OF THE FRUSTRATIONS WITH
TEMPERANCE FLATS AND LOW.
THEN THE WATER COMMISSION.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS HERE THAT ARE FILL
AND.
LITTLE BETRAYED IN THE PROMISED
TO DELIVER ON THESE TWO BIG
PROJECTS.
SO.
I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF WANTING A
MORE DETAILED IN DEPTH.
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT BUT
WHAT OCCURRED AND WHETHER THAT'S
THROUGH HEARING I DON'T KNOW.
THROUGH THE CHAIRS OR. WHETHER
WE DO THAT WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR WITH THE VALLEY CAUCUS
OR WITH COMPANY BASICALLY ANY
LEGISLATURE THAT WAS HERE THAT
VOTED FOR PROPOSITION ONE BEFORE
IT BECAME PROPOSITION ONE.
I'M AYE DEATHLY THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO FOLLOW UP
ON.
BUT ON THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW.
NOT ENOUGH TO COVER THIS EARLIER
UP BUT I WANTED TO JUST ASK.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF US OF THE
VALLEY WERE CONCERNED WITH THE
SPECIALLY WERE HELP OPEN
TEMPERANCE WOULD HELP WITH THAT.
WAS WATER QUALITY.
WATER QUALITY AND THEN ALSO
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES OF SIGMA
ACT OUT THE GOVERNOR'S YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THE SIGMA PLAN THAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE.
BUT FOR THE WATER FIX WAS
TYPICALLY HOW'RE WE ADDRESSING
THOSE ALLOCATIONS WHERE THEY'RE
GOING AND. IS THERE.
IS OUR PURPOSE TO ADDRESSING THE
WATER QUALITY ISSUES.
AND DELIVERING.
DELIVERING THIS WATER THEIR
BECAUSE HE'D NO I'VE TALKED TO
SOME FOLKS.
I AND MY PART OF THE SOUTHERN
INTO THE VALLEY IN THERE JUST
CONCERNED WHILE.
YOU KNOW EVEN IF WE PAY INTO
THIS THING IS ALL THIS WATER CAN
GET SHIPPED TO LOS ANGELES AND.
AND TO OTHER BASINS AND SO YOU
KNOW WHAT'S OF BENEFIT THERE AND
SO IF YOU JUST KIND OF TOUCH ON
THAT.
FOR ME.
SURE THANK YOU IN.
YOUR COMMENT SOMEONE TEMPERANCE
AND OTHERS ISSUES ARE DULY NOTED.
IN TERMS OF THIS PROJECT ONE I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT WATER
QUALITY.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN NIGHT
THAT'S WHY I THINK THIS PROJECT
IS IS ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT
OVER TIME. TO HELP MANAGE THOSE
ISSUES.
.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT.
THAT THIS PROJECT.
FROM THE STATE WATER PROJECT
PERSPECTIVE IS DESIGNED AROUND
THE DELIVERY OF EXISTING
CONTRACTED AMOUNTS WHICH ARE
TABLE A CONTRACTED AMOUNTS IF
YOU WILL. AND SO THOSE PARTIES
THAT HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
UP THROUGH THE STATE WATER
PROJECT THEY WILL GET THEIR
ALLOTTED BENEFITS.
FROM WATER FIX.
IT'S THERE IS NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
HAVE YOU'LL HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY ON THE NEXT PANEL
BUT. THERE'S NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH THE MAT METROPOLITAN
FINANCING OF THE REMAINING
PORTION FOR THEM TO GET MORE
WATER THAN THEIR CONTRACTED
AMOUNT.
SO.
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE ANSWER TO
TO THAT QUESTION AND I AM ALSO
TALKING WITH A LOT OF FOLKS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY ABOUT HOW TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROJECT. SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE
AND.
I BELIEVE WILL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THEM.
OKAY.
THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME.
PANEL.
A WITH THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING TODAY AND THEN OUR NEXT
PANEL PAL NUMBER TWO.
JEFFREY CUDDLING HER GENERAL
MANAGER BETTER POULTON WATER
DISTRICT.
JENNIFER.
PIERRE GENERAL MANAGER STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS BONTA TOLLEY.
CHAIR OF THE DELTA COUNTIES
COALITION. DOG.
BG STATE ATTORNEY FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND OSHA MISTER.
ATTORNEY REPRESENT ADULT
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
COMING TODAY.
CUTTING WOULD LIKE START.
I THINK VERY MUCH OF CHAIRS
EGGMAN. CHAIRS BLOOM IN GARCIA.
PROJECT OPPORTUNITY COME HERE
AND SPEAK UP MY NAME IS JEFFREY
TIGHTLY AROUND THE GENERAL
MANAGER SEAL THE MATCH POINT
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I JUST LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT WHO WE ARE OF WHAT'S OUR
WATER SUPPLY SITUATION LOOK LIKE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND AND
WHY ARE AGENCY TOOK ITS ACTION
OF THAT IT TOOK IN APRIL TO
SUPPORT THIS PROJECT.
SO MUCH BUT WATER DISTRICT IS
THE WATER WHOLESALER OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE THAN
HALF OF ALL THE WATER USED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
SERVE THE COUNTIES OF ALL THE
COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES ORANGE
AND SAN DIEGO AND PORTIONS OF
BEEN TERRORISTS ITEMS HAMBURG
MEDINA.
THIS SIX COUNTY SERVICE AREA HAS
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE ON IT
AFFECTIVELY WE SERVE WATER TO
THROUGH OUR MEMBER AGENCIES TO
ONE IN EVERY TWO CALIFORNIANS.
ANDA ROUGHLY THAT'S ONE EVERY
SIXTEEN AMERICANS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THERE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMY ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY ALSO RESIDES
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LIKE IT'S
THEIR WATER. UP THROUGH
METROPOLITAN.
THE WATER THAT MUCH FUN PROVIDES
COMES FROM TWO PLACES PRIMARILY
ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT OF ALL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS IMPORTED
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THROUGH
THE STATE WATER PROJECT. AND
THEN TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
METROPOLITAN IMPORTS THROUGH ITS
COLORADO RIVER ACT WITH ACT UP
BRINGING IT IN. AND YOU SERVING
THOSE TWO SUPPLIES BLENDING THEM
AND DELIVERING THEM THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE OTHER FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF
WATER IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A SMALL PIECE THAT COMES
THAT IS JUST THE CITY OF LA IS
THAT IS IMPORTED FROM THE OWENS
VALLEY.
ROUGHLY FIVE TO TEN PERCENT OF
THE REGION'S WATER AND THE REST
IS OUR LOCAL NATIVE WATER
THROUGH OUR GROUND WATER BASINS
AND OURS RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNTS OF RAINFALL.
OUR BOARD A DECIDED TO INVEST IN
WATER FIX.
THIS LAST APRIL.
WE ACTUALLY HAD THE CITED IT
PREVIOUSLY TO DO IT IN OCTOBER
AD THAT WAS A DIFFERENT FORMAT
BECAUSE WE WERE LOOKING AT A CBP
PORTION OF IT ROUGHLY A THIRD OF
THIS PROJECT WOULD BEEN FINANCED
BY CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
CONTRACTORS.
THEN WE TOOK IT MATTER UP AGAIN
WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR THEY WOULD
NOT PARTICIPATE IN APRIL. AND
OUR BOARD LOOKED AT TWO OPTIONS
ONE IS BUILDING HELPING THE
STATE FINANCE A SMALLER OPTION A
ONE TUNNEL TO WHEN TAKE OPTION.
THE OR FINANCE THE ENTIRE
PROJECT WHERE WE WOULD PICK UP
THAT CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION AND
USE. TO SEE A THAT DOESN'T
INVESTMENT.
I WE LOOKED AT IT OUR BOARD
LOOKED AT IT FROM ABOUT FIVE
MAIN ISSUES OF THAT WERE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US. ONE
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THOUGH IS
THE WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY THE
PROJECT PROVIDED.
WE ARE HAVE BEEN LOSING WATER
SUPPLY FROM STATE WATER PROJECT
IT'S THIRTY PERCENT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY.
THE PROJECT HAS ROUGHLY LOST
ABOUT A THIRD OF ITS RELIABILITY
TO TWO ENDANGERED SPECIES
S. CUTBACKS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DECADES.
THIS PROJECT HELPS REVERSE THAT
IT HELPS TURN THAT AROUND.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT A CLIMATE
CHANGE WORLD WERE IN A CLIMATE
CHANGE WORLD OF RAIN AND LESS
SNOW WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
WAITING FOR THE SNOW TO MELT AND
PICK UP AND PUMP YEAR ROUND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PICK UP
WATER. IN SHORT BURSTS AND MOVE
IT INTO STORAGE AND MOVE THAT
INTO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY ENDANGERED
SPECIES IMPACTS
A CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS.
AND THEN FINALLY WATER QUALITY
HUGELY IMPORTANT TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OUR GROUND WATER
BASINS NEED THAT FRESH WATER OF
STATE WATER PROJECT. ARE
COLORADO RIVER WATER IS
SIGNIFICANTLY SALTIER THAT'S WHY
WE BLEND THE TWO AND WE CAN USE
IT FOR BOTH OUR RECYCLING
PROGRAMS ARE CONSERVATION
PROGRAMS AND PUTTING THAT WATER
INTO OUR GROUND WATER BASINS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE GOVERNOR
STRESSED WITH US.
ATTENTION THE LAY UP WE WERE
LOOKING AT A WE'VE WORKED ON
THIS PROJECT FOR A DECADE WE
HAVE INVESTED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
COLLECTIVELY AS WATER. MANAGERS
TO STUDY THIS PROJECT AND COME
UP WITH THE PROPOSED PROJECT.
AFTER A DECADE OF ANALYSIS.
MOVING TO A ONE TUNNEL INSTEAD
OF TWO TUNNELS MOVING TO A
PARTIAL SOLUTION INSTEAD OF A
FULL SOLUTION. UP POTENTIALLY
WOULD HAVE GONE BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD MORE REVIEW MORE
ANALYSIS MORE STUDY.
BUT MY BOARD WAS FED UP WITH
DELAY FED UP WITH THIS DECADE WE
SPENT WORKING ON THIS AND THEY
WANTED TO MOVE FORWARD.
SO CONSIDERING ALL THAT THEY
DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD.
NOW DOES HAVE WE LOOKED AT VERY
CAREFULLY AT THE FINANCIAL
IMPACTS OF THAT.
THE PROJECT COST METROPOLITAN.
ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS AND EIGHTY
CENTS PER HOUSEHOLD IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHAT THE FULL TEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR FINANCING
LEVEL. IF WE DID JUST OUR SHARE
OF IT IT WAS TWO DOLLARS AND
FORTY CENTS PER HOUSEHOLD IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A MONTH.
THAT'S AFTER THE FULL BUILD OUT
ITSELF BLARED IN OVER A DECADE
SO IT GOES AND IT ROUGHLY. ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE CENTS A MONTH FIFTY
CENTS A MONTH AND THEN THAT
BUILDS UP TO THAT AMOUNT.
THAT WAS LOOKED AT IS THAT
AFFORDABLE FOR OUR REGION WE DO
SPREAD ACROSS A BIG BASS OVER
SIX MILLION HOUSEHOLDS NINETEEN
MILLION PEOPLE. THAT FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH WHEN WE LOOKED
AT.
ADDING IT AGAINST THE CELL
ADDING AGAINST DISTRIBUTIVE
STORM WATER CAPTURE
SIGNIFICANTLY CHEAPER THAN THOSE.
IT DOESN'T DISPLACE THOSE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO ALL OF THE
ABOVE WERE VERY PROUD OF OUR
TRACK RECORD IN NINETEEN NINETY
WE SERVED FOURTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE. WITH AND MUCH PALM SOLD
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ACRE FEET.
TODAY WE SERVE NINETEEN MILLION
PEOPLE AND WE'RE GONNA SELL ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION ACRE FEET.
WE'VE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE OUR
RELIANCE ON IMPORTED WATER WATER
FROM THE DELTA. BUT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE REPLACED OVERNIGHT
UP A DIESEL PLANTS.
WOULD BE BETWEEN LA AND SAN
DIEGO TO REPLACE OUR STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER WOULD BE A DIESEL
PLANT EVERY THREE MILES IT WOULD
TAKE FIFTY DIESEL PLANTS OVER
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS TO DO THAT
WITH THE CELL ON. THERE SIMPLY
ISN'T THE ABILITY TO REPLACE
THIRTY PERCENT OF YOUR WATER
SUPPLY IN A GENERATION WITH
THOSE OTHER TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
SO ALL THAT OUR BOARD IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO INVEST.
WHEN WE PASSED OUR APRIL BOARD
UP ACTION TO BILL INVEST TEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
HELL WATER FIX. WE PASSED OUR
SECOND LARGEST AMOUNT OF
CONSERVATION FUNDING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WE'RE PUTTING
INTO CONSERVATION OVER THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE. WE ALSO INVESTED
IN A THE LARGEST REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PLANT IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH LA COUNTY SAN
DISTRICTS AND WE COMMITTED
FINANCING TO THAT. SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO AN OLD THE ABOVE
FINANCING APPROACH.
BUT CALIFORNIA WATER SIX IS PART
OF THAT NECESSARY PORTFOLIO IN A
CLIMATE CHANGE WORLD FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
A.
IT DIDN'T MAKE IT LOOK GOOD OF A
MISCARRIAGE IT JUST INTERESTING
I MEAN.
IT TALK ABOUT HOW. MUCH
WHAT WE USED TO USE AND HOW MUCH
REASON NOW ANNA MEAN THAT THE
SAME COULD BE SAID FOR ANYTHING
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES AND IF
WE DON'T JUST LOOK AT ONE
SOLUTION. THAT MANY OTHER THINGS
OPEN UP HOW OFTEN ALSO OFFER YOU
PROBABLY IN NINETEEN NINETY YOU
ARE DRIVING A CAR THAT GOT FIVE
TO. TEN MILES TO THE GALLON AND
NOW YOU'RE PROBABLY DRIVING ONE
THAT YOU DID NOT USE ANY GAS
RIGHT.
POTENTIALLY SOME TO SING BUT
OVER THE OVER THE SCANNING YEARS
AS WE GRAPPLE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE THE WAY WE USE OUR
RESOURCES CHANGES.
HELLO MISTER.
THANK GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY BY NAME JENNIFER PIERRE
AND I SERVE AS THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS. A WE ARE AN AGENT
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS I'M
TWENTY SEVEN PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES THAT BRING WATER
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
FINE YOU JUST HEARD FROM MR KITE
WINGER HE IS HE REPRESENTS ONE
OF OUR LARGEST MEMBERS
METROPOLITAN BUT. WE ACTUALLY OF
OUR ORGANIZATION OF LARGE AND
SMALL PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES.
THAT ARE VERY DIVERSE
REPRESENTING URBAN AND
AGRICULTURAL. A REGION'S.
SEVERAL OF THEM INCLUDE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING AREAS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE MOJAVE DESERT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE.
HOWEVER TOGETHER WE DO STRIVE TO
DELIVER CLEAN RELIABLE SAFE
WATER IN THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
MANNER POSSIBLE.
IN ADDITION TO DELIVERING WATER
WE ALSO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN SCIENCE AND
RESEARCH PARTICULAR IN THE DELTA
AND ITS TRIBUTARIES. WE ANNUALLY
SPEND OUT OF MY ORGANIZATION TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO DIRECTLY FUND SCIENTIFIC
ACTIVITIES AND RESEARCH TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE DELTA
INCLUDING INVESTING IN THINGS
LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL DNA
UNDERSTANDING ON HOW. FOOD I'M
IS.
MOVING IN THE DELTA HOW FISHER
USING IT.
AS WELL AS HELPING TO IMPLEMENT
THE DELTA SMELT AND SALMON
RESILIENCY STRATEGIES I AM PROUD
TO REPRESENT THIS ORGANIZATION
THAT'S MAKING THESE COMMITMENTS.
JUST OVERVIEW THE STATE WATER
PROJECTS I'M IT IS A COMPLEX
NETWORK OF CANALS AND RESERVOIRS.
OF PUMPING FACILITIES TUNNELS
HYDROELECTRIC PLANTS AND
RESERVOIRS AND IT WAS ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED SIXTY YEARS AGO.
TODAY TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE THEIR WATER FROM THIS
PROJECT. AND THAT INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
AND OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND IS
IRRIGATED USING STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER.
HOWEVER IT'S NOT A GUARANTEE
THAT THIS WILL BE ON PROVIDED IN
THE FUTURE. AND AS SUCH WE DO
BELIEVE WE NEED TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE TO
PROVIDE THIS RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY.
WE ARE FACING ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP A LOT TODAY IN TERMS OF
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WE ALSO HAVE
AGING AND VULNERABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH I THINK
WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH. AND WE
HAVE A VOLATILE CLIMATE AHEAD
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF.
REPORTS AND ARTICLES ESPECIALLY
EVEN IN THE LAST WEEK AND IN
FACT TODAY IN THE BE ON WHAT
THIS A CLIMATE CHANGE EFFECTS
ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE AN
EXPERIENCING. THIS CLIMATE
WHIPLASH ESSENTIALLY BETWEEN
WETTON DRYERS REQUIRES THAT WE
THINK MORE CREATIVELY ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE IN ORDER
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AND MANAGE
AGAINST.
THAT WHIPLASH.
SO WE THINK WATER FIX DOES
PROVIDE THAT PRUDENT
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND FLEXIBLE
RELIABLE SOLUTION TO MANAGING
ABOUT FUTURE CONDITION.
I AS I DIRECTOR NEMETH MENTIONED
BE E. AYE ARE PREPARED BY W. ARE.
INCLUDES A MITIGATION OF MODERN
PLANETS THREE HUNDRED PAGES LONG.
IT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF ADOPTED
MEASURES THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT I'M HOUSE ADOPTED TO
AVOID AND MINIMIZE IMPACTS OF
THE PROJECT INCLUDING.
PROTECTING IN STABILIZING LEVEES
BEFORE CONSTRUCTION BEGINS IN
THE DELTA.
AS SHE ALSO MENTIONED THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO MINIMIZE IMPACTS
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL E. IR WHICH IS THE
WHOLE PURPOSE.
IS TO EVALUATE EFFECTS OF
REDUCED IMPACTS ON WETLANDS EVEN
BEYOND WHAT WAS ALREADY.
REDUCED IN THEIR.
ME THAT FIRST THE IR.
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF
MEASURES TO AVOID TO MITIGATE
THE LOCAL IMPACTS AS.
SHE ALSO MENTIONED THOSE
INCLUDE IMPACTS AGRICULTURAL
LANDS RECREATION AND
TRANSPORTATION.
ALONG WITH METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT ZONE SEVEN AND SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT TO
HAVE.
TAKEN VOTES TO SUPPORT THIS
PROJECT OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
THE BALANCE OF OUR AGENCIES
WILL CONSIDER THIS AND IN THEIR
PUBLIC. BOARD MEETINGS AS THEY
ARE PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES TO
MAKE THEIR RESPECTIVE DECISIONS.
THEY EACH HAVE TO CONSIDER THEIR
OWN LOCAL NEEDS THAT THE STATE
WATER PROJECT.
IS OF VARYING A PORTION OF
THEIR PORTFOLIOS SO THEY WILL
CONSIDER.
THIS WATER FIX AS PART OF THEIR
PORTFOLIO AND THEIR INVESTMENT
STRATEGY.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN COMMITTED IN
THEIR RESOLVE TO STUDYING THE
OPTIONS LOOK AT THE ALTERNATIVES.
AND AND MAKING THESE.
INVESTMENTS AND UP AND UP
PUBLIC AND OPEN MANNER.
I DID WANT TO TOUCH ON THE FACT
THAT WATER FIXES NOT OF THE ONLY.
PROJECT THAT THESE AGENCIES ARE
PURSUING.
AS I MENTIONED WE ARE
RICOCHETING BETWEEN DROUGHT AND
ATMOSPHERIC STORMS.
REQUIRED US TO THINK OUTSIDE THE
BOX AND HOW THESE AGENCIES ARE.
MANAGING THEIR OWN PORTFOLIOS.
SO WHILE WATER FIX IS.
ADVANCING OUR AGENCIES CONTINUE
TO MAKE INVESTMENTS AND OTHER
PROJECTS
WE'RE NOT PICKING ONE SOLUTION
OVER ANOTHER.
OF WE'VE IN FACT I'M RATHER MORE
STORAGE WAS BROUGHT UP ELEVEN OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTOR
MEMBER AGENCIES ARE CURRENTLY
INVESTED IN THE SIGHTS OF THE OR.
SO THEY ARE LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS OF.
PROTECTING THE WHAT THEIR WATER
SUPPLIES
IN FACT.
EVEN THE STABLE WATER SUPPLY
THE SURFACE SUPPLY THAT WATER
FIX WILL ESSENTIALLY STABILIZE.
IS NEEDED TO STABILIZE GROUND
WATER BASINS THAT THE REALLY Q.
FACTOR IN THE ABILITY FOR SIGNAL
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHAT OUR OTHER
AGENCIES ARE DOING.
FOR EXAMPLE DOESN'T WATER AGENCY
IS NOW RECYCLING ALMOST ALL OF
ITS WASTE WATER FOR IRRIGATION.
AND PERCOLATES ITS TREATED WASTE
WATER RECHARGE THE LOCAL
GROUNDWATER BASIN AND PUSHES
AGGRESSIVELY ON ITS CONSERVATION
AWARENESS PROGRAMS.
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IS IMPLEMENTING A GROUND WATER
REPLENISHMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT. IN ADDITION TO MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF CONSERVATION
PROGRAM FUNDING AND AN
AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO PUT MORE
CUSTOMERS ON RECYCLED WATER.
THE SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IS
INVESTED MILLIONS AND WHETHER
BASED IRRIGATION CONTROLLERS
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE PROGRAMS
TURF REMOVAL. CONSERVATION
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND
DEMONSTRATION GARDENS IN REBATES
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY HAS INVESTED
IN RECHARGE FACILITIES IN
MULTIPLE GROUND WATER BASINS.
AND DEVELOP STORAGE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE RELIABLE SUPPLIES.
IN PARALLEL THEY'VE EXECUTED
AGGRESSIVE CONSERVATION THROUGH.
MEASURES RESULTING IN A THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT DECLINE IN PER
CAPITA BECAUSE PER CAPITAL GAINS.
SO WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO DO
MORE LOCALLY AND THEY WELL IT
DOESN'T MEAN NEGATE THE NEED FOR
A LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR THE
STATE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATIONAL SUPPLY.
SO I THINK WITHOUT.
ALL BE OPEN FOR QUESTIONS OR
WE'RE GOING.
EGGMAN MISTER UNTIL HE.
MORNING CHAIRMAN CHAIRWOMAN
EGGMAN AND.
CHAIR.
CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND MEMBERS
COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE I'M DONNA TOLD HIM A LONG
TIME MEMBER THE SECOND COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ON BEHALF THE
DELTA COUNTIES COALITION THIS
MORNING.
COMPRISED OF THE TOWNS OF
SACRAMENTO YELLOW SOLANO SAN
JOAQUIN CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES.
WE REPRESENT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS
FIVE ARE THOUSAND WHO LIVE AND
WORK IN THE DELTA.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION
THAT YOU AS LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
ARE GIVING TO THE WATER
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES IN OUR
REGION OR STATE THE FOCUS YOU
BRING TO IT THIS MORNING.
RECENTLY I PROVIDED TESTIMONY AT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
AS A PART OF THE.
A PHASE TWO OF THE CHANGE
APPOINT DIVERSION PROCESS.
AT THAT HEARING I DISCUSS THE
REASONS THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN DELTA.
ARE IMPORTANT TO THE REGION AND
TO THE ENTIRE STATE WHY IT
WARRANTS LONG TERM PROTECTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY AS REFLECTED IN
TWO DAYS DISCUSSION PRESENTATION.
I THINK IT'S APPARENT THAT THE
STATE A PART A WATER RESOURCES
AND HIS PARTNERS.
INTENDED CONTINUE PRESSING
FORWARD BUT THE PERMITTING
PROCESS AN AUTOMATIC CONSTRUCT
THE TWIN TUNNELS.
FOR TEN YEARS
THE FIVE DELTA COUNTIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY VOICE OUR CONCERNS.
BUT THE STATE'S LESS THAN
TRANSPARENT EFFORT TO FIX THE
DELTA.
FIRST WITH A BEADY CP.
AND NOW WITH CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX.
JOSE MAKE NO MISTAKE.
PROPOSED PROJECT WELL FAR
REACHING.
NEGATIVE AN EVERLASTING IMPACTS
TO THE.
TO THE DELTA.
ESSENTIALLY WE BELIEVE IT
AMOUNTS TO WATER GRAB.
IT PUTS THE FIVE DELTA COUNTIES
IN THE CROSS HAIRS OF A LONG
LIST OF IRREVERSIBLE IMPACTS.
SOME OF THOSE IMPACTS INCLUDE.
IRREVERSIBLE CHANGES TO THE WAY
OF LIFE IN THE DELTA.
YOU IN GREAT PART TO THE
INCESSANT OFF THE ROUND THE
CLOCK TRUCK TRAFFIC.
NORWAY'S AIR QUALITY DEGRADATION
IT CARRIER DETERIORATED ROADWAY
CONDITIONS THE VARIETY OF
CONSTRUCTION LATE ACT IMPACTS
SOME OF THEM LAST A DECADE OR
EVEN LONGER.
IMPACT AGRICULTURE.
ECONOMICALLY IT WILL AFFECT IN
DESTRUCTIVE PROP SALES THE
PRODUCTION.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IMPACT
THE ENTIRE REGIONAL FARM ECONOMY
IN THE DELTA.
IT ALSO DEGRADES THE
RECREATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
RESOURCES.
VIA THE NORWAY'S BE.
ACCESS ISSUES THE DEGREE OF
INTEGRATION OF AND VISUAL
INTRUSION TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
RIVER NILE DELEGATION WILL BE SO
VERY CONSTRAINED ESPECIALLY NEAR
THE PROPOSED INTAKE LOCATIONS
FOR YEARS ON END.
I THINK LASTLY THERE MANY
IMPACTS BUT SONY LOST DELTA'S
GENERATION.
IT ALL ALONG.
IT LEGACY ALL MANY MANY
GENERATIONS OLD LONG LEGACY
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THEIR
COMMUNITIES OF HEARD. CORTLAND
LOCK IN WHILE THE GROVE.
THE LIVELIHOOD OF THE PEOPLE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN MIND.
THE CALL THE DELTA HOME ARE
WORTHY OF LONG TERM PROTECTIONS.
IT SHOULDN'T BE SUBJECTED TO
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS OF
UNBEARABLE CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS.
THE SEGMENT OF SILICON DELTA
REFORM ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINE.
ESTABLISHED A CO EQUAL GOALS AS
ALL OF YOU KNOW. IT MANDATED
ESTABLISHED A POLICY TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON WATER EXPORTS THE
DELTA.
ENCOURAGED INVESTMENT IN
ALTERNATIVE REGIONAL WATER
SUPPLIES THAT WAS DISCUSSED
EARLIER BY MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
CALIFORNIA WATER FIXES FOCUSED
ON INCREASING WATER EXPORTS FROM
THE DELTA AND DOES NOT.
I DON'T BELIEVE ACKNOWLEDGE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE TO REDUCE
DIVERSIONS INVEST AND REGAL
SUPPLIES.
I MUST SAY WE ARE VERY SKEPTICAL
OF HOW. WELL THEY WILL ATTEMPT
TO PROVE AS I HEARD EARLIER.
REDUCE RELIANCE ON THE DELTA
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX
PERMITTING PROCESS.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE BETTER MORE
COST EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES TO
REDUCE RELIANCE ON THE DELTA AND
ADDRESS THE COLECO GOALS.
ALL ARE FREE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
DELTA AS WELL.
THESE COULD INCLUDE IN DO
INCLUDE INVESTING A STATEWIDE A
REGIONAL WATER STORY THAT WAS
DISCUSSED HERE THIS MORNING.
UPGRADE THE STATE WATER PROJECT
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH WE BELIEVE NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN OUT A HARD LOOK AT THAT.
INVESTING IN THE LEVY SYSTEM THE
CURLY EXIST.
I THINK THE BILL OFF THE LOSS
THAT EVEN WITH CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX AT LEAST FIFTY PERCENT A
TARGET RELY ON THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
YOU TRANSMIT AND CONVEY WATER
THROUGH THE DELTA.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS FROM
CONSERVATION OF WATER USE
EFFICIENCY.
WE NEED DEVELOP REASONABLE AND
EFFECTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION STRATEGIES.
A COMPREHENSIVE AND TRANSPARENT
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN MUST IN
OUR VIEW PROVIDE A SECURE WATER
SUPPLY. AND ASSURE THE QUALITY
AND RELIABILITY OF SUPPLY.
AND NOT JUST FORGET SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR OTHER REASONS A
STATE BEFORE THE FORM DOING
CALIFORNIANS WHO RESIDE IN OUR
FIVE COUNTIES IN THE DELTA.
WE SHOULD ALL AGREE THAT THE
DELTA IS A VERY SPECIAL PLACE
IN ACKNOWLEDGE IT BECAUSE HOME
TO MANY PRECIOUS IN UNIQUE
RESOURCES.
BUT BE NO REDIRECTED ADVERSE
IMPACTS ASSOCIATE WITH A WATER
SUPPLY SOLUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
IN OTHER WORDS DON'T SACRIFICE A
DELTA
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OTHER REGIONS
OF THE STATE.
ALL THIS REPEAT WHAT I DON'T
SACRIFICE THE DELTA.
TO BENEFIT OTHER REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE DELTAS
RESOURCE IS A STATEWIDE ASSETS.
ARE PROTECTED FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME.
IS DEEPLY TROUBLING TO HEAR THIS
MORNING THAT JOINT POWER
AUTHORITIES WILL BE FORMED WITH
NO LOCAL REPRESENTATION.
AND THERE WILL NOT ONLY OUT
INSULT INJURY. BY CONSTRUCTING A
PROJECT BUT THEY WILL DESIGN
BUILD AND FINANCE THE PROJECT
THERE ARE FRONT AND BACKYARDS.
WE SUPPORT THE STATE
LEGISLATURES A ROLL AND
CERTAINLY RESPECTED IN
PROTECTING THE DELTA. AND WE
SUPPORT YOUR OVERSIGHT AND I CAN
ENGAGEMENT IN THIS PROCESS.
IN OUR VIEW THERE IS NO DEBATE.
THIS DOCUMENT SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
IS A VALUABLE IN IRREPLACEABLE
RESOURCE WHAT MANY.
SPECIAL ATTRIBUTES.
IT WARNS LONG TERM PROTECTIONS.
ANY FUTURE WATER MANAGEMENT OR
LAND USE POLICY CHANGES SHOULD
NOT IN OUR VIEW CANNOT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DIMINISHMENT
OR DESTRUCTION OF THE DELTA.
WE DESERVE BETTER THAN THE
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX.
AND SO DOES ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND ALL OF HIS MEMBERS
THE OPPORTUNITY ADDRESS YOU.
IN ANY EVENT YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY
DONE SO AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF
YOU RESIDE IT'S ONLY HAVE DONE
SO RESIDE ADULT IT DOES SO.
THE DELTA COUNTY'S COALITION
WELCOMES YOU TO FOR TWO OR THE
DELTA TO EXPERIENCE THE AWESOME
WONDER. THIS VERY SPECIAL PLACE.
THAT WE KNOW IS WORTH PROTECTING
AND SAVING.
WE WANT TO BE APART A SOLUTION
WE STAND READY TO BE A PARTNER.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THE PRINT
TITLES A CALIFORNIA WATER FIX IS
THE ANSWER.
THANK YOU MUCH SUPERVISOR.
I'M PRUNING.
MR.
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DOUG BG I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN IT WHEN
I FIRST BEGAN WORKING ON THE BAY
DELTA CONSERVATION PLAN THAT
BECAME WATER FIX.
AN RTC STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
WATER FIX PROJECT BECAUSE FOR
THREE REASONS WHICH I WANT TO
DISCUSS TODAY.
FIRST THE PROJECT IS ACTUALLY
WORSE THAN THE DEGRADED STATUS
QUO FOR FISH THAT MIGRATE
THROUGH THE DELTA DESPITE HOW
BAG CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE.
SECOND THE FINANCING FOR THIS
PROJECT WILL DIVERT MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING AWAY FROM REALISTIC
LOCAL WATER SUPPLY SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL ENABLE REDUCE RELIANCE
ON THE PART ON THE DELTA. AND
THIRD. THAT THE FINANCING SCHEME
FOR WATER FIX APPEARS TO VIOLATE
STATE AND FEDERAL THE STATE LAWS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS
THAT RACE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE VALIDITY OF THE
FINANCING.
JUST A STEP BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN ENERGY C. ACTUALLY
PROPOSED WHAT WE CALL THE
PORTFOLIO ALTERNATIVE FOR THE
DELTA WHICH INCLUDED A SINGLE
TUNNEL AND NEW INTAKE ON THE
NORTH DELTA. NEW.
INVESTMENTS IN LEVY STABILITY
AND STORAGE SOUTH OF THE DELTA
AN OPERATING RULES THAT WOULD
REDUCE DIVERSIONS FROM THE DELTA
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT WOULD BE PAIRED
WITH INVESTMENTS IN LOCAL AND
REGIONAL WATER SUPPLIES. AND THE
STATE REFUSED TO EVEN STUDY THIS
AT ALL IT WAS REJECTED OUT OF
HAND SO ENERGY SEE DOES NOT HAVE
A FORMAL JUST SAY NO POSITION ON
THE TUNNELS.
WHAT WE HAVE EVALUATED THIS A
SPECIFIC PROJECT BEFORE US IN
THE SPECIFIC PROJECT IS BAD FOR
THE DELTA AND IS BAD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
THE BAY DELTA IS AN ECOLOGICAL
CRISIS
WE'VE WATCHED FISH AND WILDLIFE
THAT HAVE BEEN NATIVE TO THIS
AREA FOR GENERATIONS MILLENNIUM.
ON THE VERY BRINK OF EXTINCTION
DUE TO HABITAT LOSS OVER
DIVERSION OF WATER ENTRAINMENT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND OTHER FACTS.
AND YET DESPITE HOW BAD THE
STATUS QUO IS.
AND IT'S REALLY BAD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY WHEN WE
INITIATED CONSULTATION TO REDO
THOSE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS FROM
TWO THOUSAND ANDTWO THOUSAND
NINE. BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
IMPLEMENTED DURING THE DROUGHT
AND BECAUSE THEY HAVE FAILED TO
PROTECT LISTED SPECIES.
AND YET DESPITE HOW BAD THE
STATUS QUO IS FOR NATIVE FISH
LIKE SALMON. WATER FIX IS
ACTUALLY WORSE.
THE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS AND THE
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT ISSUED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE MAKE CLEAR.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX
PROJECT WILL REDUCE SURVIVAL OF
SALMON THROUGH THE DELTA COMING
DOWN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
DESPITE HOW BAD CONDITIONS ARE
TODAY.
WILL REDUCE THE ABUNDANCE OF
LONG THIN SMELT A STATE THREAT
LISTED THREATENED SPECIES.
DUE TO INCREASED DIVERSIONS.
IT WILL HARM AND REDUCE THE
ABUNDANCE OF DELTA SMELL.
SO FOR THE MOST CRITICALLY
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA
WATER FIX IS ACTUALLY WORSE THAN
THE STATUS QUO.
AND ALSO HARM FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON WHICH FORM THE BACKBONE
OF THE STATE'S SALMON FISHERY.
TODAY THE US FISH WILDLIFE
SERVICE ISSUED A BIOLOGICAL
OPINION THAT AMAZINGLY ONLY
COVERS PART OF THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THIS PROJECT IT DOES NOT EVEN
AUTHORIZE OPERATION OF THIS
PROJECT.
AND THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE BIOLOGICAL
OPINION ONLY OPERATE AUTHORIZES
OPERATIONS TO THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH IS BEFORE THE
PROJECT WOULD EVEN BE COMPLETELY
CONSTRUCTED.
AND SO IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
PERMITS FOR THIS PROJECT REALLY
DO NOT PROVIDE OPERATIONS IN THE
LONG TERM OR ANY CERTAINTY ABOUT
WATER SUPPLY.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES TO THOSE EXISTING
PERMITS AND TO THE SECRET
DOCUMENTS MORE THAN TWENTY
PARTIES HAVE FILED.
LITIGATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
AND IN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT.
US SEVERAL PARTIES INCLUDING
PARTIES REPRESENTED BY THAT
AFTER RESOURCE DEFENSE COUNSEL
HAVE CHALLENGE THOSE FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS AS WELL AS
THE STATE CALIFORNIA.
SHE'S MADE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT PERMITS.
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THERE
ARE NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES
THERE'S A GREAT LIKELIHOOD THAT
ONE OR MORE OF THOSE LITIGATION
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL IN
INVALIDATING PERMITS BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY DO NOT PROTECT. OUR
ENDANGERED FISH AND WILDLIFE.
MOREOVER.
AS YOU HEARD THIS MORNING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD IS STILL CONSIDERING THE
PETITION TO CHANGE THE POINT A
DIVERSION. AND THE BOARD HAS THE
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
IMPOSE APPROPRIATE FOR CRITERIA
WHICH ARE TO BE INFORMED BY HE
TWENTY TEN PUBLIC TRUST FLOWS
REPORT. WHICH REQUIRED WHICH
FOUND THAT THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE.
WOULD JUSTIFY SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN DIVERSIONS AND
INCREASE FLOWS THROUGH THE DELTA
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AS A RESULT WE BELIEVE THE
SCIENCE IS VERY CLEAR THAT IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
THIS ESTUARY WE NEED TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA AND REDUCE
DIVERGENCE AND INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF WATER FLOWING THROUGH
THE ESTUARY. AND YET WATER FIX
DOES THE OPPOSITE.
ANY PARTICULAR WATER FIX
PROPOSES TO INCREASED DIVERSIONS
DURING THE DRY AND CRITICALLY
DRY YEARS AND ACTUALLY WILL NOT
INCREASED DIVERGENCE DURING THE
WET YEARS. BECAUSE WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL SOUTH ADULT OF
STORAGE WE SIMPLY CAN'T MOVE
MORE WATER IN A YEAR LIKE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
SECOND THERE ARE.
SIGNIFICANT COST EFFECTIVE LOCAL
SUPPLY OPTIONS.
TYPICALLY IN URBAN AREAS
THAT THE FUNDING FOR WATER FIX
JEOPARDIZES.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY AND
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
HISTORICALLY VOTING AGAINST
FUNDING BETWEEN TUNNELS PROJECTS
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS THAT THIS
PROJECT WOULD ACTUALLY DIVERT
THE NEEDED FUNDING AWAY FROM
THOSE SOLUTIONS LIKE INCREASED
WATER RECYCLING STORM WATER
CAPTURE. IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AND
OTHER LOCAL SUPPLY PROJECTS.
AS YOU HEARD THE DELTA REFORM
ACT REQUIRES US TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA. AND AN
RTC HAS PREPARED A NUMBER OF
REPORTS IN RECENT YEARS
INCLUDING OUR TWENTY FOURTEEN
UNTAPPED POTENTIAL REPORT. WHICH
IDENTIFIED MILLIONS OF ACRE FEET
OF POTENTIAL NEW WATER SUPPLIES
FROM WHICH WATER RECYCLING
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AND STORM
WATER CAPTURE. AND ARE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MISMATCH REPORT WHICH
FOUND THAT AS COMPARED TO THEM
URBAN WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS OF
ITS MEMBER AGENCIES.
METROPOLITANS URBAN WATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN OVERESTIMATES
DEMAND FOR IMPORTED WATER
UNDERESTIMATES LOCAL SUPPLIES
AND CREATES THE PERSON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE.
DIVERSIONS FROM THE DELTA WHILE
SUSTAINING THE ECONOMY.
WHAT A FIX IS GOING TO COST
WATER DISTRICTS TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT FORTY
YEARS?
THE ESTIMATED TOTAL COSTS
INCLUDING FINANCING IS AS MUCH
AS FORTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
OR MORE.
AND THAT FUNDING IS MONEY THAT
CANNOT BE SPENT ON THESE LOCAL
SUPPLY PROJECTS.
FINALLY WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE FINANCING SCHEME FOR WATER
FIX VIOLATE STATE LAW.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES FILE
THE ACTION IN SACRAMENTO
SUPERIOR COURT TO VALIDATE.
NEARLY ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
BONDS TO PAY FOR THE FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE SHARE OF WATER
FIXED COSTS THAT IT WAS
ANTICIPATED THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WILL PAY FOR.
HOWEVER AS YOU'VE HEARD THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
CONTRACTORS HAVE REFUSED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION IS NOT PARTICIPATE.
AS A RESULT METROPOLITAN IS
VOTED TO PAY FOR NEARLY TWICE A
THEIR ORIGINAL INVESTMENT IN
WATER FIX.
PAYING FOR NEARLY TEN BILLION OR
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
TOTAL COST
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD
ONLY GET TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE WATER SUPPLY FROM THIS
PROJECT.
THAT RAISES SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT A. WHETHER METROPOLITANS
VOTE ACTUALLY IS PROTECTING
RATEPAYERS ORDERS PUTTING
REPAIRS IN VIOLATION OF
PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN OR
TWENTY SIX BY PAYING FOR MORE
THAN THEIR SHARE OF THE PROJECT.
IN ADDITION.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
THAT THE FINANCING FOR THIS
PROJECT ASSUMES THAT STATE WATER
PROJECT CONTRACTORS CAN CONTINUE
TO PAY FOR IT THROUGH. PROPERTY
TAXES AT LOWER PROPERTY TAXES
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL. THERE
ARE LEGITIMATE ARGUMENTS THAT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN PROHIBITS
THAT WITHOUT A VOTE OF THE
PUBLIC. THE NINETEEN SEVENTY A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
REQUIRES THAT ABOUT TO THE
PUBLIC BE. BE MADE BEFORE THERE
ARE BONDED INDEBTEDNESS TO PAY
FOR THE ACQUISITION OR
IMPROVEMENT OF REAL PROPERTY.
IN THE VALIDATION ACTION ENERGY
SEE AS ONE OF MANY PARTIES WHO
IS CONTESTING DELIVERY OURS AT
THE ALREADY HAS RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT THESE. ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
AND STATUTORY PROTECTIONS FOR
RATEPAYERS AND TAXPAYERS.
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES FILED
A DEMURRER TO THOSE TO ARE
ANSWER WHICH WAS DENIED AND WE
EXPECT THIS LITIGATION WILL
CONTINUE.
ULTIMATELY ENERGY SHE OPPOSES
THE WATER FIX PROJECT BECAUSE IT
IS WORSE THAN THE STATUS QUO
ENVIRONMENTALLY. BECAUSE IT
DIVERTS MUCH NEEDED FUNDING AWAY
FROM REALISTIC SOLUTIONS AND
BECAUSE THE FINANCING SCHEME
APPEARS TO BE INVALID AND RAISES
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET
ITS. CO EQUAL GOALS OF IMPROVING.
OF THE DELTA ECOSYSTEM AND
REDUCING RELIANCE ON THE DELTA
WHILE SUSTAINING WATER SUPPLIES
AND THE ECONOMY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RESERVE.
GOOD MORNING I'M I'M OCEAN
OBSERVE I REPRESENT FRIENDS OF
STONE LAKES NATIONAL WILDLIFE
REFUGE. A LOCAL AGENCIES OF THE
NORTH DELTA IN IN THE LITIGATION
THAT I'M MISTER BIJAN MENTIONED
ABOUT THE SEQUEL REVIEW. AND MY
REPRESENT FOR THE FIVE DELTA
COUNTIES AS WELL. I'M AND.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO JUST ADD ON
AND NOT REPEAT TO WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN SAID BUT IN GENERAL THIS
PROJECT SHOULD BE JUDGED IN IT
IS A MEGA PROJECT BECAUSE THE
COST IS IN THE BILLIONS. AND IT
SHOULD BE JUDGED ON THE MERITS
OF WHAT IT CAN DELIVER IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER OPTIONS NOT
EMOTIONAL SCARE TACTICS ABOUT
WHAT MAY HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE.
AND YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS BEFORE THAT
CONSERVATION AND OTHER
ALTERNATIVES IF FOR FULLY.
DEVELOPED CAN DELIVER THE WATER
THAT THE STATE NEEDS.
NOW.
WITH RESPECT TO THE MOUNTAIN OF
ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS I
JUST WANT TO STRESS THIS IS NOT
A BENIGN PROJECT I'VE HEARD THAT
TERM USED A LOT. AN IT IS NOT
BENIGN AND I THINK SUPERVISOR
NATOLI HAS MADE THAT CLEAR.
AND EVEN IF THE NUMBER OF ACRES
OF WETLANDS FILL GOES DOWN TO A
FEW HUNDRED RATHER THAN SEVEN OR
EIGHT HUNDRED THAT'S STILL THE
LARGEST FILL OF WETLANDS THAT
WE'VE HEARD OF IN THE STATE.
I'M THERE'S ALSO MASSIVE ENERGY
DEMANDS.
I HAD A HANDOUT ACTUALLY I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT WENT OUT.
HOW PERFECT OKAY SO THAT SHOWS
HOW IT LAYS DOWN ON THE STONE
MAKES NATIONAL WILDLIFE REFUGE
AND YOU CAN KIND OF SEE HOW IT
SQUEEZING OTHER REFUGE IN
BETWEEN THE EXPANDING OUT GROVE
AND THE DELTA WHICH IS?
LARGELY PROTECTED AREA I'M FOR
BIRDS.
SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE.
STANHOPE CRANES WHICH WE'VE GOT
A PICTURE OF OUT ON THE SECOND
PAGE
I AM AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF FISH IN THE
NORTH DELTA AND SOMETIMES YOU
MAY HEAR. IT SPOKEN OF AS THOUGH
ITS AVOIDING FISH BY HAVING
THESE MASSIVE DIVERSIONS WHICH
HAVE GOT A PICTURE OF A MOCK UP
THERE FROM THE ER. THAT THAT
THERE WILL BE AWAY FROM FISH
THERE MAY BE FEWER SMELT IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF OTHER FISH AND LIKE MR
OBG MENTIONED. AS SEVERAL
SPECIES OF PROTECTED FISH ARE
GOING TO BE LIKELY TO ADVERSELY
BE AFFECTED.
AND THEN IN ADDITION OURS
FALL RUN CHINOOK SALMON IS IS
VERY THREATENED BY THIS AND AND
I THINK AND PETROLEUM CERTAIN
ITALY MENTIONED BY A NEEDS TO BE
EMPHASIZED THAT THE BETTER WATER
QUALITY THAT YOU HEAR. THE WATER
CONTRACTORS IN GW ARE TALKING
ABOUT FOR EXPORTS COMES AT A
SPECIFIC COST
TO THE WATER QUALITY FOR THE
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN THE IN
OUR AREA. IN A LOT OF THOSE AND
I'VE GOT A LITTLE CHART.
OUR LIVE ON PAGE THREE.
THAT SHOWS WHAT HAPPENS IT WITH
THAT THEY HAVEN'T EVEN REALLY
LOOKED AT CAREFULLY WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE WATER SUPPLIES FOR
STOCKTON FOR INSTANCE.
I'M.
SO.
IN IN THERE'S NO PLAN ALSO YOU
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE IDEA OF
DIVERTING AT HIGH FLOWS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CHART ON THE
THIRD PAGE. ACTUALLY JUNE TO NOVEMBER PERIOD IN A
BELOW NORMAL YEAR
AND SO ACCORDING TO THE PETITION
BEING PRESENTED AT THE WATER
BOARD THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF RIGHT NOW. THERE IS NO
OPERATIONAL PLAN THAT SAYS WE
ONLY DIVERT DURING HIGH FLOWS
AND SO THIS IS VERY CONCERNING
WITH RESPECT TO THE FISH WITH
RESPECT TO THE OTHER WATER USERS
IN THE AREA. AND THEN ALSO WITH
RESPECT TO HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS
WHICH IS AN INCREASING CONCERN
AS.
TEMPERATURES WARM I WARM AND
AND AND THOSE MUNICIPAL WATER
SUPPLIES THAT ARE IMPACTED ARE
OFTEN WILL THOSE LEAST ABLE TO
PAY AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS STOCKTON IN
ANTIOCH IN PARTICULAR. I'M AND
I'VE HEARD THE GROUNDWATER
MENTIONED AS WELL BUT I THINK
IT'S BEEN PART OF THE WATER
BOARD PROCEEDING WE'VE SHOWN
THAT GROUND WATER LEVELS IN THE
VICINITY.
IN SACRAMENTO IN THE EAST
AMERICAN SUBBASIN SOUTH AMERICAN
SUBBASIN AS WELL AS THE SAN
JOAQUIN SUBBASIN ARE IMPACTED BY
THE DIVERSIONS OF WATER BECAUSE.
SO MUCH WATER WOULD BE TAKEN OUT
THAT THE WATER LEVEL IN THE
RIVER LITERALLY GOES DOWN.
SO.
I AM.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ALSO THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR INSTANCE FOR THE
TUNNELS FROM PETER MORE OIL BUT
BUT THE BUT THE U. SIDEBOARDS HE
PUT AROUND THAT NEVER REALLY GET
DISCUSSED. THE SCREENING
TECHNOLOGY.
IS IS VERY.
IS NOT DEVELOPED.
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT IS RELIED
UPON FOR THE FUTURE WHICH WE
DON'T KNOW HOW IT WOULD BE
MANAGED THERE'S A HUGE RANGE OF
OPERATIONS THAT ARE POSSIBLE AND
THE CONTRACTORS AND YOU HAVE YOU
ARE. ARE JUST SAYING WE'LL TAKE
CARE ABOUT DON'T WORRY.
SO AND THEN YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN NO DUE DILIGENCE ON
CARRYING OUT THE RESTORATION
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO HELP FISH
EVEN BACK FROM THE TEN YEARS OLD
BIOLOGICAL OPINION SO THERE'S
JUST NOT A GOOD TRACK RECORD
HERE. FOR DOING THE THINGS THAT
THAT THESE FOLKS SAY THEY WILL
DO SO WE'VE GOT SEVERE RATE
PAYER RISKING TAXPAYER RISK
GOING ON WE'VE GOT FUNDS
DIVERTED FROM OTHER INVESTMENTS
THAT WE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
PROVIDE WATER. AND THEN WE'VE
GOT IT BECAUSE OF THE SUM COST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED EVEN MORE PRESSURE TO
DIVERT WATER FROM THE DELTA THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE. SO S.
SUPERVISOR NATOLI MENTIONED WE
NEED TO WORK ON THE LEVEES THERE
AS THEY.
DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION HAS
ESTIMATED THAT THAT'S A ONE TO
TWO BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT
PROBABLY.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE CHANGES TO
THE EXISTING PUMPS THAT ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED.
BY THE A BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS IN
THAT PETER MOYAL IN HIS WHITE
PAPER ALSO SAYS SHOULD BE DONE.
AND AM THERE ARE POSSIBILITIES
OF POSSIBLE OTHER DIVERSIONS
MAYBE IN THE WEST OUT OF FOR
HIGH FLOWS WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT THOSE ALL THE
MONEY'S BEEN SPENT ON THIS ONE
PARTICULAR OPTION.
OR THE SUITE OF OPTIONS AROUND
IT SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE
CAN DO AND AND I WOULD ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DOES EXERCISE
CONTINUING OVERSIGHT OVER THIS
PROCESS YOUR HELP IS NEEDED TO
GET THIS ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND
TO GET US TOWARD THE KIND OF
SOLUTIONS. THAT WE CAN HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT AND
THIS IS THAT THE VISIT PROJECT
PROP PROJECT THAT WILL JUST
DIVIDE CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE IS THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTOR AMENDMENT PROSPECTS
THAT'S UNDER WAY NOW AND THAT
DOES REQUIRE A LOOK AT HEARING
HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE.
TO INFORM REGARDING.
THE AMENDMENTS AND IN ADDITION
A WATER COULD SECTION ONE FORTY
SEVEN REQUIRES ANNUAL REPORTING
TO THIS BODY.
REGARDING THE BUDGET OF THE
WATER RESOURCES DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT ANNUAL REPORTING SHOULD BE
REQUIRED AS PART OF ANY.
HEARING THAT IS HELD IN
OVERSIGHT.
SO BECAUSE ESPECIALLY WITH
ORVILLE CRISIS AND THE FED
SAYING THEY MAY NOT PAY BECAUSE
THE STATE WATER PROJECT FAILED
TO MAINTAIN. AS THEY SHOULD HAVE
THEY REALLY THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO HAVE MORE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE STATE WATER PROJECT NOT
LESS
SO ALONG III ARE A LONG PROCESS
AND A LONG LIST OF MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT ARE LARGELY
UNENFORCEABLE.
DOES NOT MAKE THIS A GOOD
PROJECT
AND.
I THINK YOU'VE SEEN
UNPRECEDENTED WAVE OF AT EVERY
LEVEL ALL THE WAY DOWN FROM THE
LOCALS ALL THE WAY UP TO
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
FISCALLY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO TAXPAYERS AND
RATEPAYERS. ALL CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS PROJECT.
WE SHOULD PURSUE OTHER OPTIONS
PLEASE HELP US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. DAHLE
ALL PANEL TO.
.
THIS WOULD OPEN UP BUT JUST
MISTER CUDDLING HER BUT WHAT DO
YOU SEE AS THE MAIN RISKS.
TO MW DIS DECISION TO COVER
MORE THE PROJECT AND HOW DO YOU
PLAN TO MITIGATE THOSE RISKS.
SO ARE AMONG THE RISKS IN ANY
LARGE PROJECT TO COURSES PROJECT
MANAGEMENT CONSTRUCTION DELIVERY
THERE'S ALWAYS ISSUES PROTECT IT
WHEN YOU GET INTO TUNNELING WHEN
YOU GET INTO THE GROUND. A
METROPOLITAN HAS A GOOD TRACK
RECORD AYE IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WE COMPLETED BUILDING A TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
RESERVOIR THE LARGEST RESERVOIR
BUILT IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY. WE DID ON TIME
AND ON BUDGET.
WE ALSO THEN CONNECTED IT WITH
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
TUNNEL PROJECT. IT WAS NOT ON
TIME IT RAN INTO THE PLACE WE
RAN NTO A VERY DIFFICULT.
GROUND BUT WE ALSO DELIVERED IT
ON BUDGET.
AND SO WE DID MANAGE TO DO THAT
ON BUDGET. COUPLE YEARS TO LIFE.
WE'VE ALSO A DONE OVER A ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
RETROFIT OF ALL THE TREATMENT
FACILITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MOVING IT TO OZONE
TREATMENT
WE'VE DONE THAT ON BUDGET AS
WELL. SO WE KNOW HOW TO MANAGE
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS AND WE KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS. THAT WE THINK IS
THE STRENGTH OF THIS JPA
APPROACH WE'RE BRINGING IN
EXPERTISE OF AGENCIES LIKE MINE
THAT BUILD LARGE PROJECTS AND
PUT THEM AND TO MARRY WITH THE
W. OURS AUTHORITY. AND TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN DELIVER THIS ON TIME
AND ON BUDGET.
IT JUST SEEMS OVER YOU IF YOU'VE
DOUBLED THAT THE AMOUNT YOU'RE
WILLING TO PAY.
YOU HAVE TO MITIGATE THAT IN
SOME KIND OF WAY.
WELL RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALREADY
TALKING TO AGENCIES THAT WOULD
BE OF MOVING WATER THROUGH THAT
CAPACITY SO WE WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. A MOVE WATER THROUGH
THAT CAPACITY AND THEN BRENT
THAT OUT OR WE'LL WATER IN OTHER
WORDS PEOPLE COULD MOVE THAT.
YOU'VE SECOND PASS CITY AND A
CLIMATE CHANGE WORLD WE EXPECT
THERE'S GOING TO BE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE OF SANTA CLARA BY THEIR
ACTION THE OTHER DAY.
PUT TOGETHER AN OPTION THAT
THEIR BOARD OF AUTHORIZED TO GO
UP EFFECTIVELY PURCHASED TWO
HUNDRED CUBIC FEET PER SECOND OF
THAT THREE THOUSAND THAT WE
WOULD BE FINANCING. AND WE
EXPECT THE REST OF CENTRAL
VALLEY AND OTHER PARTNERS TO DO
THAT AS WELL.
IT WAS ALWAYS EARLIER YOU BANK
IT THEY BUY IT UPSET THE CONCEPT.
BANK IT A WINK WHAT YOU KNOW WE
WOULD NOT ACTUALLY BE MOVING
WATER SOUTH BECAUSE IT'S THEIR
WATER THEY WOULD BE CONTRACTING
WITH US FOR US TO MOVE IT FOR
THEM.
ACT.
CAN YOU TALK WITH THE GPAS AND
HOW DO YOU SEE.
THE PUBLIC HAVING INPUT INTO AND
AND THIS BODY HAVING INPUT AND
OVERSEEING US.
ABSOLUTELY I THESE JP IS WOULD
BE PUBLIC BODIES JP'S ARE PRETTY
COMMON IN DELIVERING LARGE SCALE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THE GOLD
LINE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MOST
OF OUR LIGHT RAIL PROJECTS HAVE
HAD STANDALONE JP HAS THAT HAVE
A. GOOD OVERSEEING THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION OF THEM THEY
ARE PUBLIC AGENCIES THEY MEET
THEY ARE MADE UP A PUBLIC AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES THING IS SUBJECT
TO THE BROWN ACT OF THE U. CAMP
PUBLIC COMMENT. THAT WOULD HAVE
A PUBLIC WEBSITE OLDER SPENDING
AGENDAS EVERYTHING WOULD BE
POSTED AND AVAILABLE AND THE
COURSE OF THIS LEGISLATURE AS
ANY PUBLIC AGENCIES FORM COULD
ALWAYS I HAVE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
AND AND REVIEW THE PROCESS.
I'M.
WE'RE GOING WE TALK ABOUT THE.
DELTA DEDUCTIBLES OF MAINTAIN
THE DELTA WATER CONVEYANCE I'M.
DOES THIS PLACE CAN YOU. WATCH
IT WITH THIS PROJECT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND AND I AND I
HAVE SAID THIS MULTIPLE TIMES
WERE JUST FOCUSING ON ONE
PROJECT WITHOUT LOOKING AT
WESTERN INTAKES WITHOUT LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT ALTERNATE WITHOUT
LOOKING AT STRENGTHENING OUR
LEVEES WITHOUT. LOOKING AT
ANYTHING ELSE SO THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY NOT GOING TOWARDS A LOT OF
TENSION NOT GOING TOWARDS IT
THREE CO EQUAL GOALS.
I MEAN HOW DO YOU I'M JUST VERY
SPECIFICALLY OR OR GENERALLY HOW
DO YOU SEE THAT THE CO EQUAL
GOALS.
BEING ADDRESSED THROUGH THIS
PROJECT.
IF YOU DO IT ALL.
YEAH BUT WHAT ABOUT START AM. I
MEAN I THINK.
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY WE
DON'T THINK IT MAKES THE
SUPPLIES MORE RELIABLE I'M FOR
ANYONE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW IF THIS
PROJECT CAN EVEN BE BUILT ON
TIME IT'S A MEGA PROJECT AND
WE'RE AT TEN PERCENT DESIGNED
SUPPOSEDLY THERE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A WATER RIGHTS HEARING
AND THE PROJECT HAS ALREADY
CHANGED SO MANY TIMES THAT WE
ARE APPARENTLY DELAYED IN. AYE
PREPARING REBUTTAL BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROJECT IS
RIGHT NOW.
SO IF THERE ISN'T A LOT OF
CERTAINTY AROUND THE PROJECT AT
ALL AND.
SO IN TERMS OF WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY WE THINK THAT THE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT AGENCIES CAN
AND DO. UP PUT ATTENTION ON
SHOULD HAVE THIS KIND OF
RESOURCES PUT BEHIND THAT AND
THAT COULD SUPPLY. LEVEL
RELIABILITY.
AND IN TERMS OF RESTORATION
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT.
MORE NATURAL FLOW PATTERNS I
WAS PLEASE DIRECTOR NEMETH IS A
LIMITED HER REMARKS TO THE SOUTH
DELTA WHICH MAY BE TRUE BUT IN
THE NORTH DELTA. IT THIS IS
GOING TO LITERALLY RUN THE RIVER
BACKWARDS UNDER CERTAIN
CONDITIONS IN EAST BAY MAD AND
OTHERS WITH OTHER LARGE INTAKES
IN THE AREA THAT AREN'T NEARLY
AS LARGE BUT THERE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
THAT. AND THEN IN TERMS OF WHAT
WAS NEGOTIATED TO BE THE THIRD
LEG OF THE STOOL. THE DELTA AS A
PLACE.
IT IT JUST GETS TRASHED I MEAN.
AND AND A JPA I MEAN SANTA CLARA
VOTED YESTERDAY TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEE
WHICH IS TOTALLY UNDEFINED THAT
WOULD APPARENTLY PROVIDE SOME
OVERSIGHT IN ADDITION TO. THE
ALREADY EXISTING MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT YOU HEARD MISS
PEER AND OTHERS HAVE REFERRED TO
BUT I MEAN THERE'S NO MEAT TO
ANY OF THIS IN ON THE WATER
QUALITY SIDE FOR IN DELTA. MOST
OF THE MITIGATION SAYS THEY WILL
WORK WITH THESE COMMUNITIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO ADDRESS.
THE WATER QUALITY THEY DON'T
COMMIT TO PROVIDING REPLACEMENT
SUPPLIES OR BROUGHT PROVIDING
THE INCREASED COST OF TREATMENT
FOR BROMIDE AND.
SALT SALT SO WE JUST DON'T SEE
IT.
AND WHO DO YOU THINK HAS THE
POWER TO CONTROL THE FLOWS AND
WITH THEM DIABETES. DECISION I
MEAN.
AND SO AND I KEEP COMING BACK TO
THIS ISSUE OF.
YOU'RE GONNA PAY A LOT MORE
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO. COMMIT TO
PROVIDE MORE WATER YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT IT SOLID OR WHATEVER BUT.
THERE IS UP THERE IS A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO NOT DO
THAT KIND OF.
RECYCLING RECLAMATION AND AND
OTHER THINGS IF WE ARE.
FULLY INVESTED IN IT IN THIS
THEN THERE HAS TO BE SOME KIND
OF WAY TO EVEN IT OUT FOR FOR
REPAIRS.
YEAH AND I THINK IT'S SORT OF
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE EXISTING SYSTEM TO LOOK AT
HOW MUCH PRESSURE GETS PUT ON
THE EXISTING SYSTEM TO EXPORT.
WHEN WARREN DROUGHT LOOK AT THE
WORD A BILL THAT YOU KNOW CHANGE
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR PROTECTION
OF SPECIES SO THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
ALREADY. AND I THINK IF THERE'S
BILLIONS MORE INVESTED.
AND BON PAIRS BEHIND NOT TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN MAKE MONEY
ON THEIR INVESTMENT. THEN YOU
KNOW IT REALLY GIVES US
CONCERNED ABOUT WATER BECOMING
MORE OF A PRIVATIZED ASSET WHERE
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN FISH AND
WILDLIFE ARE EVEN FARTHER DOWN
THE FOOD CHAIN.
M. THANK YOU AND AND THE.
SUPERVISOR NATOLI WHAT DO YOU
THINK ARE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
A AND RESIDENTS MOST SERIOUS
CONCERNS.
I THINK I'M THE LONG TERM
DEGRADATION TO THE DELTA A AS I
MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS AND I
WILL BE REPETITIVE BUT. ALL YOU
HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
SETTLED THE SAME TIME THE STATE
WAS SETTLED AND. OF FOLKS HAVE A
A MAJOR.
LIVELIHOODS AND LIVES IN THE
DELTA COMMUNITIES AND SOME OF
THOSE HAVE GROWN AND PROSPERED
ALONG WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WATER RISK IS KEYED
ALL THAT'S AN ACUTE OTHER
REGIONS THE STATE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT. BUT I THINK THAT THE SONY
THE CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS A BUILD
ME COMPRISES TEMPORAL BUT IN MY
VIEW TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS IS
NOT TEMPORARY THAT NET POINT
TIME YOU CAN HAVE.
SMALL BUSINESSES COLLAPSE COULD
HAVE DISRUPTION TO THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITIES RELEASED A FARMING
INTO ALL THE RELATED. ACTIVITIES
GO WITH THAT.
I THINK WE RUN THE RISK ALONG
WITH OTHER.
YEAH UNIX A COME DOWN RELATIVE
TO.
FLOOD ELEVATIONS INTO
LEGISLATION COMES THROUGH AS
RELATES TO.
LEVY PROTECTIONS ITSELF FOR
THAT YOU YOU OF FREEZE THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND TIME AND ALL
THAT YOU CAN CREATE GHOST TOWNS
I THINK FOLKS ARE VERY CONCERNED
THE RECREATIONAL DUST OF
DISRUPTION. ONE THE WATERWAYS.
IN IN IN IN IN IN IN CAN VERY
FRANKLY.
JOAN EGGMAN.
I THINK THAT.
IS OFTEN OVERSTATED IS TO OF
THE FRAGILITY OF THE DELTA THAT
YOU KNOW SOMEHOW IF THE.
YOU KNOW.
FLOODS IN IT AND SEE LEVEL RISE
DON'T GET YOU EARTHQUAKES WELL
THERE IS A RISK IS A RISK IN
EVERYTHING WE DO AND I THINK
FOLKS IN THE DELTA OF A
RESILIENT THEY ARE SUPPORTED BY.
THEIR LARGER BROADER COMMITTEES
IN THEIR COUNTIES IT CERTAINLY
IS AS A REASON THE STATE WE
RECOGNIZE THE CONVEYANCES.
IMPORTANT AND THAT YOU KNOW WE
BENEFITTED DEGREE THAT HILL VIA
IN DELTA SUPPLY ARE RECIPIENTS
OF A FRESH WATER SUPPLIES IT
MOVE THROUGH THE THING THAT
INVESTMENT OUGHT TO BE AND THAT
LEVY SYSTEM. TO UP DO THAT REYES
WERE MENTIONED SOME THE OTHER
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY BUT I THINK
THE LONG TERM I THINK THERE'S A
GREAT FEAR AND CRITICALLY
COMMUNITIES I COULDN'T CORTLAND
THAT ARE SMALL BEGIN WITH THAT.
YOU WILL NOT HAVE IT A LONG THAT
YOU KNOW I SAID EVERLASTING
AFFECT IT WILL CHANGE THE FACE
OF THE DELTA NOT JUST THE
AESTHETIC. BUT I THINK THE THE
THE THE THE LIFE AS WE KNOW IT
IT AFFECTED VARMINT WILL AFFECT
AGRICULTURE AFFECT RECREATION.
TO ME THAT IS A THAT WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS TERRIBLE LOSS I THINK
IS A FEW WASN'T PURSUED WHISPERS
THEY HAVE THINKER SO I MEAN TO
BASICALLY THIS IS GROUP DOES NOT
MYTHICAL RECALLS.
YEAH AND ARGUE IT DOES NOT I
THINK THAT YEAH AS YOU STATED
EARLIER THE CRITICAL GOALS THAT
IN AN EMPTY A VERY IMPORTANT
QUALIFIER IS A LAW THAT YOU
PROTECT. AND PRESERVE AND
ENHANCE THE DELTA AS INVOLVING
PLACE BUT WITH A QUICK
AGRICULTURAL ON HISTORICAL
RECREATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
VALUES.
I THINK YOU KNOW MISS IS THAT
MARK.
TERRIBLY.
MISTER BUDGET M. WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN
OVERSEEING THE GPAS AT THE
FINANCING CONSTRUCTION OF THAT.
I THINK THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT THE GPAS
ARE AWAY TO SHIFT LIABILITY AND
TO A.
REDUCE OVERSIGHT FROM THE
ELECTED BODIES OF WATER
DISTRICTS TO AN UNELECTED JPA.
AND THERE ARE REAL CONCERNS AS
WE'VE SEEN WITH OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTAIN BY THE
STATE WATER PROJECT OF THEIR
ABILITIES TO ACTUALLY MAINTAIN
IT PROPERLY AND TO OPERATE
PROPERLY.
IN ADDITION THERE IS A
AGREEMENT ON ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
FOR THE WATER FIX THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY PRIVILEGE THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS.
BEING IN THE ROOM WITH THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE AGENCIES DID OF YOU
ARE IN THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION
AND NO PUBLIC INTEREST NO
INTEREST AT THE DELTA. AND SO
WERE ONCE AGAIN SEEING WHAT
ALMOST APPEARS TO BE A PAY TO
PLAY OPPORTUNITY WHERE.
THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING THE
PROJECT GET TO HAVE GREATER
CONTROL NOT JUST OVER THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT BUT
THE ITS OPERATIONS.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY I I DO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT THIS
PROJECT REALLY FAILS A CO EQUAL
GOALS. IT IT REALLY DOES NOT A
RESTORE THE HEALTH OF THE
ESTUARY IT'S GONNA HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS BOTH DURING
CONSTRUCTION AND IN THE LONG
TERM FOR COMMUNITIES IN THE
DELTA. AND IT DOESN'T REALLY
IMPROVE WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S THAT
REALLY HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED IS
THAT. THE STATE WATER PROJECTS
AT LEAST THE STATE WATER PROJECT
CONTRACTORS HAVE BEEN INFORMING
THEM MEMBER AGENCIES THAT THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO PAY FOR
THE PROJECT OR TO TRANSFER SOME
OF THEIR WATER AWAY TO ANOTHER
CONTRACTOR WHO'S WILLING TO PAY.
AND WHAT METROPOLITAN HAS BEEN
REPORTING IS THAT THEY ARE IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH KERN COUNTY
WATER AGENCIES AND OTHER
CONTRACTORS WHERE WE WOULD SEE
MET PAY MORE. AN ACT COMMUNITIES
GET LESS WATER AND ULTIMATELY
THAT SEEMS REALLY COUNTER
INTUITIVE TO IMPROVING THE
RELIABILITY OF WATER SUPPLIES
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE OPTIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE INTEREST FROM
SAN DIEGO AND LA TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA.
THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
MISTER BRAZIER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MR RIGHT WING.
SO.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE. POLL ALL
ASPECTS OF THIS PROJECT. BUT WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO GET NECESSARY. PERMITS
IF.
.
THE DETERMINATION ON LAWSUITS
GOING ON.
FOR ALL THESE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
ARE GONNA BE SUING THIS PROJECT.
THAT TIME FRAME AND THE
CONSTRUCTION TIME THAT YOU
ANTICIPATE.
WHEN YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU COULD
ACTUALLY PRODUCE ONE DROP OF
WATER TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ALL PROJECTS TAKE TIME PROTECT
WATER PROJECTS I MEAN IF WE TOOK
THE ANALYSIS THAT IT PROJECT
MIGHT TAKE A DECADE TO DO WE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BUILT
ANYTHING MUCH ABOUT WOULD NEVER
BUILT THE COLORADO RIVER
AQUEDUCT IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES. WE WOULD NOT PARTNERED
WITH GOVERNOR PAT BROWN TO BUILD
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES THIS PROJECT AS
LINK THINK. IT'S TWELVE IT'S
GONNA BE ABOUT A TWELVE YEAR
CYCLE TO GET THIS ONLINE AND UP
AND RUNNING. PERHAPS EVEN A
LITTLE LONER VENDOR STANDARDS
CAN BE LITIGATION THERE HIT
PRETTY HARD TO BUILD ANYTHING IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT MAJOR
LITIGATION THESE DAYS. THIS IS
THE PLACE WE LIVE AND WE BELIEVE
WE NEED TO MODERNIZE THE SYSTEM
IF WE JUST SIT HERE AND STATUS
QUO INSIDE WE CAN'T BUILD
ANYTHING AT THIS TO DIFFICULT.
ARE I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE SUSPECT.
APPRECIATE THAT AND.
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF DOCTOR
JEFFREY MICHAEL FROM YOUR P. YES
SIR COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS I'VE
NEVER SEEN YOUR AGENCY REFUTE.
HIS COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS AND
PROVIDE YOUR OWN THAT SHOWS.
HERB SOMETHING DIFFERENT SO WE
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH DOCTORS
HUNTINGTON ANALYSIS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOCTOR
MICHAELS DID ONE I'M WORKING
WITH RESTORE THE DEALT ANOTHER
GROUPS AND.
WE ALSO USED TO ANNOY ECONOMIST
AT BEACON ECONOMICS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DOCTOR THORNBERG AND
WE ALSO DID OUR OWN IN HOUSE
ANALYSIS.
SO MISTER MICHAELS FOUND IT DID
NOT PASS THE BENEFITS TEST LE
DOCTOR SOUNDING DR THORNBERG AND
OUR OWN STAFF FILLED THE DEAD.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT'S
WHAT OUR BOARD LOOKED AT THOSE
STUDIES AND DECIDED THAT THIS
DID MAKE FINANCIAL SENSE FOR
METROPOLITAN. LOOK AT.
BASED ON OUR PAST
EXPERIENCES WITH THE.
ORVILLE DAM AND.
WATER CONTRACTORS OF.
BEEN REMISS ON MAINTENANCE I
WOULD I GUESS WHO'S BEEN THE
CONCLUSION.
.
WHAT IF THIS PROJECT DESTROYS
THE DELTA?
WHAT IS WHAT IS WHAT IS
METROPOLITANS COMMANDMENT?
THAT AFTER THIS PROJECT IF IT
WAS PUT IN PLACE LIKE THE OTHER
PROJECT THE.
NOW REVERSES THE FLOW OF THE
DELTA.
AND YOU KNOW TO BENEFIT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS
PLAN B.?
IF THIS TURNS THE DELTA IN TO US.
SALTON FORMER.
AND THE ONLY BENEFIT THEN IS
WHAT WE THOUGHT. ALL ALONG VISIT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GOT A GOOD
ONE AND.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AT THE SHAFT
SOMEHOW IT WILL HOW DO WE KNOW.
THAT BECAUSE OF PAST.
EXPERIENCES NOW WITH THE DAMN
REPORT WE HAD IN THE MAINTENANCE
LEVELS BEING VERY VERY LOW.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE THERE?
AS A BACKSTOPS.
IF THIS SCREWS UP THE DELTA.
AND WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE CO
EQUAL GOALS METROPOLITAN WAS AN
ORIGINAL SPONSOR OF THE DELTA
REFORM ACT AND HELPED NEGOTIATE
AND DEVELOP THAT LANGUAGE WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE CO EQUAL
GOALS ARE BOARD ADOPTED THEM.
AND WE PARTNERED WITH AN RTC AND
DEVELOPING THAT LANGUAGE AND
THAT WAS A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
TOOK SERIOUSLY WE BELIEVE THOSE
TWO PIECES OF IT. WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AND ECOSYSTEM
RESTORATION AND WE'VE INVESTED
MONEY IN BOTH AND WE BELIEVE
BOTH HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD.
ON.
YOU KNOW MISTAKES MADE NINETEEN.
ORVILLE WAS BUILT TO THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY AT THE TIME IN
NINETEEN SIXTY.
AND IT FUNCTIONED WELL FOR FIFTY
YEARS IT HAD A IT DID DEVELOP A
CRACK AND THEN IT FELL APART. A
WE HAD ISSUES WITH IT UP
MAINTENANCE WAS TEN MAINTAINED
AT A HIGH LEVEL THAT WAS BUT
THEY WERE YOU KNOW WAS BUILT
WITH NINETEEN SIXTIES TECHNOLOGY.
OF WE BELIEVED AT THE TIME WHEN
THEY DISCUSS THE PERIPHERAL
CANAL THAT THE SMARTEST
TECHNOLOGY WAS TO BUILD A VERY
LARGE AND DROP OFF WATER
THROUGHOUT THE DELTA TO FRESHEN
IT UP. NOW TODAY WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE A MISTAKE BECAUSE IT
WOULD CONFUSE SALMON.
WE LEARN AND WE ADAPT AS WE GO
ALONG WE'RE GOING TO DUST THIS
PROJECT IS THE IS THE PRODUCT OF
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE WE
HAVE TODAY TO MOVE WATER IN A
FISH FRIENDLY RELIABLE MANNER.
PROTECTED FROM SEISMIC.
WORK WITH CLIMATE CHANGE IT IS
THE BEST TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE
TODAY. FIFTY YEARS FROM NOW ARE
WE GONNA BE SAYING I'M WHICH WE
BUILT SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THERE'S
A CHANCE OF THAT ABSOLUTELY AND
THEN WE WILL BE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH EVERYBODY TO DO
THAT.
SO AND AGAIN I THINK ONE OF THE.
FRIGHTENING FACTS OF.
WHEN AN AGENCY GETS IN SO
INVESTED INTO A PROJECT AND HAS.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
IT IN AND WE DO GO INTO A DECADE.
GOD FOR BID DROUGHT.
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A
TENDENCY TO.
GO AFTER.
INDIAN DANGERS SPECIES TO BE
ABLE TO NOW MOVE THEM OUT OF THE
WAY SO THAT MONEY CAN BE SPENT
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD.
PEOPLE BEFORE FANA OR FISH.
OKAY IS AS IT IS KIND OF AN
NOMENCLATURE DOWN THERE.
AND THEN AGAIN.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
GONNA WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
INVESTMENT IN HIS?
CERTAINLY SIR I MEAN I'VE DONE.
SEVERAL BILLS TO PROTECT MY
DELTA.
AND NONE OF THEM GOT AND I HAVE
TO GIVE YOUR AGENCY IN A LOT OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS THE CREDIT. NONE OF
THEM GOT OUT A COMMITTEE BECAUSE
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INFLUENCE.
ON THE DELTA.
AND.
YOU KNOW I USED TO BEYOND
WATERPARKS AWHILE BUT BECAUSE OF
MY STAND TO PROTECT THE DELTA.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE I WAS REMOVED I
AM ASKED TO GET OFF.
AND SO.
AGAIN.
HOW DO WE HAVE ASSURANCES THAT
YOU SPENDING TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON A PROJECT?
THEY THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO
AFTER THE INDIES ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT.
AND AND.
DECIMATE A SPECIES TO PUT.
PEOPLE BEFORE.
ENVIRONMENT
WELL SIR I CAN ASSURE YOU WE
DIDN'T ASK THAT YOU BE TAKEN OFF
THE COMMITTEE EITHER WELL BUT
ABSOLUTELY NOT SO.
I WASN'T TRACKING AND TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST ARE SO. WE
WORKED.
WE WHAT WE WERE COMMITTED TO THE
CO EQUAL GOALS AND THAT IS BOTH
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION AS WELL AS
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY OUR
AGENCY HAS ALWAYS BELIEVED WE
CAN WORK. WITHIN THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT TO MAKE THIS WORK WE
HAVE TO FIND A BALANCE.
WE INVEST IN.
FISH PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE THINK
IT'S IN OUR SELF INTEREST TO
HAVE THE FISH DO BETTER BECAUSE
THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE MORE FLEXIBLY.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENED.
OUR COLORADO RIVER SUPPLIES
FIFTEEN OF THE LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS HAVE BEEN DRY SOME OF THE
DRIEST YEARS IN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED YEARS BASED ON TREE
RINGS ON THE COLORADO RIVER. IN
THE LAST DECADE IN CALIFORNIA
NINE OF THE LAST ELEVEN YEARS
HAVE BEEN TRY AGAIN SOME OF THE
DRIEST YEARS ALMOST FIFTEEN
HUNDRED YEARS. WE'VE GONE
THROUGH UP REALLY DIFFICULT
DROUGHT AND WE HAVE NOT HAD TO
RESORT TO AUSTRALIA OR CAPETOWN
TACTICS TO DELIVER OR WATER OR
DO EMERGENCY CRASH BUILDING.
MAINLY BECAUSE WE PREPARED FOR
THIS AND DONE PRETTY WELL WITH
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
WE'VE RESPECTED THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT WE HAVEN'T RAMROD
THROUGH DO BILLS NOT WHAT
METROPOLITAN HAS NOT BEEN
WORKING AND CONGRESS. ARE SO
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A. MAJOR
GETTING OF THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT.
THERE ARE STILL CHALLENGES NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT THESE ARE TOUGH
TIMES WE ARE GOING THROUGH AN
INCREDIBLY DRY PERIOD AND.
FISHER SUFFERING FARMS ARE
SUFFERING PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
BUT WE'RE MANAGING THROUGH IT
AND WE'RE PROTECTING AND
RESPECTING THOSE LAWS THAT WE
HAVE.
ONE MORE QUESTION PART SO YOU DO
TALK ABOUT THE THE RESTRUCTURING
OF THE LEVEES IN THE DELTA WELL.
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY A LARGE
MAJORITY THE TELCOS
LEVEES ARE SUPPORTED BY
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS
BETTER ON THE HOOKED UP TO
MAINTAIN THOSE LEVEES ON THEIR
OWN IN THE. FARMERS PAY FOR IT
OUT OF THEIR PROFITS
AND SO WE HAD PROP ONE THE THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A SUPPLEMENT
TO THAT I THINK WE STE. TOOK TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FROM MONEY
INSULATED OVER INTO ONE A AS A.
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE A SEVEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AS
HEAD OF THE FIVE BILLION THAT
WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
FINANCED.
.
SO.
YOU KNOW YOU COULDN'T HEAR
AGENCY WENT OUT AND BOUGHT FIVE
ISLANDS OUT IN THE DELTA. ON
THAT WERE FORM FORM COMMUNITIES.
.
YOU KNOW IN AND.
HEAVILY LADEN WITH ARSENIC AND
ALL OF THESE OTHER FARMING.
ISSUES.
AND THEN I HEARD YOU KNOW IT IT
INITIALLY WAS GONNA BE FOR
STORAGE AND DIFFERENT OPTIONS IN
ONE ON.
.
SOME JUST SOME OF THE STUFF THAT
YOU YOU GUYS ARE CLAIMING WE
DON'T HAVE IN PLACE WHERE
WRITTEN RECLAMATION DISTRICTS
HAVE SUBVENTION. ACT IN PLACE A.
SO.
I MEAN.
WHEN WE FIRST SAW.
THE BCP AND ITS INCEPTION WAS
GOING TO BE THIS BIG
CONSERVATION PLAN TO THE FIX
EVERYTHING.
THEN FIGURED OUT YOU COULD
AFFORD IT.
AND THEN SO NOW IT'S JUST ABOUT
THE WATER.
AND NO ONE IS GOING TO BE DONE
TO THE DELTA.
BUT IN CASE IN FACT I REALLY.
I REALLY THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
WHEN I SEE SALINITY BARRIERS
GOING IN PLACE.
WHEN WE HAVE LOW FLOW YEARS.
I DID OF YOURS PUTTING IN PLACE.
AT FALSE RIVER IN AND OLD RIVER.
AND THEY WANT TO PUT HIM IN
STEAMBOAT SLOUGH IN DIFFERENT
POSITIONS.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO DRAIN THE
DELTA.
HIGHER UP IN THE NORTHERN INTAKE
AT CORTLAND.
YOU'RE GONNA DIMINISH SHALL FLOW
AND SELECT IS GONNA COME UP.
AND RECREATION WILL SUFFER
AND BOATING WILL SUFFER IF WE
HAVE TO PUT SALUTE ANY BARRIERS
BECAUSE OF THIS PROJECT.
THESE ARE JUST TRUE FACTS.
AND.
I I REALLY THINK THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO WEIGH IN AND PUT SOME
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
SOME BENCHMARKS AND SOME BASS
LINES.
AND SOME ACTION ITEMS.
BEFORE THIS THING GETS OUT OF
HAND AND AND THAT AND ESTATE
AGENCIES. CREATING. WITH A.
WILL MOVE WATER CONTRACTORS
THEIR OWN PURPOSE.
I THINK THE WE NEED THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS HEARING ALL THREE
OF YOU CHAIRS.
SO THAT WE COULD HAVE A VOICE
AND BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
COLLECTIVELY.
THAT WHAT WE GOAL WE'RE UP IN
SACRAMENTO TO DO SOMETHING AND
THAT'S TO PROTECT ALL.
NOT JUST SOME.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
GO THROUGH HERE CREATE OUR OWN
COST BENEFIT NOW. COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WILL AND WHAT WILL NOT WORK
IN OUR MINDS THAT REPRESENTS THE
PEOPLE?
IT HAS AS IT IS NOW RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
TRAGEDY ABSOLUTE TRAGEDY THAT IF
THIS GOES FORWARD. HELLO.
I HOPE.
BUT I'M NOT HERE.
WHEN THIS THING JUST ABSOLUTELY.
DEVASTATES THE DELTA.
I CAN ENTER.
UP MISTER BINYON MISTER BLOWN
HER GOOD LUCK GO WOULD GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
ACTUALLY WOULD YEAH SINGLY YEAH
IT'S A AND.
NO IT.
APPRECIATED HEARING.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM DISCOVERY
BASED CONCERNS.
.
YEAH I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT.
.
WE DID HAVE A PANELIST BUT ON
PANEL ONE FROM THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO IT.
YOU KNOW PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT
INTO THE CONCERNS THAT HE SHARED.
SO THAT WE DON'T WALK AWAY FROM
PANEL TO IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT. THE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
WOULD BE ABLE TO.
HAVE ANY DIRECTION ABOUT
ECOSYSTEM.
.
IMPACTS AND AND SOUGHT MADAM
JUST WAITED THEY STATED THEY DID
YEAH SO YOU KNOW SO THEY SAY
THAN THE WRITTEN THE FIRST PART.
.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WOULD HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT
NOW GIVEN THAT THESE.
ISSUES HAVE BEEN VOICED.
OR NOT OR YOU'RE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE TO ST PAVE IT MARY
SAY THEY'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
CONTROL THIS AUDIT. AT ARE ARE
YOU ASKING FOR IT WOULDN'T COME
BACK UP. WELL IF I DON'T WANT
THEM TO FEEL AS THOUGH THAT THEY
CAN'T ANSWER TO WHAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO GIVEN THESE MORE
DIRECTED QUESTIONS.
WE WOULD LIKE THEM TO COMPANIES
YOU QUESTIONS MR GREATER.
THERE WERE PLEASE GET OF.
SO BACK BACK UP.
BUT ALREADY SHE LEFT.
SHE LEFT A QUICK.
I'M DIANE RIDDLED WITH THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE DIVISION OF WATER RATES.
AND YES THE BOARD WOULD HAVE
PERMITTING AUTHORITY OVER THE
APPROPRIATE ALL TO FLOW
CRITERION OTHERCONDITIONS ON
THE PROJECT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WOULDN'T BE IMPACTS TO OTHER
LEGAL USERS WATER. OR FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
IN ADDITION TO THE PERMITTING
AUTHORITY THAT THE BOARD HAS
OVER THE WATER FIX GENERALLY WE
ALSO HAVE A. SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT COLLUDED IN THE
DELTA REFORM ACT CONCLUDED
APPROPRIATE DELTA FLOW CRITERIA
AND ANY APPROVAL OF THE WATER
FIX PROJECT.
IN ADDITION TO THE APPROVALS OF
THE BOARD WOULD HAVE TO MAKE IN
ORDER TO PROVE ANY WATER FIX
PROJECT THAT WATER PICKED
PROJECT THAT THE BOARD CAN ALSO
CHOOSE NOT TO PROVE THE PROJECT
IF THE EVIDENCE IN OUR HEARING
RECORD. INDICATES THAT THE
PROJECT CAN BE COMPLETED WITHOUT
HAVING IMPACTS ON OTHER LEGAL
USERS OF WATER OR AND RECENTLY
IMPACTING FISHING ARE FIVE.
SO ASSUMING THE BOARD. THE BOARD
DID APPROVE THE WATER FIX
PROJECT IT WOULD ALSO HAVE
CONTINUING AUTHORITY OVER THE
WATER A PERMITS AND THE CHANGES
TO REVIEW AS NECESSARY.
THE PROJECT OVERTIME
CONTINUALLY.
IN ADDITION.
OTHER PARTIES WOULD ALSO HAVE
AND THE ABILITY TO AYE. SUBMIT
COMPLAINTS OF THEY HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE OPERATIONS OF
THE PROJECT SIMPLY THAT THEY
WERE NOT COMPARTMENTS WITH WATER
RIGHT PERMIT CONDITIONS OR IN
CONFORMANCE WITH THE LAWS
REGARDING PLACED AN UNREASONABLE
USE AND PROTECTION OF BENEFICIAL
USE THAT SO. THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF MECHANISMS BY WHICH THE BOARD
RETAINS CONTINUING AUTHORITY
OVER THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND
SUCH ABOUT A PROJECT WITH THEIR
WITHOUT THE WATER FIX PROJECT
ARM BUT. AND THERE THAT THERE
ARE THE SPECIFIC ARAB ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS BUILT INTO THE
WATER FIX.
.
PROCESS RELATED TO THE ADULTS
REFORM ACT THAT WOULD ALSO PLAY
A PART IN THE PROCESS. OKAY WITH
SO. AND JUSTICE TO SIT BACK SO
ALL THOSE LONG LINES OF MISTER
PATTERSON STE. QUESTIONS EARLIER
THAT YOU WOMEN WE MIGHT BE
SPENDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND IT REALLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO INCREASE THE FLOW ANY
POTENTIALLY.
ALTHOUGH THERE'S A LOT OF WORRY
THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA BUILD TWO
MASSIVE FORTY FEET TUNNELS A
HUNDRED FIFTY FEET BELOW THE
GROUND. YOU'RE GONNA LET THE
WATER FLOW TO THOSE AT THE TO
KIND OF THINGS WE'RE LOOKING AT
CORRECT THE TO FIT THE TO FEARS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE. THEY WOULD
SPEND TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND IT'S NOT GONNA
PRODUCE ONE EXTRA DROP. MBE
YOU'RE GONNA SAY WE'VE BUILT
THESE MASSIVE THINGS WE'VE
INVESTED ALL OF THIS MONEY. FOR
SURE WE NEED TO LET THAT WATER
FLOW.
pSO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS AND THAT.
INSTRUCTION ON THE WATER FIX
IT'S AN AUTHORIZED UNTIL THE
BOARD ISSUES ITS DECISION ON THE
WATER RIGHT CHANGE PETITION SO.
I THINK BUILT INTO THAT PROCESS
IS THE FACT THAT THERE WILL BE
IF THE BOARD WILL IDENTIFY THE
APPROPRIATE DELTA FOKKER TERRY
AND OTHER CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH.
THE PROJECT WOULD BE APPROVED
AND THAT WOULD INFORM THE
DECISION MAKERS ON YOU KNOW
WHETHER. AND UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS THAT MAKE SENSE TO ME
FOR WITH THE PROJECT.
FOR THAT WOULD BE PART OF I
THINK THE CALCULUS AND THE
FURTHER DECISION MAKING ON THE
PROCESS OF THE PROJECT.
SO BE IT. YEAH I THINK YOU GET
MADAM CHAIR I THINK MS RIDDLE
FOR COMING UP IN AND TRIED IN
SOME.
CLARITY ON THE POWERS OF THE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
IN LIGHT OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
AND DIED IN AND JUST REFLECT A
LITTLE BIT ON ON MADAM SHARES
COMMENTS JUST NOW I THINK THAT A
LOT OF ADVOCATES.
COULD SAY I THOUGHT ABOUT MORE
WATER IT'S ABOUT.
SO CERTAINTY THAT A BETTER
SYSTEM WOULD PROVIDE FOR A
HEALTHIER ECOSYSTEM.
.
AND DIE AND THEN OTHERS WOULD
SAY NO NO IT'S MORE ABOUT BE WE
JUST WANT WATER WE DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT THOSE OTHER THINGS
BUT.
I THINK WHAT TIED MY COLLEAGUE
FROM DISCOVERY BAY RAISED WHICH
I THINK IS YOU KNOW THE
NIGHTMARE SCENARIO OF.
WE WE BUILD SOMETHING THAT DOES
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING OF WHAT WE
WANTED IN FACT MAKES THINGS
WORSE. ON.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS ONCE WE
WE SPEND THAT MONEY AND PUT THE
SWITCH AND REALIZE THIS IS
ACTUALLY.
.
HAS NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES ALL
AROUND THAT THE. YOU KNOW ALL
THE BENEFITS ADDED UP DON'T SAT
ADD UP TO MORE OF THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES AND. WHAT WITH THE
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD'S COURSE
OF ACTION BE IN A SITUATION LIKE
THAT?
I THINK THE DECISION REGARDING
THE FUNDING ASPECTS OF THIS
PROJECT WHAT WILL BE CONSIDERED
BY THE STATE WATER BOARD IN ITS
CONSIDERATION OF PUBLIC
INTERESTS OF THE PROJECT SO THAT
IS. PART OF THE HEARING PROCESS
AND PART OF WHAT THE BOARD WILL
DISSIPATE DECIDE UPON A AND
WHETHER TO APPROVE THE PROJECT
OR NOT.
AND I AM AS FAR AS GOING TO LET
YOU DO IT IS I MEAN.
SO ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
CRITERIA THAT THE BOARD IS
ASSESSING THE APPROVAL OF THE
ATWATER FIX CHANGE PETITION
PROJECT ON. IS WHETHER THE
PROJECT IS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST ARE NOT SO IN ADDITION
TO LOOKING AT. POTENTIAL IMPACTS
TO OTHER LEGAL USERS OF WATER
AND IMPACTS DEFICIENT WILDLIFE
THE PORT IS ALSO CONSIDERING
PUBLIC INTEREST CONSIDERATIONS.
THAT'S A FAIRLY BROAD A HUNDRED
SUBJECT MATTER AREA AND THE
BOARD HAS A LIMITED SUBSET. OF
AUTHORITIES WITHIN THAT AREA BUT
THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT IS PART OF THE HEARING
PROCESS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND AND THANKS
MADAM CHAIR FOR FOR REALIZING
THAT I AYE MAYBE MY QUESTION
ISN'T CLEAR ENOUGH. UP LET'S SAY
LET'S BE VERY SPECIFIC THAT
ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS NEVER
MATERIALIZED AND IN FACT IT IS
MORE HARMFUL.
AND I AS WE KNOW IN IN A DROUGHT
YEARS WATER DELIVERIES CAN BE.
STOPPED.
.
WOULD THAT BE RECOURSE FOR THE
WATER AT THE CONTROL BOARD IN
THAT INSTANCE. OR I WOULD THERE
BE OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE
BOARD CONSIDERS.
IN LIGHT OF THE INVESTMENT OR
OTHER BENEFITS.
GIVEN YOU KNOW WE FLIP THE
SWITCH AND IN FACT
MORE FISH ARE DYING AND THE
SYSTEM IS IN A WORSE PLACE IT
WAS PRIOR.
SO ANY APPROVAL OF THE WATER FIX
PROJECT WOULD INCLUDE CONDITIONS
AND ONGOING AUTHORITY OF THE
BOARD TO LOOK AT WHETHER THAT'S
CONDITIONS ARE ADEQUATE TO AVOID
AND REASONABLE IMPACTS DEFICIENT
WILDLIFE AND OTHER LEGAL USERS
WATER. SO IT'S PART OF THAT
PROCESS THAT COULD INVOLVE
LIMITATIONS ON DIVERSIONS OF
WATER INTO FUTURE. CHANGES TO
THE CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THE
PROJECT OF THEM AS APPROVED OR
NOT.
ALSO I THINK IN IT AND WEBER IF
THE BOARD CHIEF OF SUCH TO
APPROVE THE PROJECT IT WOULD
INCLUDE CONDITION THAT WOULD
LOOK AT.
WHETHER OF THE PROJECT IS
ACTUALLY DOING WHAT IT'S
INTENDED TO DO WHICH AND WOULD
INVOLVE SOME SORT OF WOULD
LIKELY INVOLVE SOME SORT OF.
REGULAR REVIEW PROCESS ON THOSE
ISSUES SO AT AGAIN.
NOTHING IS A CERTAIN STONE ONCE
THE BOARD AT APPROVED APPROVED
THE PROJECT THE BOARD HAS THAT
CONTINUED AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
THAT. THE REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO PROTECTIONS. A FISH MY WIFE
AND LEGAL USERS OF WATER ARE IN
PLACE.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD HAS AND
IT'S PROCESS TO ESTABLISH WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVE SEARCH FOR THE
PROTECTION OF.
PITCH TAMALE BENEFICIAL USES AND
OTHER BENEFICIAL USE AND EIGHT
HAS A CONTINUING OBLIGATION TO
REVIEW THOSE REQUIREMENTS ON A
REGULAR BASIS. AND UPDATE THEM
AS NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
REASONABLE PROTECTION OF
BENEFICIAL USE OF AND THAT
REQUIREMENT WOULD EXTEND TO. ALL
WATER USERS IN THE BASIN IN
ADDITION TO THE WATER FIX AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT AND
STATE WATER PROJECT SO. I THINK
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
MECHANISMS IN PLACE THERE BOTH
REQUIRE.
THE BOARD TO LOOK AT THE
REASONABLE PROTECTION BENEFICIAL
USES OVERTIME ADAM AND ALLOW THE
BOARD TO PROVIDE MECHANISMS IN
ORDER TO DO THAT. I THINK YOU
FOR FOR.
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO.
THAT THE POWERS OF THE BOARD A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE
TALKING AT THE NEW TUNNELS
HETHER OR NOT IT WOULD PROVIDE
MORE WATER THAN IT DID IN THE
PAST IF THERE WERE TWO OF THE
TUNNELS OR A BIGGER TITLE
MECHANISM.
ON ONE HAND SAYING IN HIGH WATER
EVENTS WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE WHAT IS EXTRA.
IT MORE THAN WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENT NEEDS.
AND IN LOW WATER EVENTS TRUSTING
THAT THAT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE
PLACE.
AND DIED IN SO.
HOW HOW?
QUICK IS THAT DECISION MAKING IN
IN UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO CAPTURE MORE WHEN THOSE
THINGS TAKE PLACE. AND A AND
WHAT IS THE.
KIND OF THE OF THE VERIFICATION
OUR VALIDATION THAT THE TRUST
BUILDING COMPONENT TO SAY THAT
IN THE THE LOWER WATER EVENTS
WHERE WE CAN'T ACTUALLY.
.
TRANSFER WATER BECAUSE OF THAT
THE ECOSYSTEM.
THAT THAT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE
PLACE HOW DO WE EXPLAIN THAT TO
PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THOSE
ISSUES.
AND IN BOTH INSTANCES WHAT ONCE
YOU DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO CAPTURE MORE
MODERN AND OTHERS TO SAY. NO NO
NO THAT'S THAT'S NOT I MEAN BOTH
BOTH HAVE VALID POINTS.
SO I THINK THOSE ARE THE MAJOR
MAJOR CONSIDERATIONS AND THE
BOARDS ESTABLISHMENT OF
APPROPRIATE DELTA FLOW CRITERIA
FOR THE OPERATIONS OF THE
PROJECTS. WHICH WOULD LOOK AT
ALL OF THOSE ISSUES AND WHAT
FACTOR AND YOU KNOW AND THAT'S A
DECISION THE BOARD HAVE THEM
MADE GETS I CAN'T SPECIFICALLY
SPEAK TO. EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WOULD BE REQUIRING AS PART OF
THAT DECISION BUT THE DELTA
REFORM ACT.
IT'S AN OBLIGATION ON THE BOARD
TO ESTABLISH THAT AS CRITERIA IN
ADDITION AS I MENTIONED THAT
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLANNING
PROCESS IN OUR IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS I THINK ARE. ANOTHER
MECHANISM THAT REQUIRE US TO
INCH ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE BENEFICIAL USES
AND MORE. YOU KNOW ENGAGED IN A
PROCESS TO UPDATE THE BAY DELTA
PLAN NOW.
TO ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
BENEFICIAL USES OUT REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE WATER FIX PROJECT.
TAKE PLACE OR NOT AND I THINK
THOSE FLOW OBLIGATIONS THAT COME
OUT OF THAT REVIEW WILL BE
APPLICABLES WHETHER THAT. WATER
FIX PROJECT GOES IT GOES FORWARD
OR NOT AND ADAM ARE CONTINUING
OBLIGATION OF THE POURED INTO
THE FUTURE AND SOMETHING YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE. WE'RE OBLIGATED
TO LOOK AT ON A REGULAR BASIS SO
I I THINK THOSE ARE THE
MECHANISMS THAT YOU KNOW PROVIDE
FOR. THAT THOSE ASSURANCES AND
ALSO UNIT ADS EILEEN SPOKE TO.
THE PORTS PROPHECIES ARE VERY
PUBLIC THE BOARD THOUGH PUBLIC
ALWAYS HAVE THEIR.
TO COMMENT AND PUBLIC FORUMS
BEFORE THE BOARD MEMBER SO.
I THINK FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE
EVERYTHING CONCERNS BEFORE THE
BOARD THE BOARD ITS UNIQUELY AND.
FISH AND TO PROVIDE FOR THAT
PUBLIC IN PLAY AND HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC IF THEY HAVE CONCERNS
REGARDING OUR PROJECT AND HOW
IT'S BEING OPERATED. WHAT
SPECIFICALLY IS THE CRITERIA
GOING TO BE DEVELOPED?
THE CRITERIA WOULD BE PART OF
THE DECISION THAT THE PORT
ISSUES ON THE WATER RIGHT CHANGE
PETITION. AND ALSO CONDITIONS
WOULD LIKELY BE INCLUDED IT
WOULD ALSO BE INCLUDED AND THE
BOARDS.
ISSUANCE OF A WATER QUALITY
CERTIFICATION FOR THE PROJECT IF
THE BOARD.
CHOOSES TO APPROVE THE PROJECT
SO. THOSE CONDITIONS WOULD BE
LAID OUT IN THE A DRAFT ORDER
THAT IT'S RELEASED FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT.
THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE THAT
ORDER BEFORE THE BOARD'S
CONSIDERATION OF ADOPTION OF THE
ORDER. ONCE THE BOARD ADOPTED
THE ORDER OF THE PUBLIC IN THAT
AND OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES
WOULD ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR TIME MINOR DAY THAT
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN KNOW
THAT. THEIR SUPPORT HAS NOT YET
DETERMINED WHEN THAT PROCESS
WILL BE COMPLETE. A IT DEPENDS
ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FACTORS
INCLUDING AT GWR'S COMPLETION
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTATION FOR THE PROJECT.
AYE AND THE ADDITION OF THE
INFORMATION THAT'S COMING OUT OF
THE HEARING PROCESS THAT WERE IN
THE MIDST OF A HEARING PROCESS
RIGHT NOW. WHERE I AM WE'VE
COMPLETED THE FIRST PART OF THE
HEARING WHICH FOCUSES ON OTHER
WE WILL USERS OF WATER WE MAY
NEED TO REVISIT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES? IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
REALIGNMENT THAT YOU GET YOUR IS
CONTEMPLATING.
WERE PART WAY THROUGH PART TWO
OF THE HEARING WHICH IS FOCUSED
ON FISH AND WILDLIFE ADMIN
APPROPRIATE DELTA FLOW CRITERIA.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW THE PRODUCT
THE HEARING PROCESS THAT STE
STILL TAKING PLACE MONTHLY HARRY
RECORD. CLOSES THEN THE BOARD
NEEDS TO TAKE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT IT HURT DURING
THE HEARING PROCESS ASSESSMENT
INFORMATION. AND DEVELOP A DRAFT
ORDER SO THAT HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO.
TO COMPLETE THAT PROCESS REALLY
DEPEND.
ON THE VOLUME AND COMPLEXITY OF
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THE
HEARING RECORD OF WHICH IF IT'S
FAIRLY COMPLEX
AND SLIMNESS SO I THINK SO LIKE
IN THIS DECADE HER. NEXT DECADE.
BUT WHAT WHAT EXACTLY I THINK
THE BOARD IF IT IS DEFINITELY
COMMITTED TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
WORKING THROUGH THIS PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT.
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE TO KNOW
WHETHER THIS PROPHET WHETHER
IT'S PROJECTS GOING TO BE
APPROVED OR NOT AND IF IT'S
APPROVED UNDER WHAT. CONDITIONS
SO I CAN'T COMMIT TO YOUR
SPECIFIC TIMEFRAME BUT IT IS.
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO AN
EXPEDITIOUS PROPHETS FOR THOSE
REASONS.
THE MISTER WILL.
THANK GOODNESS EGGMAN.
I HAVE TO RUN SO.
RATHER THAN ASK QUESTIONS I'M
JUST GONNA AT A COUPLE OF
THOUGHT OF OF COMMENTS AND TO.
AND MAY BE ABLE TO COME BACK IN
TIME FOR THE END OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I WHICH I REALLY WOULD
APPRECIATE HEARING.
OF.
I THINK ONE THING THAT THAT'S
BECOME AMPLY CLEAR AS RESULT OF
THIS HEARING. AND AND THAT I
ALLUDED TO IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS IS THAT OF THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK REALLY NEEDS
TO TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
THE. PROVIDING REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT TO OF THIS PROPOSAL.
I'M EXPAND A. OF AND IT'S BEEN A
PRETTY MUCH COMPLETE LACK OF THE
UP AND UP UNTIL THIS POINT AND I
SAY THAT NOT ONLY IS THE CHAIR
OF BUDGETS UP THREE WHERE. OF
THE OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
SOMETHING OF THIS NATURE WOULD
TRADITIONALLY LIVE BUT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES SANTA MONICA
AND OTHER PARTS OF FOR. THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT THAT
THAT I REPRESENT I WOULD TO A
POINT OUT THAT THE.
OF THE THE THE VOTE ATTA AT THE
MET WAS FAR FROM UNANIMOUS.
AT A IN FACT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
A WAS SIR.
FULLY OPPOSED TO THE.
TO THE RECENT VOTE TO APPROVE
IN THE FINANCING BECAUSE OF A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE.
.
A OF OF THE PROGRAM I WAS STRUCK
BY.
A A COMMENT.
.
A DURING THE TESTIMONY THAT.
SEEM TO ME TO SET OUT SORT OF A
ZERO SUM GAME WE EITHER APPROVE
THE TWIN TUNNELS. OR.
FOR MATT ANYWAY WE HAVE TO HAVE
A FIND A WAY TO REPLACE THE
ENTIRETY OF THE THIRTY PERCENT
THAT A IS CURRENTLY. A A A A A
COMING FROM. FROM THIS AREA. AND
THAT'S CLEARLY NOT THE CASE
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS.
I'M NOT AT A POINT RIGHT NOW
WHERE I CAN SAY THAT THOSE OTHER
OPTIONS HAVE BEEN. ADEQUATELY.
LOOKED AT AND WHETHER OR NOT
SOME MIX OF.
.
THE STATUS QUO RECYCLING STORM
WATER DIVERSION.
IS THE THE PROPER SOLUTION I'M
INCLINED TO THINK THAT IT IS I
THINK WE HAVE TO MOVE THAT
DIRECTION. ANYWAY.
I DO HAVE TO SAY THIS BUT A LOT
OF COMMENTS ABOUT. A HOW MUCH.
OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD COST AND
HOW MUCH UNCERTAINTY THERE IS.
AND IF WE'RE GONNA MOVE AS IT I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD IN THE
DIRECTION OF RECYCLING AND STORM
WATER DIVERSION ANOTHER.
.
FORWARD THINKING WAYS OF OF
DEALING WITH OUR WATER ISSUES.
OF IT'S GOING TO COST US A LOT
OF MONEY SO DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE WE SHOULD BE
PREPARED TO SPEND MONEY ON THIS
ISSUE.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THAT WILL
COME OF IT BUT TO IT'S GOING TO
BE EXPENSIVE.
AND WITH THAT.
THANK YOU FOR DURING THE MEETING
KENTA LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE FIGURE VETERANS FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST ONE
QUESTION OF.
BUT THE WATER CONTROL RESOURCE
BOARD WHO POINTS THE ABOARD.
BUT GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY ó
THANK YOU TO THIS PANEL AND.
WILL NOW GOING TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
BUT I WOULD ASK.
WE'VE HAD.
COUPLE HOURS OF TESTIMONY.
AND I KNOW EVERYBODY CAME TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE THEIR INPUT BUT IF
YOU WOULD.
EITHER NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION.
OR. LESS THAN A MINUTE PLEASE.
LOOK UP A MINUTE.
IS A SONG OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S JACQUELYN
THE MELON AND I'M AN OFFICER TO
RETURN ORGANIZATIONS I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS THEIR LONG TERM SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX.
FOR US WE THINK IT'S A CRITICAL
INVESTMENT AND WERE MODERNIZE
OUR STATE WATER DELIVERY SYSTEM
ENSURING CHRIS RELIABILITY.
FIRST I'M REPRESENTING VIKA BIKE
IS THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS
THROUGHOUT THE GREATER SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AREA. AND ACROSS
LA COUNTY. I ALSO REPRESENT THE
SITA THIS IS THE VENTURA COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
AND IT PROVIDES EDUCATION AND
POLICY GUIDANCE ON ISSUES THAT
AFFECT THE ECONOMIC HEALTH AND
VITALITY THE REASON.
FOR NEARLY TEN YEARS BOTH OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN SUPPORT OF THE CO
EQUAL GOALS. AS ESTABLISHED BY
THE BILL BAY DELTA BLUE RIBBON
TASK FORCE.
IT'S BEEN A LONG JOURNEY. IT'S
BEEN A CLAP OF ONE AMONG MANY
STAKEHOLDERS REQUIREMENTS THE
TOUGH SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS POLICY
REVIEW. COUNTLESS PUBLIC
HEARINGS TO ADDRESS THE AT
DELTA'S ECO SYSTEM AND WATER
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES.
IN THE END IT WAS DETERMINED
THAT THE DOLE CONVEYANCE MODEL
WAS A DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JANET WORK
NEED FROM VENTURA COUNTY HERE TO
SUPPORT THAT DELTA WATER FIX.
I EN VICE CHAIR OF TRIUMPH OF
SIGNED A TITIAN DISTRICT AND WE
SUPPLY POTABLE WATER RECYCLED
WATER. AND WASTEWATER PROVIDE
WASTEWATER TREATMENT TO OUR
CUSTOMERS WE ARE DOING A LOT NOW
WITH THE WATER WE RECEIVE FROM
THE DELTA I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE NO GROUND WATER A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF OUR WATER
COMES FROM THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
WE CURRENTLY RECYCLE.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT THIRTY
PERCENT OF THE WATER USED BIO
PARK WATER SERVICE IS RECYCLED
BUT THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH
FOREST'S WE ARE NOW GOING TO DO.
INDIRECT PORTABLE RE USE BECAUSE
WE STILL THIS CHARGE
BETWEEN FOUR AND FIVE THOUSAND
ACRE FEET INTO THE PACIFIC IN
THE WINTER. SO WITH OUR PARTNER
LOS VIRGINIS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT WE WILL BE CREATING
ULTRA PURE WATER. USING THE NEW
STATE RAGS FOR. OUR SURFACE
WATER AUGMENTATION AND THAT WAY
WE CAN USE EVERY SINGLE DROP
SO I AM. TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF
WHY CURIOUSLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I LIKE TO THINK CHAIR EGGMAN IN
THE RESPECTIVE CHAIRS AND VICE
CHAIRS FOR THIS HEARING MY NAME
IS STEVE HERE I A VICE PRESIDENT
WITH THE PARSONS CORPORATION.
PARSONS OF THE CALIFORNIA BASED
INTERNATIONAL ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY. OUR
COMPANY HEADQUARTERS IS IN
PASADENA CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMPANY WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR IN PASADENA.
TODAY WE HAVE OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND A HUNDRED
LOCATIONS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE HAVE OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS PARSONS
HAS BEEN.
AND CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
LARGEST ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION FIRMS. FOCUSING ON
RAIL AND TRANSIT ROAD AND
HIGHWAY BRIDGE AND TUNNEL.
AND AVIATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
PARSONS IS COMMITTED.
SMART AND RESPONSIBLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING AND
FULLY SUPPORTS THE CALIFORNIA
WATER FIX.
WE BELIEVE THE PROJECT PREVENTS
THE PRESENTS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
RESPONSIBLE INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING TO MODERNIZE OUR STATES
WATER SYSTEM. IN A MANNER THAT
IS BENEFICIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ENTIRE ECONOMY THANK YOU AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
MCDERMOTT ON THE DIRECTOR OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION PUBLIC
OUTREACH WITH LAWS VERSION AS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. WE
SERVE ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THE. CALABASAS
AGORA HILLS AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY.
ARM.
BASICALLY WE RELY ON A PERCENT
ON THE STATE WATER PROJECT TO
MEET OUR CUSTOMERS NEEDS. ONE
THING I REALLY JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE IS THAT WE
ARE ALSO DOING OUR PART AS FAR
AS.
ALL THE CONSERVATION MEASURES
AND WE CANNOT.
LOCAL SOURCES SUCH AS PART OF
OUR REVIEWS.
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH TRIUMPH
OF SAN.
AND.
THE THING THAT THE SIZE YEARS
WITH CALIPHATES IT FOR US IT'S
REALLY ABOUT RELIABILITY.
THE SYSTEM IS NOT RELIABLE RIGHT
NOW AND WE NEED THAT OUR
RELIABILITY. AND TOM.
BUT WE WERE GONNA DO ALL THESE
FANGS.
ARM.
AND BUT WE ALSO NEED HEALTH
CALIPHATES TO TO REALLY GIVE US
THE RELIABILITY THAT WE NEED TO
THE HOUSE THANK YOU THINK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TONY RICE
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
ORGANIZATION OF.
OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
BUSINESSES EMPLOYING NEARLY
COLLECTIVELY A MILLION PEOPLE IN
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
WE ARE VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX FOR ALL
THE REASONS OUT OF BEEN
DISCUSSED.
TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS
THAT EVERYONE IS GIVING TO.
THIS INCREDIBLE PROJECT HOW WE
BELIEVE.
IT WILL PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY
MOVING FOR.
NOT ONLY FOR THE RESIDENTS OF
EVERYONE CAN HAVE QUALITY
DRINKING WATER BUT ALSO CONTINUE
TO FEEL CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC.
ENGINE WE'VE ALREADY WE'VE
WE'VE NETWORK NOW NUMBER FIVE.
ECONOMY IN THE COUNTRY.
IT WE BELIEVE THAT.
STABILIZING CALIFORNIA'S WATER
FUTURE IS IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THOMAS LOVE GENERAL MANAGER
WITH THE UPPER SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
I DO WANT TO SAY I DO CONCUR
WITH MANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENTS. ABOUT THE
NECESSITY OF OUR CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN WATER RECYCLING
STORM WATER CAPTURE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AND CONSERVATION.
AT THE SAME TIME IN OUR REGION
WITH OUR REGIONAL PARTNERS WE
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL
IN CONSERVATION AND WATER
RECYCLING THERE IS NO LONGER
SUFFICIENT RECYCLED WATER FROM
THE LOCAL WASTE WATER PLANT. TO
MEET ALL THE MAN'S WE HAVE
RECYCLED WATER.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE STOPPING
AND WE ARE CERTAINLY INTERESTED
IN PARTNERING WITH METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT ON THE PROJECT
MISTER CUDDLING OR MENTIONED. TO
BRING WATER FROM THE CARSON
PLANT FIFTY MILES AWAY. TREAT IT
AND BRING IT UP IN OUR AREA TO
HELP A SUSTAIN OUR A RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY.
WITH THAT IN OUR PORTFOLIO WE
ALSO NEED CALIFORNIA WATER FIX
AND OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
THE DISTRICT MANAGEMENT FULLY
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX THANK YOU
THINK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS CARL COLMAN WITH
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY.
FEW PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF SEEING THE
ELEMENTS OF A LONG TERM CAPITAL
PROJECT UNFOLD. I HAPPEN TO BE
ONE OF THEM
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR I TOOK
THE POSITION AS GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE MOJAVE WATER AGENCY.
IN A NEWLY FORMED SPECIAL
DISTRICT
I JOINED THE COMPANY OF THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
THIS WAS A CRITICAL STEP FOR OUR
REGION. IN THE MOJAVE DESERT
RECEIVE LESS THAN SIX INCHES
WATER PER YEAR.
RAINFALL.
FAST FORWARD NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
AND I'M NOW A MEMBER OF THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
YET I FIND MY ROLE HAS NOT
CHANGED MUCH
AS IT RELATES TO THE STATE WATER
PROJECT TODAY I NO LONGER
OVERSEE THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS.
BUT I STILL ADVOCATING. THE
IMPORTANCE OF WATER.
SUSTAINABILITY WHILE TOUTING THE
MERITS OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THEM CHAIR MY NAME IS CRAIG
MILLER ON THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
WERE LOCATED IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WE ARE MET MEMBER AGENCY.
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF COMMENT
TODAY ABOUT.
IN EITHER OR BETWEEN LOCAL
PROJECTS AND THE WATER FIX A ONE
OF A HIGHLIGHT THAT OUR AGENCY
IS NOT ANY EITHER OR WERE
INVESTING IN BOTH VEST HEAVILY
AND STORM WATER CAPTURE WATER
RECLAMATION. BRACKETS DE SALLE
PROJECTS TO EXPAND OUR LOCAL
GROUNDWATER. AND BACK IN TWENTY
TEN A SENSE TWENTY TEN ARC WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS HAVE ACTUALLY REDUCED
THEIR DEMANDS BY FIFTY PERCENT
THROW WATER EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS.
WE STILL ARE RELIANT BY ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR SUPPLY
ON.
FLOWS FROM THE DELTA SO THIS
PROJECT EXTREMELY IMPORTANT US
WERE FULLY SUPPORT OF THE TWIN
TUNNEL PROTEGER.
HELLO CHRISTY FOR A HAM BEHALF
OF THE THREE VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AND I'M HERE
TODAY AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE WATER FIX PROJECT THANK YOU
THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS LOUISE SO TINA I AM VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD FOR THE
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
WE'RE ALL OF WILL LARGEST CITIES
IN SOUTHWESTERN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
WHICH WERE EXPECTED TO GO TO AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEXT
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA FROM
CALEXICO TO READING. AND THE
IMPORTANCE IN US SUPPORT OF JOBS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
IN SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX I FULLY UNDERSTAND. THE NEED
FOR THIS PROJECT OVER THE COURSE
OF LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
CUCAMONGA WE'VE INVESTED OVER
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
UPGRADE OUR LOCAL SUPPLIES.
WE HAVE ADDRESSED ALL THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT MADAM CHAIR WE
NEED THIS PROJECT WERE FIFTY
PERCENT DEPENDENT ON IMPORTED
WATER SUPPLIES. FOR OUR
REPLENISHMENT RA BASIS AND FOR
USE DIRECT USE FOR OUR JOBS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU MOVE
FORWARD IN SUPPORT THIS PROJECT
FOR THE GOOD OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT AFTER THE MEN CHAIRMAN IS
CHARLIE WILL SIGN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CEO OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER COALITION INDUSTRY LABOR. CITIES COUNTIES
WATER AGENCIES AND AGRICULTURE
IS THE SINGLE LARGEST FOCUSED
COALITION ON WATER RELIABILITY
IN THE STATE. WE'VE BEEN IN THIS
ISSUE NOW FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
WE HAVE STUDIED GOING THROUGH A
CONVERSATION AND AS WAS
DISCUSSED HERE THIS IS NOT AN
EITHER OR. ISN'T ALL THE ABOVE
STRATEGY WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE WATER THAT IS DELIVERED THE
MODERNIZATION OF. THE STATE
WATER PROJECT THROUGH THE DELTA.
IT IS IMPORTANT AS A BASE OF
SUPPLY ON WHICH ALL OTHER
ALTERNATIVES CAN THEN TAKE PLACE.
WE ALSO KNOW BASED ON THE
RESEARCH THAT WE'VE DONE BUT ALL
OTHER ALTERNATIVES OR BETWEEN
TWO AND FIFTEEN TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE.
SO WITHOUT THE BASE WE'VE AND
REALLY START JACKING RATES ON
SOME OF OUR CONSUMERS.
WE'VE ALSO DONE SOME PUBLIC
OPINION POLLING WE DON'T SEVENTY
PERCENT CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY
WANT TO SEE THIS MODERNIZE BUT
IN LA COUNTY SPECIFICALLY WE GOT
OVER EIGHTY SIX PERCENT
UNDERSTAND WHAT EXPLAINED TO
THEM THEY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER PATTERSON
JACK WELCOME BEHALF THE KERN
COUNTY WATER AGENCY SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT.
AND SO ON SEVEN OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF WATER FIX
CALLOUS HOURS HAVE BEEN SPENT ON
ANALYSIS IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN SPENT.
IN PUBLIC DEBATE AND REVIEW AND
AT THIS POINT WE'RE WERE VERY
COMMITTED TO MOVING THINGS AHEAD
AND THEN ASK AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. A CONTINUED OVERSIGHT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROJECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANTHONY HERNANDEZ WITH US EACH
TIME HELL IN SUPPORT OF OTHER
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX IMPROVING
THE STATE WATER PROJECT.
WILL PROVIDE OPERATIVE CONTROLS
THAT YOU DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY.
IMPROVE RESILIENCY AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE AS WELL AS
SEISMIC EVENTS SO THAT'S ALWAYS
PART BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN OTHER BUYERS WITH
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE'VE CONDUCTED A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY OF OUR LONG TERM WATER
RELIABILITY. PROVIDING VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO KEY DECISION
MAKERS REGARDING THE FUTURE
ORANGE COUNTY'S WATER SUPPLIES.
CONSIDERING ALL AVAILABLE WATER
SOURCES AND POTENTIAL PROJECTS
ARE STUDY FINDS THE WATER FIX TO
BE THE SINGLE MOST.
COST EFFECTIVE LARGE SCALE WATER
RELIABILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
FOR SOME IN CALIFORNIA. OUTSIDE
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER IN
CONSERVATION. AND THESE EFFORTS
WILL REMAIN OF CRITICAL AND YOU
WILL NOT STOP REMAIN IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROJECT THINKING OF.
I'M SUSAN MULLIGAN GENERAL
MANAGER OF PAGUS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT
SERVING ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN VENTURA
COUNTY JUST SOUTH OF SANTA
BARBARA.
OUR AREA HAS FEW LOCAL WATER
RESOURCES AND MINIMAL ACCESS TO
THE COLORADO RIVER. SO STATE
PROJECT WATER IS OUR IS OUR
LIFEBLOOD WE CAREFULLY REUSE THE
STATE PROJECT WATER WITHIN A
DECADE WE WILL HAVE DEVELOPED
ALL OF OUR RECYCLED WATER AND
WERE USED.
ALL OF IT
BUT EVEN WHEN WE DO.
WILL REMAIN DEPENDENT ON THE
STATE PROJECT FOR THREE FOURTHS
OF OUR SUPPLIES LAST WEEK THE
NEW YORK TIMES REPORTED THE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIES HAS
SURPASSED THE UNITED KINGDOM
BECOME THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST.
BUT IT COULD BE WIPED OUT
INSTANTLY.
AN EARTHQUAKE IN A DELICATE
DELTA COULD RUPTURE LEVEES TURN
THE DELTA INTO AN INLAND SEA.
AND CUT OFF THE PRIMARY SUPPLY
FOR SIXTY PERCENT OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMIC DOES DEVASTATION
WOULD LAST YEAR'S BECAUSE IT
WOULD TAKE YEARS TO RESTORE THE
SUPPLY WE URGE YOU TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND JOBS OF
OUR RESIDENTS. AND SUPPORT WATER
FIX THANK YOU.
TELL LIKE LEVY IMPROVEMENTS IS A
MUST.
MADAM CHAIR FRED MADE ON BEHALF
OF THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALLIANCE OF. VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY TWELVE LOCAL
CHAMBERS IN SUPPORT OF THE WATER
FIX THANK YOU.
BALLERINA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX WE VIEW IT AS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF A TOOL KIT AVAILABLE. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THINK YOU.
PASSAGE OF THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA JUST ONE ECHO THE
POINTS MADE BY A MISS MISS SERVE
WBG FROM AN RTC. WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LONG LASTING MARITAL
IMPACTS THIS PROJECT AND ARE
THEREFORE OPPOSED AND WE DON'T
THINK THE STATE HAS ENOUGH
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WILL GET PROTECTED
AND ADDRESSED.
AND AM ALL THOSE WHAT THESE
WATER AGENCIES ARE DOING ALL
THEY CAN WE THINK THAT THIS IS
STILL SEVENTEEN TO YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH BILLION DOLLARS THAT SHOULD
BE SPENT ON OTHER THINGS THANK
YOU. THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
THANK YOU MORE ATOP ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
WE DO SUPPORT WATER AFFECTS
WINNING THIS IS AN INVESTMENT.
AN INVESTMENT THAT WE ARE
PREPARED TO HELP PAY FOR AND
THAT NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD NOW
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
WE DO APPRECIATE ALL THE TIME
YOU SPENT ON IT THIS MORNING AND.
CONTINUE OUT TO SEE YOUR
OVERSIGHT ON AND APPRECIATE THAT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO HAD
TAKEN.
AND.
OPPOSE POSITION ON WATER FIX MY
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT THAT IS.
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT HAPPENED
AND SO WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A VOTE
IN OPPOSITION BUDGET BUT THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF PUBLIC. I MEAN
JUST FROM THE MEMBERS FROM OUR
APPROACH HIM. AND IN OUR OTHER
HOUSES HAD STRAW WAS REPEATEDLY
SAID THAT SAN DIEGANS DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MATT STONE I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
WATER AGENCY I THINK THE NEWEST
WATER AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA WE
REFORM FROM FOR.
PRIOR AGENCIES WITH THE IDEA OF
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT THE SENATE
CREATIVE VALLEY.
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS A KEY
PART OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WATER RELIABILITY PLANNING
HOWEVER IS NOT THE SOLE SOURCE
WE HAVE LOCAL GROUNDWATER.
RECYCLE WATER THAT WE ARE
PURSUING TO DEVELOP WHICH IS
ALSO DIFFICULT TO PERMIT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOW FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
GROUNDWATER CONJUNCTIVE USE
WATER BANKING AND WE REALLY ARE
TAKING APPROACH IS A NEW AGENCY
OF WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
THE ENTIRE SENATE THREE TWO
RIVER WATERSHED? WHICH EXTENDS
DOWN INTO VENTURA COUNTY IN
AREAS OF OVERDRAFT I THINK WE
ALL BELIEVE THIS IS A KEY
ELEMENT OF THE SOLUTION BUT NOT
THE SOLE SOLUTION AND YOU'LL SEE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN ALL
AREAS AND WITHOUT IT WOULD
INDICATE.
OUR BOARD TOOK A POLICY SUPPORT
POSITION LAST FALL AMPLE THANK
YOU LIKELY PARTICIPATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY* I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE MOB THE WATER AGENCY
LOCATED IN THE HIGH DESERT WE
COVER FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE MILES
PRIMARILY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
THE COMMISSION THAT THE.
THIS ALTERNATE CONVEYANCE
STRUCTURE WAS ENVISIONED IN ON
NINETEEN SIXTY. AT THAT TIME IT
WAS PART OF THE BURNS PORTER ACT
AND WAS LISTED ON THE BALLOT AS
A PROPOSITION ONE THE CALIFORNIA
WATER RESOURCES DEVELOPMENT BOND
ACT.
IT WAS AT THAT TIME SEEN AS A
COMPLETION OF THE ENTIRE STATE
WATER PROJECT AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO REMIND THE COMMISSION. THAT
WE CONCUR WITH THE SENTIMENTS
BACK THEN THOSE THAT SAW THE
NEED FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
CONVEYANCE STRUCTURE. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE TWIN TUNNELS.
THANK YOU
IT RICH AND LATER THE VOTERS
VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY IT DOWN BUT
THINK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THAT ALLOW
SO ON BEHALF OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY UP WE TO
WANT TO SHARE THAT THE AGENCY.
AS A A LARGE PORTFOLIO APPROACH
TO A LOCAL WATERSHED MANAGEMENT.
LOTS OF INVESTMENT RECYCLED
WATER AND CONSERVATION AND AND
CREATIVE WAYS TO.
REUSE LOCAL SUPPLIES.
PART OF THE PORTFOLIO PLUG
APPROACH THAT IS NECESSARY AND
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU MUCH.
HELLO.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I HOPE.
MY NAME IS BARBARA DAILY I LIVE
IN THE DELTA I LIVE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION ZONE WHERE THE
TUNNELS ARE PLANNED TO BE.
BUILT AND WHERE THE INTAKES ARE
PLANNED TO BE BUILT AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY AND MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR. THAT THE PROJECT
WILL DEVASTATE THE DELTA REGION
ITS AGRICULTURE ITS HISTORY ITS
RECREATION ITS ECOSYSTEM. PEOPLE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO LIVE THERE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BREATHE THE
AIR WE WON'T BE ABLE TO TRAVEL
THE ROADS. WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
DRINK THE WATER IF THIS IS TO
SUPPLY A WATER SUPPLY FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS IT'S TAKING AWAY
OUR WATER SUPPLY IT WILL BE
TAINTED.
THE CONSTRUCTION WILL A
DESTROYER WELLS THERE IS A
LITTLE TOWN THERE CALLED LOCK
IT'S A LEGACY COMMUNITY IT'S ON
THE NATIONAL HISTORIC REGISTER.
IT WILL FALL BECAUSE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION THE VIBRATION THE
NOISE AT SAUDARA. AND ALSO WE
RECENTLY LEARNED THROUGH I HAVE
BEEN ATTENDING THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HEARINGS
AND I'VE HEARD. THAT.
THERE ARE MANY GAS WELLS OUT IN
THE DELTA THE IN THE LINE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION THAT COULD.
BE AFFECTED BY THIS WE HAVE
FIREMEN OUR FATHERS AND OUR
BROTHERS.
MIGHT HAVE TO GO INTO THAT I DO
HAVE A HANDOUT IF I MAY TO GIVE
YOU THAT GIVES THE SERGEANTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON PALM A SPECIFIC
FOREST TRUST I JUST REALLY
STRUCK DURING THE TESTIMONY OR
DURING THE DISCUSSION EARLIER. A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE MENTIONED IN
OUR TALK ABOUT BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HERE THERE'S
NO NEW WATER WE'RE JUST
INCREASING THE RELIABILITY OF
MOVING WATER THAT SCENE ALL KIND
OF OUR CURRENT.
AMOUNT IT SEEMS CRAZY TALKING
ABOUT MAKING THESE LEVELS OF
INVESTMENTS WITHOUT ALSO. DOING
MORE CONCERTED RESTORATION WORK
IN OUR UPPER WATERSHEDS
TO TRY AND GET BACK INTO MORE
RESILIENT CONDITION OR WERE LESS
SUBJECT TO LARGE FIRES LURE
OTHER. EVENTS THE CAN DEGRADE
WATER QUALITY BUT ALSO QUITE
LIKELY COMPREHENSIVE RESTORATION
THERE COULD LEAD TO MORE WATER
AVAILABILITY.
SO AND CERTAINLY COULD EXTEND
THE TIMING OF WATER LATER INTO
THE YEAR SO AS WATER IS FLOWING
OUT INTO. JUNE JULY RATHER THAN
ENDING IN MAY THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF MORE WATER
AVAILABILITY SO. I REALLY
ENCOURAGE US TO NOT LOSE TRACK
OF THE FACT THE WATER ACTUALLY
COMES FROM SOMEWHERE AND WE'D
MAKE INVESTMENTS THERE AS WELL.
I THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COM.
MORE ON THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN OUR HEARINGS
NAM.
AND JUST IN CLOSE OVER THANK
EVERYBODY VERY MUCH FOR FOR
COMING FORWARD.
AGAIN THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK ALL OF CALIFORNIA IS
INVESTED IN.
IT AT AND I THINK THAT THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY EVEN I MEAN
FURTHER DEMONSTRATED.
THIS NORTH SOUTH SPLIT.
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
EVERYBODY COMING UP FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TELLING US
THEY WANT THIS PROJECT. EVERYONE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
DESTROY OUR WAY OF LIFE IT'S
GONNA HAVE MASSIVE IMPACTS ON
OUR COMMUNITY ON OUR WATER ON
OUR ENVIRONMENT. A AND ON THE
DELTA AND I KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE. BURKE
FURTHER AGENCIES BUT LIVE IN
THIS AREA.
AND AT AND FEEL THAT AND THERE
ARE SO MANY UNKNOWNS QUESTIONS.
WE KNOW THAT IN.
DO THOUSAND THAT THIRTEEN THE
BAY BRIDGE OPENED A SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
WE AUTHORIZE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION.
WE KNOW THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
VOTERS VOTED FOR.
THAT THIRTY THREE BILLION BOARD
NOW UP TO SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION.
AND WHEN PEOPLE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL I SEE
THE VOTERS VOTED FOR THAT.
THIS PROJECT WE KNOW VOTERS WHEN
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THEY VOTED AGAINST
THE TWIN TUNNEL PROJECT EARLIER.
AND NOW WE'RE BACK WITH JP IS
THAT WE'RE NOT SURE OF THE TERMS
ABOUT.
WITH POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS
WE HAVE UNCERTAIN FINANCES.
THERE IS NO AGAIN W. SKIP SAYING
THERE IS NO NO WATER.
AND THEN WE OTHER COURT
QUESTIONABLY BILLS WILL WORK ON
THIS FOR YEARS YES FOR YEARS
PEOPLE BEEN SAYING WE NEED TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
WHAT ABOUT A WESTERN INTAKE BUT
THEY'RE DIFFERENT THINGS BUT WE
SEEM. HELLBENT.
TO GO DOWN THIS PATH.
WE SAW A PRINT PENDING PERMITS
PENDING LAWSUITS AND WHAT ARE
THE ALTERNATIVES THERE ARE SO
MANY UNKNOWNS QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. WITH VERY FEW ANSWERS WE
STILL DON'T HAVE THE FULL COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
ON WAS STILL HAVE THE FULL
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS WE STILL ARE
NOT UNSURE OF THE FUNDING.
UNSURE OF THE GOVERNMENTS OF THE
GPAS.
AND YET ALL OF A SUDDEN MORE ON
A RACE OUT THE DOOR IT SEEMS
LIKE.
BEFORE THIS ADMINISTRATION'S IS
FINISHED THAT'S BUT IT CERTAINLY
SEEMS LIKE.
.
WE OFTEN TALK TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
PUTTING THINGS ON THE BALLOT TO
TO DIVIDE CALIFORNIA. I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING MORE
DAVIS OF IN THIS PROJECT AS WEAK
AS WE CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT FOR
THE SAKE OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WE COME TOGETHER AND REALLY
LOOK AT WHAT. ARE SOME SOLUTIONS
THAT DON'T DIVIDE US IN THESE
KINDS OF WAYS THAT BECAUSE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FOR WHICH
WE THERE'S NO END IN SIGHT AGAIN
DOES NOT CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL
WATER I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO TO DO OVERSIGHT ON
THIS TOPIC.
AND CONTINUING BUT THE
DISCUSSION GO FORWARD AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ON I THINK EVERYBODY WHO CAME
HERE TODAY TO PARTICIPATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH